aujourd'hui il ya des gros chocs qui
commence ouais c'est clair donc là on
avait trois joueurs à quatre et dix sur
cinq on avait tout d'un niveau
[Rires]
anormal de faire ça direct c'est un coup
bas ça
faisait d'être quelqu'un sabbatique
taper quelqu'un de sympathique mais tu
m'as fait un sale coup d'envoi que
j'aurais pu faire - sita hier vincent je
suis pas en position de le faire mais
maintenant je retiens je retiens c'est
que ses jambes et d'impact a perdu
d'autres premier par paris entre nous
d'ailleurs apparu dans le père du
réglage en a deux en cours lançant je
mène 1 0 il ya deux partis de paris en
cours je suis pas forcément gagnant
colonne en perdant
je suis sûr qu'aujourd'hui ce soir on a
compté et ses stratégies faire ça sera
peut-être moi alors j'ai le pape
extraits de troll en fait j'ai vu
l'appariement enfin c'est vraiment un
dépôt mais poujoulat est pour moi je
sais que duda et la quatrième sur cinq
évidemment c'est mon poulain mais là
comme jeu contre des pauses n'était pas
sûr donc du coup on a je vais avoir 40
scène et duda à quatre et demi sur 5 et
ensuite on a beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs à 405 dont un dépôt qui est vice
champion du monde qui je contrôle tout
da ici donc là du coup on a 1000 après
en partie donc vous amuse obama
quarantaine qui hier je pensais que ce
serait qu'un seul avec les blancs contre
contre duda donc c'est bizarre qui se
joue pas parce carson double c'est
l'histoire de couleurs mais carson
double noiret et java et de diana
pourquoi pas les blancs enfin c'est
assez bizarre donc bon ok de la bonne
raison que vous ne connais pas mais
peut-être qu'il voulait voir car cette
perte dès le début cette fois c'est
quand même pas près d'être très cool de
le faire perdre à partie de la journée
je vous rappelle que duda c'est mon
poulain et bouddha va être un beau du
monde selon moi je vous le rappelle moi
j'ai parié sur un apport à aceh et en
plus c'est beaucoup plus de prise de
risque puisque je vous rappelle que
l'epo il n'a pas forcément été encensé
par la critique qu'il a plutôt été
justement critiqué à tort c'est un
joueur exceptionnel et c'est un joueur
ultra rapide et il va être revanchard et
il va vous montrer de quoi il est
capable lorsque j'ai été très étonné
qu'ils s'écroulent et honnêtement je
pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui font
fausse route et ces doutes ne sais pas
d'où doit qui va être champion mais
n'est peau est avec swat aurore il va
juste faire la figuration picard chef
qui nous fait bien rigoler heureusement
heureusement qui m a fait le pari avec
nous on lui aurait pris tout son argent
n'est ce pas
n'est ce pas il encore il est encore un
peu jeune là nos autoroutes mais mais
bon et picard chasse aussi petit cachet
c'est aussi du coup il ya un peu tendre
voilà c
est ce même génération sans doute c'est
pour ça qu'il parle fumer ça fonctionne
pas comme ça le monde
oui j'ai vu dire et alors j'ai vu la
vidéo en replay la france est à lui à
qui je tire
c'était votre type 4 ce qui veut dire il
a joué contre un bon annoncé on a
annoncé la en annoncer la victoire son
adversaire ça c'est sûr ouais c'est
nationale dames adoption de moins
et bon enfin le mec se promettant de
coûts
moi c'est pas trop aimé l'attitude de
gris sur l'échiquier genre il fait échec
c'est matt prochain coup alors qu'il est
complètement foutu et là il commence à
la limite je la tiens c'est s'est pas
tué mais ouais mais enfin il a mauvaise
réputation pour sa mère dirige
vix ou encore parmi nous le temps mais
je peux comprendre que ce soit pas si
si simple l'histoire c'est à dire tu es
content du coup tu as envie d'être
démonstratif ça peut arriver mais en
fait foi de démonstratif mais pas
irrespectueux c'est un peu ça ouais
c'est un peu ça voilà et c'est ce que je
reproche en fait je reprends cela dit
parce que pour le coup franchement le
mec en face c'était hyper classe hein
t'as vu guitare bien
lundi alors moi j'aurais quitté en
mai mais juste bons à manger perdant ce
mauvais perdants ça me dérange pas mais
mauvais gagnant c'est hyper dérangeant
je suis d'accord avec toi ses fans
nouvelle gagnant ça devrait pas exister
quoi
barbares bixi c'est ça franchement
mérité
le sombre mais on ne laisse pas grand
chose quoi tu vois pas non plus
une trouve dur il trouve dur d'entrée
ouais c'est vrai qu'on ménage pas en
amont à nos cibles 1 mais franchement
pour l'instant dans le cher il ya pis
quatre chefs michel et par mitsou enfin
je veux dire c'est génial quoi tu vois
ça donne envie de ça donne envie d'être
dur quoi tu vois de commencer par an
est ce qu'on regarde un peu les parties
c'est à jour ou pas ou pas boire je sais
pas
on a franchement hier hier c'était
c'était c'était spectaculaire c'était du
haut niveau et carl sénat comme les
c'est parce qu'on aura parié sur lui
donc enfin voila c'est facile on peut en
parler facilement bien sûr mais il a
dégagé une grosse grosse inflation
mondiale est énorme l'impressionnant
carlson hyper propre vraiment ben hammam
contre contre shirov quoi je veux dire à
la pression aux pressions en pressions
sans arrêt c'est vraiment
vraiment impressionnant en club je
montre contre bas qu'est-ce qu'il a été
moins bien moment
45 je n'aime pas sur un vrai
chien aura peut-être après l'ouverture
oui oui c'était pas si limpide que le
saint mais bon ok ça va tu as he may il
n'y a pas eu des avantages réels dans le
jeu ces annonces mais après ton fief
cadre d'un v6 tout ça c'était un peu
bizarre mais en fait trois coups après
il arrive ce programme sera organisée
sur rafa raté un petit peu le coche pour
vraiment avoir la position avantageuse
et au final bien après il amassé fur et
à mesure m'a franchement car c'est très
important
on en profite on en profite en tout cas
pour dire salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoindrons merce merci à tous les
commentaires sympas que l'on a et ça me
fait très plaisir avec stéphane de de
commenter ce grand événement mais en
plus à ces hyper facile a commenté
pascal tout le temps des choses qui se
passent en plus le niveau y perdront
c'est hyper à une approche alors on a eu
des petits soucis hier avec les
techniques au niveau des caméras qui ne
marchait pas et qu est-ce qu homme qui
crache un moment donné quand même deux
fois accroche donc là on a reçu
à trois minutes du lancement de la route
qu'un petit porte on a reçu enfin les
liens pour la nouvelle caméra de la part
de la fidh donc normalement aujourd'hui
au niveau des caméras on n'aura pas de
problème j'espère et oui on sait pas
quand le jour 1 se passe mal le jour 2
c'est juste exceptionnel donc on vous
annonce une journée exceptionnelle c'est
exact et forcément le jour 3 vous
raconte même pas à windows savez tout ça
va être fou c'est vrai le faux et
d'ailleurs j'annonce d'ailleurs j'en
profite salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent il y en a qui sont très
fidèles on vous en remercie je vous
annonce la victoire de kérosène que je
vois je vois pas dans quel monde je
obama peut sortir une être aussi
brillant fait qu'hier il a été vraiment
hyper veilhan et je pense que ce qu'on a
dit c'est que 40 scène hyper stable
c'est sa grande force et je vois va
c'est un génie du jeu génie du jeu qui a
dépassé les 2700 lent donc ça montre
beaucoup de choses il adore le jeu
rapide village il adore le gleeks il est
réputé pour son style créatif et à mon
avis car ce n va être juste stable grâce
à lui aujourd'hui et j'annonce une
victoire de carcenac et noir en syrie
c'est ce qu'on disait il ya un contre
sur la fin c'est le même profil un
même profil qui a bien attaqué à un jeu
un peu fantasque et et compte 400 ça
passe pas trop en fait ce
genre de style tu vois comme battus à
hier il a réussi à bâtir avec le nord
comme je l'avais aussi pronostiqué et là
je peux avec toi je pense que enfin moi
j'ai envie d'annoncer une victoire de 41
avec les noirs contre joe va donc je
vois pas qui est un joueur quand il est
en forme il est très très dangereux donc
hier il a vraiment fait 80 sur cinq
saisons mais quasi parfaite c'était
monstrueux je suis pas sûr qu'il va
garder ce niveau de jeu pendant trois
jours en tout cas ce serait ce qu'un
beau mais mais ça se passe avec carlos
un nouveau guide ont créé des blancs
donc c'est une sorte de semis cela si je
me trompe pas
moins d'une semaine faisant un pion aux
odeurs l'a15 encore nous sommes refusés
tu vois j'ai passé et j'avoue j'ai
regardé mes seins descendre au classique
grande dame refusé et tu vois vous
aux mélomanes j'ai vu ta question
comment progresser je veux atteindre une
leçon et lougheed je fais la tactique et
je bosse deux ouvertures moi le truc si
tu veux progresser aux échecs on lan
parce que là on est donné sur le cas du
lent très clairement il faut jouer comme
un malade et là tout dépend qui n'ont
pas du temps je sais pas qui tu es je
sais pas quel site est actif si tu es
étudiant cité retraités mais
généralement pour avoir une grosse
progression et lola tu parle vraiment du
résultat est vraiment orienté résultat
est pas
progresser aux échecs pour apprendre à
mieux jouer mieux comprendre le jeu
mieux en mieux appréhender vote de
gagner des points vélo m'a déjà tu
commences à jouer comme un malade et je
peux te dire que si tu commences à jouer
là tu pourras faire des progrès sinon
tard aucune chance même en faisant des
progrès techniques en compréhension du
jeu et ses
bas à zéro chance donc faut énormément
de temps pour progresser aux échecs et
c'est pour ça enfin je sais pas moi j'ai
arrêté ans j'avais fait dix ans que je
joue plus trop aux échecs
plus et du coup c'est impossible de
gagner des points à l'os sans jouer très
régulièrement voilà déjà ça c'est dur ce
que je dis mais c'est là c'est la vérité
c'est que la
bête a parlé du bouquin de deux minutes
voilà
savoir que bon les ouvertures c'est ça
fait pas tout surtout avant je sais pas
quel niveau tueur encore un mais mais
moi je recommande toujours de ne pas
travailler d'ouverture quand on débute
pour moi c'est une grosse avoir un
travail plutôt le jeu en lui-même la
tactique tout ça et là les ouvertures
est sympa pour pour plus tard donc après
je sais pas quel est ton niveau mais les
ouvertures sait pas forcément ce qu'ils
recommandaient quand on débute ses
échecs en tout cas si tu veux être 2000
sans fil de voilà tu joues et après en
fait c'est parce que selon nous narre de
travail et les échecs si tu joues pas
c'est fini pour situer juste d'atteindre
un résultat après si tu veux mieux
appréhender le jeu en fait il faut lire
des livres comme chez smith the old
games de pôle gare enfin c'est pas à
lire d'ailleurs ces dépositions a étudié
les livres de cilman sont déjà très bien
en termes de stratégie et là on n'est
pas de soupe du bourg et de ski on est
bien sûr des livres accessibles pour les
joueurs amateurs site est très fort en
tant que joueur amateur c'est à dire au
moins plus de 1800 dans ce cas là je te
conseille
de
travail et le mont livres préférés qui l
école d échec qui sonne très mal parce
que l'école des échecs ça sonne gentille
et on a l'impression c'est un livre qui
est facile et en fait il est écrit a été
écrit par cole koblenz qui était ex
champion de la ss et du coup l'école des
échecs c'est un bouquin de tactique qui
va permettre de trier le calcul et du
coup l'école des échecs c'est juste à
avoir dans sa bibliothèque parce que
c'est un livre prendra du plaisir et tu
vas tu vas beaucoup progressé doc seaman
l'école était déjà pas mal pour démarrer
ok mais romain là on parle de même chose
je suis d'accord les petits lits de
kenan sont sympa très visuel est très
pédago mais là on n'est pas pour 2100 et
l'office lui même et 2100 et nos filles
mais c'est pas c'est pas son objectif il
veut former des joueurs amateurs on va
dire à ogeu de compétition
alors on va peut-être passer un petit
peu au parti à avoir peu ce qui se passe
alors je vous rappelle petit
intermédiaire donc oui kevin et moi on
construit aussi un sou neuf cents
personnes donc on fait beaucoup de
pédagogie entre autres voix par rapport
aux questions du tchad par rapport aux
références de livres etc je vous
conseille d'aller d'aller visiter nos
chaînes alors je vais faire un petit un
petit saut pour
pour kevin il est là stéphane est là sur
l'aspect pub on n'a pas été aussi fort
que ça tu démarres fort au niveau pub
direct non mais on parle de pédagogie
pour la résa donc du coup ben j'en
profite or moi je n'ai pas le droit de
me faire c'est le moment de ce site et
c'est le moment de la cité c'est bon là
ça va être pas la pub pour moi
même si tu es le roi qu'elle aura eu
droit non non c'est pas moi de le faire
le saut le web a fait un saut mais j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient réussi à trouver une
petite part à dos au chômage avaient
utilisé je le sais bien
je vois que vous je vais je prendre la
graine
et les mouvements intéressants un coach
luxe et le pied et mais en fait ce que
je remarque c'est que mes élèves c'est
qu'ils deviennent dépendants du coach et
ça c'est anormal
l'âme au fait ce qu'il faut avoir comme
qu'à la qualité pour devenir un bon
joueur d'échec c'est la curiosité vous
montrez que vous êtes passionnés soit et
soyez curieux et là vous allez faire des
pauses aux échecs la mêlée mais comme 40
cents ou ça ils ont énormément perdu aux
échecs avant de devenir aussi fort
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
personne n'écarte scène il et il est
vraiment le plus talentueux peut-être de
tous les temps mais en tout cas il prend
énormément de plaisir et il se bat au
niveau de sa part actions pour
progresser ce qu'il faut retenir donc
chacun son niveau vous jouer aux échecs
parce que vous aimez ça et du coup il
faut faire énormément d'efforts pour
nourrir votre passion j'ai pas d'autres
conseils à donner
je suis d'accord avec toi en tout cas où
il faut être intéressé parle de 5,1
s'était pas qu'eric de m'intéresser tu
risques pas de progresser en tout cas ça
c'est clair
mais pas trop consommateurs cec vain
puisqu'il y en a beaucoup qui sont
contents parce qu'ils prennent des cours
et ça suffit à soi même je suis pas
d'accord avec cette démarche les courses
et presque annexe est un facilitateur ce
que va vous apporter le coach il va y va
faciliter les choses mais tout le
travail et pour vous c'est vous qui
allez jouer les parties
c'est vous qui allez passer du temps sur
le jeu pour mieux l'appréhender et ça
c'est très difficile et on earth pour ça
aujourd'hui on regarde les grands
champions en à jova joueur fantasque qui
se retrouvent au champion du monde parmi
les tout meilleurs on sait qu'il en est
capable mais ce qui va venir tout on
voit mon petit pari c'est que non
je pense pareil je pense que c'est pas
vrai et table sur sur le long terme sur
trois propositions sur 13 secondes pour
moi c'est pas un joueur qui est stable à
ce niveau là sur une journée un tournoi
où il veut il peut pas de 400 voix que
tout le monde mais mais sur trois a
prouvé sur moi je ne le vois pas réussir
comme ça donc jean luc alphand ça soit
en marquant ce soir est ce qu il a tenue
le jour 2 mais je crois pas mais est ce
que tu veux
aussi à dessau est ce que tu croises un
petit tour des stades à voir un peu ce
qui se passe parce que là on la connaît
la position qu'ils sont en train de
jouer donc je m'isolais donc on a on à
l'epo donc cette partie qui est ré
invente alors du coup alors est ce que
tu veux qu'on voit c'est un petit pari
pour cette partie parce que du coup je
te rappelle on l'avait dit hein on avait
dit qu'on en parlerait pour l'armée
d'israël ouais c'est exact merci de le
rappeler en plus je vois que mes poils
et blanc donc il me dit que j'ai un
petit edge chat un fou stéphane je me
dis bah il a raison il me rappelle il
m'offre une opportunité incroyable
là il faut que j'en profite quoi tu vois
faut que je vois il faut que je prenne
la balle au bond je porte les bateaux
rappelle que j'étais proposé à paris en
étant mené 4 1 par ding donc du banc
bien sûr mais je sais et stéphane dans
la personnalité chez les allemands
talité joly stéphane mais toi tu est
irréprochable à 14 la paix c'est pas
tout ça c'est pour ça que j'espère que
ça va tourner pour moi parce que c'est
seulement la leçon à prendre de chance
il suffit pas d'être irréprochable il
faut aussi se battre ah parce que là je
ne vois la position et je suis plus trop
s'il de fulda ses marques comme le phare
way à un petit lg
mais ça semble déjà l'imposition dès le
départ enfin cook
mais si tu veux si tu veux toi somalie
je vous rappelle allez paris on a parié
sur les joueurs français moi j'ai choisi
mvl et stéphane il a choisi firoud déjà
petit cadeau que j'ai laissées par
contre sur les autres cider parce qu'on
n'a pas à moi de parler et parier sur
canal seine nakamura
stéphanie l'a choisi duda et moi j'ai
choisi la grosse cote n'est pas aux
matches à grosse cote on avait dit on
avait dit qu'on allait aussi parier sur
leurs partis respectifs s'ils jouaient
ensemble et du coup stéphane me le
propose même s'il est vrai que né pour
un petit avantage mais en rapide on sait
que ça veut rien dire en même temps si
ça se vérifie je serai pas malheureux
mais en tout cas c'est en avril 5
secondes pour chaque gros tournois là on
a obligé de faire un pari moins
intéressés on va parier plus modestement
c'est toi qui le déterminent toujours
pareil puisque tu es mettre des sommes
en fait c'est comme ça que je sais que
tu attendais le trésor
j'étais pas envie de voir j'ai pas envie
de forcer à donner je préfère que tu
donnes de toi-même de banques allaient
alors que propose 2
ben oui deux petits seins pour cette
partie alors deux petits sauts pour
cette partie tu vois et bien payés parce
que c'est vrai qu'elle a avancé mais
toute façon une espagnole façon un site
comme ça avec la petite colonne a
ouverte ça sentait que ça allait mal se
passer pour notre ami lula avait deux
façons l'avait déjà on avait dit avant
la partie qu'on ferait comparez donc du
coup ça change rien ça change des
avances à changer tu sais bien le
respect oui
là on voit la position je vais pas faire
le mot la mauvaise langue mais dire ok
j'ai pas envie voilà donc du coup on
fait ça qui ne soit pas la fine bouche
la quine bouchons plus apte à tours 6
on me demande de faire un truc
parce que ouais moi je te demandais
stéphane gentiment de commenter le
placement de ta tour en 1 6
j'espère tu vas pouvoir nous répondre
parce que l'attend je suis
pour que si
elle contrôle la cazelle 6 elle empêche
cavale et fils échec tu vois bon pour
poissons sur toi se faire voir et c'est
tout ça et là l'ordinateur dans nos
canaux qui est juste incroyable
mais en fait il ya un truc il ya un truc
stéphane c'est que pikachu rajoute
vraiment pour t d que
duda joue assez vite c'est vrai que
doute à jouer assez vite il est en train
de dominer n'est pas marquer autant
et ça ça fait plaisir je pense pour toi
parce que c'est un truc d'avoir une
position difficile mais c'est un autre
truc bien longtemps et
comme le souligne pikachu
malheureusement vous aurez compris
l'ironie duda à 4 minutes est né pour
match il a 15 mieux soit comme la
cadence et 15 et 10 secondes par coup
bas il ya autant de temps à arriver au
match ico départ ok bon ok leurs
complices et c'était le coup proposé par
l'ordinateur je vous l'avais pas dit un
vrai cavalier h61 sur 20 prend
qu'avaient les âges s'y sont retouches
sont rois comment je te mangerais et oui
comment je trouve l abandon est
magnifique
c'est très très bien joué et là en fait
l'idée c'est que si j'avais le goût de
madame ben patrick a mangé ses six
enfants ce serait moche quand même
d'empocher d'empocher deux sommes au
bout de même pas une demi heure le
stream
c'est pas
moi moi je pense que de toute façon il y
aura d'autres paris dans la journée
s'est fortement possible quand il
commence comme ça à sa tion d'un
livraison totale quoi je vais te tirer
un truc moi je suis très connu pour pour
parier et pour pour perdre 90 % de paris
mais peut-être plus je me suis très bon
vieux appareils ne prend pas de chance
du tout et médias mais tu aimes ça aller
en avant a dit voilà
certains qui nous regardent vous avez vu
qu'à l'été chaque cd difficile mais vous
aimez ça donc vous insistez et c'est ce
que stéphane fait au niveau des paris et
voilà il vous en scène quelque chose
c'est l'abnégation et c'est important
aux échecs aussi je suis extrêmement
joueur donc donc du coup et c'est bien
là on prend du plaisir à regarder ça
mais effectivement comme dit michel
sapin s'est franchement ça pue
la position las il sait travailler on
peut vraiment aller peut-être faire un
petit intermède sur une autre position
parce que là
j'ai envie de laisser un peu tranquille
alors du coup on aidé par tour en a au
nom vous savez on a à peu près cinq
heures de stream si j'enchaîne stephen
dès le début devant vouloir match qui
oppose et je vais me faire engueuler
parce que des fois au procès il se passe
des trucs 1 vous savez donc multiples
costumes beau c'est que c'est juste la
pub tranquille mais des fois on
s'engueule on dit a dit un truc c'était
les mises machin on n'est pas d'accord
avec le commentaire bonjour une position
c'est un peu incroyable dépend non mais
ok il est trop été trop confiant les
peaux va finir par agacer un coup comme
d'hab alors trop bas andrade est vôtre
aussi on va aller voir on va aller voir
un petit peu les français en retrait de
maxime maxime que vous le dis j'ai envie
que t'as pas envie de trop de temps
avant que vous savez que je suis fervent
défenseur de maxime stéphane mahé
laisser choisir un on va pas se mentir
là dessus aussi j'ai choisi maxime qui a
quand même l'agroscope normalement
avec une pression très compliquées entre
andrei molodkin ouais donc ils sont
comme en ouverture à temps mais là je
pense qu'en fait ça va s'arrêter un jour
parce que je pense ça va comme tout à
l'heure
j'ai pas mis un nom je pense que ça va
aller dans l'ouverture et comme tu vois
j'ai pas la liste des coups ici sur mon
casque je pense que nous faisons et à
l'artiste à jour et qui du coup va voir
la position dans quelques instants pour
l'instant je n'ai pas je vais essayer de
rafraîchir un petit peu la page mais je
vous dis que maxime il est spécialisé
franchetto donc je suis pas inquiet pour
lui il est très créatif la possibilité
très créative apparemment très complexes
tel dessein c'est le début de partie
mais c'est bizarre que de voir reconnu
qu'il ya eu 30 à la parcelle drame
soldat par soldat et regardait ce que
pika chest aux annonces dans le tchat
j'ai peur de lire
stouff high
dolls aurait menti ouais non j'ai
l'impression qu'il a été fort honnête
pikachu et avec deux minutes à la
pendule zehst 15000 tourné peau j'ai
l'impression de ne pouvoir montrer les
muscles en cette deuxième journée aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe par dams
et essai croit à cette dame à la pause à
la tour prend et mat du couloir c'était
la menace un pareil la main tendue de se
prendre le match du couloir pour god ou
da pour démarrer cette journée c'est
assez dur mais attention il peut se
refaire un nom mais
j'ai été honnête hier il aurait dû faire
comme moi cinq sur six nations mais me
l'aï su accrocher une nulle part
je bave à à la dernière ronde et
franchement il marchait sur l'eau hier
par contre avec et noir on a dit les
rapides ça fait très dur et vous voyez
là encore il avoue est exceptionnel
directement ça a été chaud ça a été
chaud et je veux il n'a pas survécu il
n'a pas passé l'ouverture en fait un nom
mais ok vaste encore beaucoup de monde
bon j'ai perdu deux semaines
cmh pattes parce que pathé bâtiment
l'inventa change prouver ce crime là et
en plus il a perdu deux soeurs souffle
lui passe après il nous a et nous a dit
qu'il avait l'habitude de ce genre de
contexte à ou non mais maxime et enfin
maxime il est en train je suis hyper
confiant oh là là maxime il est en train
de sortir une grosse partie comme on les
aime peutrec real déjà final bien que
ouais c'est clair mais je pense qu'ils
doivent plus ou moins à trouver un truc
qui l'a déjà vu dans parce que je joue
très vite
[Musique]
honnêtement je ne sais même pas s'il a
pris 7 milieu donc s'ils connaissaient
parfaitement il y aurait plus de temps
et je pense qu'il est juste très bon et
pour moi vraiment ce que je pense qu'on
va avoir analysé avec maxime joué trois
fois contre lui quand même
j'ai toujours été impressionné à
l'analyse par sa rapidité
ouais il trouve les idées hyper
rapidement par contre en partie lente ce
qui se passe c'est qui les jouent pas
forcément parce que des fois il dit je
ne suis pas sûr mais quand il dit je ne
suis pas sûr et qu'il le joue pour la
partie généralement il a toujours raison
de traîner intuition de ouf sauf que
pendant les parties vérifient principal
des parties d'anti vérifie mais il a
vraiment des capacités calculatoire et
intuitive hors norme passe et on sait
que c'est déjà un des meilleurs joueurs
du monde
en partie réelle mais en termes
d'intuition et de créativité
il fait partie des du top 5 mondial à
chaque fois sur sur ce registre là soit
la créativité au calcul et du coup les
juste exceptionnel donc je crois qu'il
ne connaît pas parfaitement mais qu'il a
juste bien juger les choses avec le
broker cavaliers des cinq des poursuites
et des quatre fous j'ai cinq grosses
initiative et que ça lui plaît il est
pas sûr de lui je pense pas sûr à 100 %
s'il veut mais il s'engouffre de nom
alors qu'en partie lente il aurait
peut-être plus réfléchi on a là
j'aimerais bien avoir son avis sur ce
sujet qu entre en tout cas quand tu vois
un rôle qu'il ya une lutte à la pendue c
ça fait un peu peur qu'un parce que la
position vorias inquiété pour les noirs
milliards et duquesne des pions pour la
qualité il ya un gros ensemble c'est un
super cavale en d5 et aussi comme avant
je développement donc un appel
transition pour la qualité à sacrifier
et surtout une lutte pauvre le kittin
pour terminer la partie donc c'est pas
énorme belle pression aussi en plus de
maxime donc
j'ai envie de donner
peut-être un petit point je pense qu'il
va raser c'est une position qui est
extrêmement difficile à lalimite la
pendule en plus il ya un gros jeu
derrière donc
est ce que van damme est bizarre est ce
qu'on est et la bande entre amis furent
rosa
vous savez que je suis fervent défenseur
de maxime mais il faut aussi
aller voir un peu le poulain de stouff
haut niveau et ferrat on a dit que
s'ouvre à choisy
le superbe soir kéfir où déjà on vous le
rappelle un fil rouge à il a passé les
2800 en lots lent et c'est le plus jeune
joueur il détient un record du plus
jeune joueur à dépasser
cette barre symbolique c'est absolument
énorme voilà on le connaissait un
c'était venu nouveaux ingénieurs mais là
il a dépassé les 2000 de huit ans donc
il est enfin ces voix là il est
maintenant considérée non plus comme un
junior mais un adulte à part entière et
il fait partie des ja du top 5 mondial
pour longtemps je sais qu'il est numéro
deux mondial comme le dit pat mais oui
il va rester numéro dans les zones top 5
pendant très longtemps c'est quasiment
certain voilà c'est quasiment certain je
vois pas comment on va pouvoir le faire
sortir par contre c'est pas dit qu'ils
réussissent à être champion du monde 2
litres et de rapides même s'il est très
doué voilà c'est la petite renault le
plateau et allemands est tellement
et tellement énorme franchement là il ya
eu il ya tout les joueur mondial treize
ans dans ce tournoi tout le monde a
envie un roman de
gagner ce tournoi des champions du monde
et ça va être difficile même si bien sûr
un peu parti favori c'est pas c'est
jamais facile de gagner un tournoi dans
lequel on est favori
et est quand même je marque quelque
chose là on a gagné pendant la parlait
hier qui détient le record du monde 2
parties à la veuve en simultané
c'est un forum est à plus de 2600 mais
c'est pas un grand maître et ligue
mondiale comme comme fer au jeu
aujourd'hui et je remarque au niveau des
ouvertures les joueurs comme carsen des
compagnies choisissent de l'ouverture
assez stables d'où dont fait partie des
monarchies en fait partie les grands
maîtres et vie mondial en termes de
préparation théorique sont très stables
plus ambitieux règles et noir ils
veulent aller mieux faire nul si on leur
propose alors que des joueurs comme
guerre élèves prennent des risques avec
des noirs comme je bats vaya con contre
duda mais ça marche pas très bien
franchement je n'aime pas du tout c'est
un petit peu ce que faisait à rognan
contre dingli rennes je n'ai pas à
commenter le speech à stéphane je passe
te rappelles mais je suis pas du tout
convaincu de cette stratégie avec des
noirs qui a une stratégie un peu bistrot
un pain matters et honnêtement
je constate que ça ne fonctionne pas du
tout pour les joueurs de très haut
niveau ouais flamand tu vois ce qu'il
veut faire a les résultats intéressants
et 2000 cav année en r5
idée en fait un mode d'échangé des
pièces si jamais les noirs manches en
relève cinq cavaliers par exemple je
mange du pion le fou celui que vous
retrouverez enfermé le fossé qui est
quand même la bonne pièce un le bon on
food et noir anormalement dans cette
position et donc ne pas être prises bref
ça qui est roi à schwyz et maintenant
j'ai quatre joueurs renforce le cavalier
en f5 bien 60 comme g6 c'est parce que
s'ils ont reculé alors regardé avec le
centre bloqué maintenant stéphane
préconise la pac allèles puisqu'on dit
ata carell réaction au centre mais j'ai
quand même une question pour toi
naturellement ce que j'aurais joué
excuse moi au stéphane de rebondir sur
son cavalier m5 qui a été joué dans la
partie est ce que je pouvais pas prendre
et jouer aux cartes ce qui m'aurait en
blitz traversé l'esprit même si j'ai
conscience que je joue beaucoup les
cases noires moi j'avais envie avec les
noix ou humainement parlant c'est bien
j'évite de regarder leur dis comme ça je
ne sais pas j'ai envie de faire cavaler
problème ça on prend et écartait mot qui
est la seule option pour moi descente
avec des noirs pour essayer de
chambouler on a dit qu'on est moins bien
on doit les dynamiques jouer dynamics
est chamboulé une position donc je vois
une opportunité donc j'essaie de
l'envoyer directement pour vous et de
vous montrer un peu comment j'aurais lui
la position je me trompe sans doute
parce que j'ai j'ai quand même constater
que l'ordinateur il ne montrait pas ça
mais humainement c'est ce que j'avais
envie de jouer donc je vous le dis je
vous livre comme ça et là je voyais bien
que quatre avec les noirs stéphane
pourrait être compliqué alors dans
l'émission dans l'idée oui bien sûr ça a
l'air intéressant surtout anglet 1 où la
position que cette méthode insolite
c'est fou des cartes c'est les psy par
avaya de galles puis emprise donc
peut-être on défend je sais pas
j'ai envie de faire une liste de nagui
lindland f6 c'est bien sûr une idée en
fait dans l'idée est là j'ai la part de
vous des 4 et comme c'est la paire de
fou
quand la position au moment où va
s'ouvrir les bains normand c'est moi qui
vais qui vivait en bénéficier c'est
tintin cela donc moi mon avis perso
j'aurais envie de faire j'ai quatre et
peut-être grand roque et après peut-être
essayer de voir ce qui se passe d'être
maître une tourangelle un phare g5
attaqué à kung fu en d4 est attaqué sur
la pollution parce qu'au final la
pollution à la cab montage le 4 mai tai
chiem du mal à vraiment progresser en ta
position le fou s'est vite et mal placé
t'as pas trop ces bacs au cours du match
à terme si tu veux c'est étrange
comptait jouer tour vite cavaliers
detroit et jouer les opposer avec ma
conjointe et trouver un petit peu de jeu
avec à 4 x 6 baies 5 je pouvais pas que
c'était si temps même si je sais que
l'ordinateur même pas trop mais je
trouvais que s'il y avait comme c'était
pas si facile et en deux et on nous
annonce on nous annonce que apparemment
maxime vachier lagrave me fait mentir
alors que je le voyais deux mandants la
position contre paulo kittin et
apparemment il aurait gaffé leur égard
on va aller vers ça tout de suite
maxime qui jettent pas des coups encore
c'est très compliqué donc ce n'est pas
encore fait alors j'ai vu il ya michel
hécart porte qui me demandent que
pensez-vous de la vidéo de leurs fans
sur les méthodes aux échecs ou mais pas
la vidéo de la méthode d'ornano et
chaque mois je l' ai beaucoup utilisé de
la méthode de dorval c'est de faire un
bilan avec des critères pour définir les
objectifs d'une position voilà
globalement la méthode d'or dorfman et
du coup ils incitent le joueur qui
al'avantage sur le long terme à être
conservateur et à garder davantage sur
le long terme en améliorant doucettement
sa position alors que le joueur qui est
moins bien il doit normalement jouer
dynamique est chamboulé la coalition
comme je disais tout à l'heure moi pour
mes formations ses fans je me suis
appuyé sur la méthode d'orphan parce que
elle retenait plus ou moins trois
critères j'en ai rajouté un quatrième
avec l'activité des pièces qui est pour
moi un critère important 1 à jauger au
niveau amateur
et du coup tout simplement voilà je
parle en plus de l'activité des pièces
donc on a quatre critères sécurité des
rois rapport au matériel activités des
pièces et structures de pions
et du coup ça nous ça nous invite à
définir qui a l'avantagé pourquoi et à
trouver les objectifs en lien avec le
bilan que l'on a effectué voilà
grossièrement pour ceux qui se demande
un peu ce qui était la méthode hoffman
mais il n'ya pas que dorfman ya beaucoup
de joueurs qui disent on fait un bilan
on trouve l'objectif de la position et
et on trouve nos candidats et ont fait
le choix maintenant ce qui est
intéressant est la méthode d'hoffmann a
cependant tant que qu'entraîneur c'est
que pour moi dormani la vulgariser la
méthode de stratégie pour les joueurs
amateurs et surtout il n'y a pas
énormément de critères à regarder il y
en a que 3 4 comme je le disais
et pour moi c'est une force de partir
partout dans tous les sens et d'avoir
injustement donc de critères limité
et j'ai vu fans que de cela me de coûts
la partie de vaches et qui en difficulté
qui va essayer de carotter volodine
alors excès print et de tactique il a
joué un tour ben
s'il le retrouve
tombe bien ici en fait des gammes ouais
il s'est pris un petit cavale et prend
des quatre facultés section cavale et 3
des 4 6 années je mens journal qu'elle
s'est propagée c'est pas normal et il
vient d'affirmer tout ce que je devrais
tous les commentaires positifs que
j'avais fait sur lui ça c'est
l'équivalent des gaves donné pour rouge
pas du monde sauf que les peaux les a
faits en langue et parce qu'il était
l'ombre de lui même dû à une partie très
difficile qui n'a jamais digéré
là c'est très étonnant faut qu'elles
viennent très calculatoire et je signe
et je persiste à vachier lagrave
c'est franchement une machine de calcul
il est très créatif et l'a oublié une
tactique dans deux gamines haut de gamme
i do place et c'est une tactique est un
matériau ou la bresse à 4-4 prendre
l'avion c'est un problème en conséquent
tous les jours mais bon nous normal mais
lui c'est pas vrai c'est normal et c'est
en blitz à les mythes même en rapide si
je me prends ça je suis pas du tout
content après mois l'ambassadeur s'est
quand même même en pleine fin au mythe
si on n'est pas content on dirait une
orangeraie du voile alors commencé à
moitié pas seulement moi en tout cas
maxime s'est conclue de montréal aurait
dû voir non mais là il veut me faire
mais pareil quoi il doit savoir que j'ai
parié puis
ok ok il ya encore une petite pression
regarde le bénin le kittin à 40 secondes
ça fait un moment qu'il est utile ou sur
l'agrément tout à m trois cavaliers f6
pour sa part ça peut arriver
mais
dams et 4 malheureusement il ya eu on
sait qu'à toujours en l'air ça va être
chaud et de voix à devoir être très très
inventif pour les peut-être tour des 5
et 1 point qui avance ça va être
est ce que tu veux qu'on a eu des
espaces carlson c'est un petit moment
qu'on n'a pas vu car avec plaisir avec
plaisir avec plaisir observé au tournant
et encore vous va pas voir tout le monde
a mais c'est vrai que là on voit des
belles parties fines elles ont vaincu
c'est toujours la même chose
alors l'incroyable donc qu'un seul à
aller noirs ici est en train de cette
technique siéger au bras d'un jeune
employé chez aviva cherpion a passé et
travailler non c'est pas si évident
parce que quand même super g 6 et h67
loi je peux avoir c'est aussi un drogba
va il joue bien dans ce tournoi
franchement
donc j'ai aussi du f4 qui peut arriver
un f4 fou prend ton coin f2 pardon masri
planté un petit coin f2 essayer de ne
pas faire ça ce soir très bon de faire
ça parce qu'au final les pions ici on
locale très très faible c'est parce que
tu penses de cette position je pense que
alors est ce que je peux jouer tour à 3
avait la tour est balancé à 5 à quinta 3
j'ai envie de me faire qu'ils ont passés
à un
problème de gestion quand je m'endors je
te propose un truc sympa je te propose à
oui je voulais jouer g5 mais est ce
qu'il y aurait à chaque mois je joue
j'ai cinq ici je sais pas alors tu veux
la mode de choix parce que je pense que
le pion pas cf c'est pas pareil
c'est plus difficile et c'est toujours à
chaque gr4 et s'enferme on le fout c'est
du rap ok donc largement jeu tu veux ça
ouais papa et mon trou passé et je
n'entends refaire tu sais ce qui va se
passer je vais encore faire tout faux
contours et gagné contre toi mais pas du
tout c'est elle pas du tout mais magnus
n'a battu vous rappeler la rue 1 il a
battu un grand maître géorgien petit
gros match soit mais qui avait une super
partie qu'on magnus et magnus a réussi à
l'enfoncer dans tout concours qu'on sait
match nul mais en pratique stéphane
avait mis en garde et qui ment ce qu'il
a dit stephan s'est produit c'est à dire
que magnus a réussi à faire tourner la
tête du grand mag géorgien et à
s'imposer avec toi pour te tour donc il
ya eu f4 vous prend et que tout prend un
f2 avec menace de découverte bien je
vais aussi menace est donc là pour congé
si ça va pouvoir se jouer je pense parce
qu'il ya pas de découvrir et mettre en
danger ça et après j'ai pu avoir une
découverte mais je parle surtout aux
trois échecs eh ben je fais roi g3 et je
défends le fou en fait non cadres donc
la découverte marche pas vraiment
là moi je sens que magnus en danger dans
cette partie 1
après ça ne s'accroît pas en danger je
vous le dis et je vous le dis je vous le
dit jean firme ce qu'a dit stefan haukur
c'est nul c'est fou j'ai cinq ans
inconnu lé nom n'est pas en danger mais
il est en danger pas gagné allez je
t'accorde ça que cheyrou jours
parce que là on voit la caméra on voit
un petit peu ce qui se passe mais je
crois que il ya dû avoir un h ça qu'ici
de la part de carlson pourquoi pas une
tour là et j'ai ma combi short ou
bien vous défendez 5 mai à chaque tour
ainsi j'avais pas compris comment ma vie
j'avais continué à je m'en excuse en
rangée trois ans peut-être qu'ils
veulent juste manger ici un échec 3-3 et
moins jeunes stegall on a un pion chacun
et plus et mieux quoi moment fait c'est
nul partout peut-être et il veut s est
qu'ils jouent encore je m'arrange je
pense pas mais avec plus de temps il ya
eu çà et là je crois que cette position
c à c
quinzaine de jouer je me trouvais pas
pris trop de risque d'ailleurs comme tu
le signifier quand je narguer tes fans
et même peut-être c'est plus facile à
jouer pour les blancs
alors voilà tour avec un petit peu un
peu l'enfer mais ça peut ça peut en fait
j'aimerais m'accuse et accuse marc ça
peut être pas mal parce que là on voit
que la tour bon pour sortir il faut
qu'elle fasse plusieurs coups oui sort
si gta iv tu fais à quatre c'est pas
beau oui c'est ça parce qu'à 4 à 5 ça
marche pas ouais je vais manger du
combat de la tourelle à un peu enfermé
et et tu vois si jamais j'arrive activé
quand même ça par exemple la torah juste
incroyable parce que je me suis dit si
tu le sais faire que ça pouvait jamais
être mieux pour les noirs au pire j'ai
tout raté leur bateau allez je vais me
rappelle que quand m il faut que je m
il faut pour nous un peu de votre
ordinateur et je pense et si tu veux
stéphane que tu allais me dire qu'il
fallait que tu lances une pub parce que
attention n'a pas dansé recul début
hayatou pulpeux d'être en fait danser
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure on m'a
demandé
c'est ascom qui m'a envoyé un mail
pendant que j'étais là pour me dire de
bmv elle a perdu c'est signé mais pic à
l'aise avec les nouvelles terribles la
barre d'évaluation ici donc du coup il
faut que je vais être le truc ici ok
donc on va voir elle a perdu toutes
signées
[Musique]
attends là j'ai pas la position encore
l'accueil des six
c'est pas beau
comment la voilà ok
c'est pikachu la nonciature du mal et
c'est très très bien défini
terrible pour moi cet après
franchement la partie très propre de
dépôt et les deux secondes branger là ça
me fait très mal comme un ange blond de
la mort l'a laissé prix là c'est
vraiment c'est le fossat qui arrive en
plus
très grosse cote souffert parce qu on de
mêmes réel avec les plans coups de
volants kaki à un grand maître de renom
mais qui est un plus sur la fin quand
même la wii sur une erreur tactique mais
doit pas faire parce que comme tu dis
pas franchement c'est une erreur
tactique de bas étage et franchement je
venais d'annoncer que c'était une super
calculette mondiale quoi donc du coup
soit c'est moi qui me trompe sociaux
nouvelle qui s'est trompé et là pour le
coup
clairement clairement
ce qu'il a fait ça arrive à tout mon
parcours c'est du rapide c'est du bliss
ce fait elle refait tous beaucoup plus
régulièrement je suis un des gars ça
arrive à tout le monde ok il a voulu v
vulgariser le jeu comme nous mais mais
je suivrai avec un autre propos aïe aïe
aïe ascom a planté les gars aïe aïe aïe
bon en plus c'est pas très grave c'est
le temps de la pub donc les gars devront
en faire des passes de pub et c'est ça
que justement il met la pub pourquoi
voilà on est forcé de partir en bus
façon alors on vous dit à tous dessus
que je vous mets la petite
narbonne charrs et
voilà donc sucre
la sueur
alerter
et
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
pas
non mais de retour alors justement les
oies 47 et je bavarde qui fournit un
instant devant nous et par les grosses
parties encore de chômage ne voyait pas
du tout sorti une aussi grosse partie et
il a été encore réjoui un niveau bas ils
jouent élite mondiale
quand il craque pas comme vous avez
annoncé
frais j'ai dit qu'il finirait par la
journée un ca sion dès qu'il va faire
une partie va s'écrouler v il faut il
faut qu'ils perdent une partie
et ce qui me fait un peu mal c'est que
barbe x avait avait annoncé
l annoncé annuler
ouais après il a pris un risque énorme
sur une partie avec les blancs est
revenu c'est pas non plus wen s'est pas
non plus pour le pronostiqueur de
l'année voila voila et par x ou
d'ailleurs nous montre avec un
commentaire comme ça en fait je suis
juste un génie il avait payé il a
commenté derek dédierai
voilà il a directement de
ça fait bizarre de le voir avec souhaité
modéré
bien c'est super très bien de modérés
comme ça va vxo ça paraît normal et
emmanuel un qui nous dit que voilà il
supporte à fond jours avant
manches et j'ai quand même petite
anecdote sur surge obama
enfin le premier de juin 2007 sans que
j'aie joué c'était je veux avoir
justement à l'époque je jouais des caps
avec les blancs et tu sais on en a parlé
hier il joue là car aucun jeu va voir et
discuter avec mes collègues des matchs
et cornaque jean-pierre l'euro et et
axel de l'or mais je leur disais voici
joue au qatar open
si je joue s'ils jouent solides avec les
blanches c'est quand même dur pour le
maître de penser quoi y'a boîte 2007
semble donc bien sûr stéphane ggg testa
et les mêmes bureaux étaient quand même
pas chez bon côté m ok c'est bien un bon
mec et 2007 tu vas voir ça vas-y toi et
en fait il se trouve que pour mon
premier 2720 ça c'est hyper bien passé
c'est à dire que je vais avoir pu faire
qu'une seule menace et j'ai pas pris non
plus faire le mode afin ces panneaux
mais j'ai fait nul assez facilement et
les mecs du coup il se déverse sur le
soir chanter un petit peu tu vois c'est
normal ça va
et du fou ou alors moi je vous dis tout
bouffer je me suis retombé
sur terre assez facilement avec to golf
qui n'ont pas fait de cadeaux avec les
noirs c'est pas pareil mais avec les
blancs c'est vrai que quand on fait pas
beaucoup de bêtises aux échecs on peut
si l'adversaire joue pas une position
trop déséquilibré
c'est dur franchement c'est dur
franchement
non mais marmite sonneurs xo mais attend
la dernière fois qu'on a joué ensemble
avec leur big sue c'est quoi j'espère
que c'est pas la forge les mines tours
en achat alors que j'avais les noirs
quoi en plein milieu de je vois pas ce
que c'était
j'espère que c'est pas cette partie
j'espère que c'est pas ces deux parties
va remix ou tu me dis si on a joué
depuis
ouais ouais je joue c'est dommage que
j'ai pas la technique nous pourrait la
mettre à une pause la partie en replay
pas à faire sa prédiction est ce que
c'est ce que la parité un peu de temps
l'impôt turning tables j'aime à paul
jeune mais c'est vrai que c'était en
main le jeune tour qui arrive en achat
avec les noirs dans une petit robe on a
l'impression que j'avais rock et du
mauvais côté quoi enfin c'est au rock
téléporter ski à 5 est ce qu'on fait le
petit point sur les scores du couple
direction discutent mais alors pas du
tout la journée une barrique souvent à
s'en sortir on a un trop démagogue
marrante ça fait un bout que l'on voit
pas l'argent des partis alors le score
un américain gagne
alors je calme vous vous donnez le
luron lagravenese tous les
que va chier en fait qu'il faut revoir
le pied à l'étrier man là donc là vous
avez le classement à jour
jobard années à venir peut-être donc là
on a fair use jacky à qui a rejoint le
groupe de tête un tueur aux maquis et
qui est en tête donc peut-être un veau
voir un petit bureau jacques carten
serait quand même très très beau
donc on a sept joueurs à 5.6 donc née
peau ton petit poulain
bal auquel j'avais plaisir
vient en tête je vois pas bien à 40
cents à 91 est ce qu'ils voyaient dépôt
devant rien n'évolue
donc l'époque assène je bave a fait de
ces gaz on n'avait pas encore vu ainsi
que la non oui c'est vrai que j'aime
dans le classement mais on n'a pas quant
à elle est en tout cas on n'a pas parlé
du tout de ces gaffes firouz janet sur
l'autre français korobov et great shoot
à cinq points sur six donc c'est à
catherine nuit on a une on a pas mal de
joueurs donc on a on a guéri on à duda
n'a qu'à moi vant forez vos login kawana
hovanessian gars comme encore d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'autres on n'a pas tous les
démontrer maxime du coup il a perdu donc
il y avait trois et demi je me trompe le
bien et la trois et demi maintenant sur
six donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est et résoudre vous le
rappelle donc cinq rondes hier 4 on
aujourd'hui car on demain ça démarre
tous les jours à 15 heures
et demain on sera qui est champion du
monde après après la grosse journée
c'est ça il déjà ce soir n'aura on aura
une bonne idée de qui peut être champion
du monde très clairement de la sphère où
on en saura plus donc oui donc là on va
pas soutenu yvonne forest 25 60 ouais il
à 2700 maintenant partie l'un atteint
donc et puis en rapide je pense que
c'est pas lui c'est pas le moins fort de
joueurs de
1740 que c'est hyper dur quand j'ai vu
la mamediarov passé 50e tu vois ça peut
aller très très vite pour les joueurs
qui perdent une partie qui relègue est
très très loin mais en fait date pas de
permis aux vapeurs y avoue ma mère'
loire en fait qu'ils n'ont pas beaucoup
joué f1 qui ont pas beaucoup je de
rapides surtout dernièrement avec le co
vide avec toi ce qui est passé au café
un genre sous classe et même ses paris 9
26 un sapin savait pas rêver et d'autres
joueurs on a vu hier il y avait un grand
maître indien qui avait 1480 lots
1480 il a battu 2006 à 1080 il était
maître mais peu importe en fait à l'ats
un porte comme qu'il dit stéphane c'est
juste hallucinant les aurais pas peur si
je vais trouver à table et là on a un
ennemi qui à 2100 lots 3 me sur 6 sur 6
3 sur 6 c'est quand même c'est quand
même énorme à ce stade de regarder il a
trois points sur six îles à 1488 et
attention c'est pamiers 488 que vous
avez joué sur quelques points comme
d'autres ne vous inquiétez pas pour ceux
qui jouent dansent être un jeu là je me
dis qu'on a que certains qui sont un
petit peu inquiet peut-être mais ne vous
inquiétez pas là c'est vraiment un cas
spécifique comme dit stepan il n'a pas à
jouer à cette partie et c'est pour cela
qu'il qu'il a tout petits lots voilà
l'un talent de marc big sue ça sent
quand la modération dans le tchat
sous voile a très très bien joué j'ai
très très bien joué alors cessons de
dire combien de
fiction dès qu'on lui laisse une petite
une petite porte tu vois et là attention
je vois que c'est trois derniers
messages d'ailleurs et il a réussi un
véritable coup du chapeau puisque ces
trois derniers messages ont été modérés
voilà voilà comment ça se passe ici et
si sylvain de champlain un petit peu
mais elle est très réservée ne pouvait
pas modérer son message
on est quand même cool c'est pas un
diktat ici et là par contre je sais pas
comment on fait pour
[Musique]
enlever le ban de barix
des balles pendant dix minutes
les fraises mais ses commandes au rôle
qui comprend que tu vas en prison
pendant deux minutes là t'as plus envie
de faire des fautes mais voilà tu as
fait une troupe au support
voilà et puis aussi cigognes tu vois
qu'on va confirmer que que ça lui fait
plaisir vont finalement je pense qu'on
n'a pas choqué tant que ça le monde
n'hésitez pas vous lâcher dans le tchat
toutes proportions gardées évidemment
mais normal vous ne serez pas un vous ne
serez pas banni pendant dix minutes les
bars mix ou c'est un privilégié vient de
se faire un
100 m à exactement comme thil manuel tu
vois finalement tout le monde est assez
d'accord avec ton badin dix minutes et
finalement personne ne souhaite a dit de
nous dans le chat si vous souhaitez que
stéphane trouve la commande qui lui
permettent de faire revenir ma vie d'âge
le fait qu'ils vont être plutôt content
exactement emmanuel exactement ces
formateurs vauban le vxo près clairement
en plus il peut toujours profiter de nos
commentaires je pense tu vois du coup il
a égalé occasion nous nous écrire
et oui petit sondage voix
au sondage qui a été mis en place est-ce
qu'il fallait bannir en 2000 babx ou
pour ses propos envers en plus à charge
contre stéphane contre stouff
épicé cigognes elle dit webb arbitre de
l'eau dans son vin ça va pas trop hein
du coup on est assez content de ces un
grand bal que tu que tu as réussi
alors alors du coup on est où
on n'a toujours pas les tirages
est à prévoir sur les appariements
arriver quand même on n'a qu'à vivre la
reprise de la ronde je pense qu'ils
seront plus chauds qui hier au niveau
grimpent les yers a démarré par la
course aux contours aujourd'hui hier
après on a repris une heure et demie en
a repris à 16h30 la rva quasiment
reprendre à 16 heures c'est top
ça envoie maintenant ouais je pense que
là c'est bien parti va les caméras font
ok on arrête problèmes de jeu j'ai eu un
petit problème de connexion que tu as
l'air avec 16 comme j'étais un petit peu
crash mais met s'est vite revenus et
salades être qu'un peu flûte qui a ri
j'ai franchement c'était les gens n'y a
vu que du feu les femmes et wiz
toutefois la technique tous les jours
franchement elle se débrouille très très
bien et des fois qu'on lui donne pas les
caméras évidemment il peut rien faire si
vous avez vu franchement j'admire hâtive
de son niveau quand je vois le niveau de
stop en technique vraiment je serai
quelqu'un est pour l'instant pour
l'instant je reste à mon niveau je reste
à mon niveau aussi poussif
il reviendra charme son petit magnus
maintenu ce qu'on ne firent où mènera
bien
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs personnes
qui a adoré ce genre de deux petits
ouais de petits matches comme on dit un
petit match de copains mais après 2008
quoi donc facile mais y'a pas facile de
commenter de gérer la régie de dié au
lit tôt tu vois toute façon il va enfin
ce match va avoir lieu quoi
mais oui que à voile et à peu près sept
personnes sur dix sont pour un oui de
bannir barre mme x attention c'est que
pendant 10 minutes je pensais qu'on se
rassemble pour cent mais bon en hausse
sont 10% ça nous convient quand même
sinon on aurait fait revenir on l'aurait
fait revenir c'est sur
seven avait déjà préparés à la commande
mais voilà on est on est comme ça
on est beau joueur et finalement on va
le laisser
banni pendant ces dix petites minutes
non je levais à l'intention de lever à
talonner ah oui je devais attendre vais
mais je crois quand il ya visiblement
les partisans à pour croix qui nous loue
de raincourt je crois que nous vous
donnons
[Rires]
vie comme ça en plus ça il est hyper
boudeur dans la vie
car parce que qu'est ce qu'on pense des
master classes de mme hannafi c'est là
je mets
un fort grands maîtres français des
années 90 que je respecte beaucoup
d'ailleurs j'ai très mauvais résultat
contre lui dernièrement bon je vais
finir par tuer
pour le coup c'est quelqu'un qui
stratégiquement et brillant
qui visait à une certaine époque les
2600 qui se reconvertit un peu vert vers
l'entraînement
je pense qu'il a des contenus très
intéressant
après les pas très expressif donc ça
c'est deux choses
il ya le les contenus pédagogiques qui
sont très bons et après le savoir
pédagogique où je pense qu'il est encore
un petit peu introverti à mon goût mais
après ça dépend des goûts les couleurs
c'est chacun qui voit mais pour être
tout à fait franc c'est au niveau des
contenus j'aime bien et au niveau de les
faire de les transmettre c'est c'est
encore un petit peu différent voilà mon
avis sur le sujet et c'est un grand
spécialiste de la défense française qui
a toujours joué voilà c'est un vieux
nom mais selon se rejoint après chacun à
la base c'était plutôt un joueur
professionnel comme entraîneur
professionnel après la des connaissances
pléthorique sûr
sûr sûr le jeu d'échecs et vit
évidemment
donc là du coup on n'a toujours pas
apparemment les joueurs censés bientôt
nous rejoint et on n'a toujours pas là
sa part est bon donc je vais dans vingt
secondes ils vont tous à paraître
normalement 15 secondes nous
apparaissent tous
mais on n'a toujours pas les appareils
mans en torrent on va avoir bientôt plus
que ça on à l'arbitré dans sa seule la
caméra non
mais pour l arbitre qui se déhanchent
devant nous un me semble-t-il où ses
fans ça c'est celle aux caméras ça moi
je fais pas ça
moi je veux une caméra vous voyez hein
j'ai vraiment le droit aux caméras vip
où je vois larvik se déroulant chez
nous les viiip n'a en outre pas ça c'est
pour
vous partager un petit peu quand même
pour que vous puissiez le joueur
statique mais le déhanché de l'armee
c'est quand même sympa quoi pour moi
c'est important à bâle assez sympa il y
aura guidé hanche - sans arbitre un
petit peu il paraît très pro très bas il
est probable ils sont présents un
médecin
donc les joueurs doivent noter leur
score à la fin de la partie pour ensuite
le donald arbitres c'est plus rapide que
de faire la queue hier j'ai gagné j'ai
gagné j'ai gagné
mais combien de gars de arbitres dans ce
championnat du monde
un bain alors là c'est une crise
humanitaire 4 nages j'espère qu'elle
s'adresse au chat et par mois non c'est
une question que je vous pose est comme
ça je pose pas la question en fait je me
demanderais pour tout le monde pour tout
le monde pour tout le monde il impose
ouais je m'interroge comme savoir
combien d'arbitré du monde rapide parce
qu'il ya combien de joueurs en fait
savoir mme yade dans trois ans devraient
ravir
là je vois
je vois les décomptes et en gardant la
liste
il doit y avoir il doit y avoir
peut-être se passe 500 joueurs à peu
près ça fait 250 échiquier je pense
qu'il doit y avoir une réponse une
vingtaine d'arbitrés
ce sens le mot ratio 1 arbitres pour
adresser chéquier ça me paraît pas de
riz
par exemple cappelle-la-grande qui a des
idées phares aux open français de
l'époque où il ya vraiment beaucoup de
joueurs il y avait à les 500 joueurs à
peu près et on va dire une centaine anus
crise à six mois ht auquel beaucoup de
temps bien voyez pas de mal bonjour
comme de tarbes it et oui on l'a annoncé
elle vous avait été annoncée par à
emmanuel c'est ça
un match à la tête d affiche ça c'est là
je pense qu'on va rester dessus on voit
pas trop bouger cette participation à
varennes le grand format il ya le
champion du monde qui joue contre le
poulain de souffre donc bien sûr
s'enrayer de moulins de ce trophée là ça
peut faire mal bien sûr on va donner les
blancs cassen sources tribales et
dans ces camps sont apparus mangeant que
j'en ai d'autres un mais sont moins
intéressants j'ai pas l'aimer mais pau
j'ai parlé les autres soirs
c'est avec amour a par exemple ça va
arriver ça va arriver c'est arrivé un
petit peu maduda
pouvoir ni siens
il en a pas réellement quand même plus
commun de pour se refaire un petit peu
bon c'est quand même assez 50 c'est
quand même pas rien enfin syrie en face
ils recevaient quand on a le petit à
petit aux rough tu joues contre aronian
avec les noirs donc on va faire
attention un pic à thiès
corobo bridge toute volonté plus car
voilà
peut-être je peux vous le montrer ce
qu'il a réussi par maxi nous en apprend
un peu apparemment pour l'instant
pendant que vous vous dire et après on
entre on partira on verra la caméra donc
là j'ai payé nakamura et parce qu'il
avait gagné la partie tout à l'heure la
gagne et mac à moi
est de 2,20 qui
demandent le classement après six tours
à sache que l'éco-mafia 5.40 y en a cinq
points lancement est ici on a juste
trois secondes voilà il arrive le
classement
sefyu
5.15 efforts assez fort et c'est c'est
vraiment sympa ce convoi honnêtement
c'est très qualitatif
et là on a vu joe barbaro ci qui est
présent j'avais annoncé qu'ils ne
tiendraient pas aller là il a tenu
facilement un sou est facilement contré
us ont grimpé sur
ces kits très qualitatif ce que l'on
voit très très qualitatif n'a qu'un mois
contre anthony carone l'espagnol donc je
trouve que c'est plutôt un bon
apparemment pour une enquête pour la
camorra quand on a créé un très bon
joueur de 1700 m c'est rapide je pense
qu'avec moi vraiment vraiment un edge
la cadence pour rappel ces 15 + 10 1 ne
fait pas
15 se disent dans les 10 secondes par
coup de rajouter et la cadence de basse
et 15 minutes et on a vu que mon poulain
et vos matchs y avait joué contre
bouddha le pô le poulain de souffre et
il n'a quasiment pas dépenser une seule
minute c'est dire l'écart de niveau
qu'il ya eu entre ces deux joueurs sur
une partie évidemment
tu m'as l'air aurait pas à cet
enfermement alors qu'on peut relever
aussi comme la la la la table de on a
and jerry contre son compatriote ventre
reste
donc hyper intéressant et d'ailleurs
j'ai vu un rail il me semble à chaque
fois que je vois dans les les les matchs
contre ces deux joueurs point de forest
il est pas si ridicule contre anish giri
donc
pronostiqué un petit un petit gain
devant le reste c'est partir
être clos piscine demande est ce qu'il
ya des contrôles antidopage stéphane est
ce que
possible et qu'il y en ait mais je suis
pas sûr pourtant là alors les couloirs
du dopage j'ai fait c'est un peu
compliqué
enfin call été arrêtés avant cliquer je
cherche pas que c'est comment je pensais
que tu avais arrêté direct en disant que
les contrôles de aux anti dopage les
échecs c'était juste un peu un peu c'est
au n et on peut dire que ça paraît assez
difficile de se doper
aux échecs
l'amélioration est il y en a eu un il y
en a enfin moi j'ai déjà vu ça oui bien
sûr mais est ce qu'ils se dopent par
rapport aux échecs ou simplement et
qu'il fait des trucs divers et variés
pour améliorer leur qualité de vie ou
non - selon les écoles mais en tout cas
ouais je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient de
produits miracles en tout cas si vous
avez envie de tester de manger du
poisson et de boire du café pour vous
améliorer chaque libre à vous mais je
suis ma soeur qui est des des remèdes
miracles
oui bacrot paquereau ne joue pas à quoi
je parle pour mes poupées qui pourrait
on l'a dit les conditions pour jouer il
fallait avoir un elo a plus de 2550 dans
une des formes de jeu blix rapide ou
lent
donc il ya quelques jours deux français
qui pouvaient prétendre à venir faire ce
tournoi là mais à leurs frais
globalement du coup
on
peut imaginer si tu veux car preuve que
maxime soit seconde et par sébastien
mazet puisqu'on a parlé sébastien mazet
va jouer le blitz je l'avais vu
inscrire il ne joue pas le rapide et je
pense qu'il le seconde
je en fait si tu veux parmi les grands
maîtres roi de toute nation il ya des
affinités qui se créent et on peut le
dire sans aucun problème c'est bastien
et maxime s'entendent très bien et du
coup au delà du coaching delà du fait
d'être seconde ans c'est aussi un proche
qui lui permet pas de faire autre chose
que deux échecs et ne pas être dans la
sphère et chicken tout le temps de
pouvoir se détendre parce que sébastien
mazet pour ceux qui le connaissent c'est
quelqu'un qui est grand maître aux
échecs mais qui est aussi très agréable
à vivre
et du coup il passe des bons moments
ensemble en tournoi parce que c'est pas
si évident on se dit bon maxime il est
très fort aux échecs gagne très bien sa
vie il vit de sa passion mais c'est pas
si facile de tout le temps en voyage
donc du coup c'est bien aussi d'avoir
des moments de détente et
voilà il france qu'il fait très bien ce
travail là tout en amenant un conte un
contenu de l'échiquier de qualité parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui est grand maître
mais qu'il ya aussi des oies et qui
accompagne maxime sur le plan égyptien
en terme de préparation disait dans les
ouvertures puisqu'il adore ça les grands
vins de france et max cornette et
sébastien mazet qui sont qui sont second
dans des équipes de france un capitaine
d équipe de france ils ont des
connaissances théoriques très importante
l'amant du coup à prévoir c'est aussi un
c'est un second d'enclos si son patron
et du coup bac + 3 cammas est cool de
bâtisseur
le panier est plus de pouvoir discuter
de pouvoir quelque chose et moi je
trouve ça vraiment intéressant donc du
coup pas et je pense que là il est venu
pour le rapide pour bien sûr
coach et tu veux maxime et l'accompagner
dans ce tome 1 et après le but c'est un
peu différent le coaching d'emblée que
c'est bon c'est un pouvoir exister aussi
mais bon c'est un peu différent basé
jouera le boutis tout cas il est inscrit
pour l'instant pour le blitz et ouais il
ya ya michel qui met un truc marrant
dans
dans le chat souffre ai dit d'après des
tests allemand des années 80 ans
maintenant à 0 2 g d'alcool ont gagné 20
et 50 points elo or déjà faire te dire
stouff michel il est breton voilà ça
c'est un premier un premier truc et en
plus il ya eu un film sur ce sujet
dernièrement alors qu'ils n'étaient pas
en lien direct avec les échecs mais
c'est un film donc on peut trouver c'est
le drague et je vous invite à le voir
michel particulièrement et
et du coup ça traite de sujets là
et c'est un très joli film avec un
acteur danois de renault voilà et
c'est un film comique plutôt plutôt
rigolo voilà il faut pas hésiter à aller
le voir et merci pat situe sur ma chaîne
c'est le top et n'hésite pas à suivre la
chaîne ii se trouve ci s'est pas encore
fait alors c'était peut-être déjà faire
parce que je connais pas il étale je
connais ne
faut pas hésiter en tout cas on n'a pas
fait trop de pub là pour nos chaînes ça
fait un petit moment eh ben n'hésitez
pas à aller voir la chaîne de ce tout et
ma chaîne aussi on est très régulier là
c'est les vacances mais on est quand
même là pour czech com fr mais n'hésitez
pas à venir nous voir ça nous fera un
grand plaisir et on est de plus en plus
nombreux sur nos chaînes respectives
c'est assez logique et on fait beaucoup
de stream pendant les les créneaux
scolaires
n'hésitez pas à regarder des calendriers
sur nos chaînes et du coup on va bientôt
repartir avec les joueurs qui s'installe
et on a dit aussi le la chaîne youtube
de chasse car on nous a dit un touffe de
faire la petite à petit trot pièce parce
qu'il y aura du contenu proposé par tous
comme fr sur youtube donc n'hésitez pas
allez allez suivre la chaîne youtube de
classe comme et
bonjour a bola pour la pousser un très
bon ami à moi maître fide lyonnais tu
dois connaître
il y en a plus y en a trop fait bien et
m'a laissé j'ai fait un coucou c'est le
plus beau et le plus beau et le plus
gros c'est
non à ça je ne peux pas
alors mettre à feel you name
server c'est pas un vrai lyonnais
c'est pas un vrai lieu à nîmes avec ça
je suis bien rendu punaises
et barbouille qui arrivent et ils vont
ils arrêter le long du film et la rate
et lendu le film bat cédric drogue c'est
bourré en anglais ainsi je sais pas si
je suis pas si mauvais donc
on a des vidéos ensemble sur youtube
donc c'est sûr que j'ai vu
je t'avais vu avec avec pierre justement
donc du coup je t'ai vu une autre
personne voilà je pourrais ne pas la
regarder
et oui ils vont exactement et
franchement c'est un film à voir
c'est l'histoire de deux profs des
collèges en fait qui disent qu'un 05
qu'ils auront une vie plus plus sympa et
après ça déconne un petit peu voilà
voila voila semble que la partie haute
est haché
c'était un championnat d'europe jeunes
ça devait être
en plus caries
ou
6 à 7 personnes s'étaient fait chier
dessus par un pigeon pendant qu'il
mangeait
réponse de toujours parce que moi je
n'ai jamais vu ça dépanne
mais attends mais il ya un truc
mais je pensais pas que cette personne
que j'aime beaucoup un beau coup il ya
le seuils à 0,6 mais je pensais pas
qu'il était maître fide en fait
c'est quoi ce signal
je me remette aux échanges et une
impression mais écoute je dirais un truc
après l'été que j'ai passé et bah je
suis passé derrière mu en lots et leur
âge c'est à dire que ça me fait très mal
aux cas j'ai fait moins 100 n'était
passé derrière nous nous battons mais
l'assainissement ou quoi là j'ai perdu
100 kw 110 points et a
été portée combien ce tout faux cela je
suis
c'est pour moi si je coupe maqamat
presque ou maisons d'hôtes est descendu
trop bas la base cote parce que rien
d'écouteurs tu te plains fin tout est en
train de dire que le bo la pelouse
savais pas qu'il était maître fide pas
mal je veux dire non non ma réponse est
c'est un grand même de comptoir grands
maîtres de comptoir c'est un 16-0
problème il
il est pas mauvais
willems et le le temple et comme le
tombeur
de mémoire en fait doux et chacun g4
normes de m et j'avais 2390 donc j'étais
à dix points d'avoir le même titre que
toi tu imagines un petit peu alors là si
j'avais si j'avais mon titre je pense
que la gravité les remettre aux échecs
et mais voilà je perds 110 points là je
suis à l'arrêt complet je suis parti en
vacances je tilt de fou et j'ai même pas
2003 mais bon on en
souffre faut que tu me règle et je vous
rappelle que contre stouff voilà
exactement moi j'avais cité bologne et
la vie et la ola et et et moi je me
souviens donc alors donc ça c'est 2009
où je joue stéphane bré s'accrochant
pilotage expliquer les conditions je les
paie recommanderais pas ici tout se
passait dans
mais je me souviens aussi d'une partie
contre un certain géré tôt
parce qu'on laisse était à calvi aussi
mais c'était un calvaire à ses tracas
liés aussi dans un autre une dans une
autre édition jusqu'en 2011
je n'ai pas fait je n'ai pas fait la
partie de ma vie mais suffisamment
toujours voilà un niveau correct aux
échecs ou wallon de ne pas trop nous en
donne pas de deux pièces bordeaux
adoption on tient juste le stand et une
généralement ça suffit au battre les
futurs maîtres kiffe pas vraiment ça sue
contre un joueur de cet acabit là
généralement pas besoin de faire la
partie de ta vie pour gagner aux échecs
juste ne pas donner ça suffit
généralement
il faut se tirer plus d'une balle dans
le pied et il y en a qui nous disent que
ça a commencé les gars arrêtez de ben
idir et les oiseaux
là thales qui me dit allô allô on y va
il ya eu il ya eu
3 kg pas encore reçu
quelques acquis qui suit bien c'est nous
dit mais pourquoi pas les coûts sur les
chevilles virtuel bas parce que tout ça
soit homme bien intentionné peut on
attend qu'il faut on fait savourer
et oui c'est normal michel faut faire
vivre le stream et il faut se plaindre
un petit peu ça fait chier c'est comme
ça que je vois les choses
là je me suis pas plaint je me suis pas
plaint franchement j'ai pensé cette
belle partie jouait contre un certain
géré tôt
c'est vrai que je pourrais jouer aux
dames aussi j'ai un petit niveau mais là
apparemment le staff qui peut pas faire
bouger le petit dernier ajuste à la main
sur sur les échecs sur les plateaux
plateau de jeu aux échecs
dont la valeur alors on attend et j'en
profite pour dire bonjour à tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent dont et chaque et
raf et tous ceux qui nous sont fidèles
aussi c'est super sympa
non gélives pas reconnaître dans le
petit h3 ouais alors c'est une sorte
qu'ils devraient 4-4-2 gambie d'amway
larmor plage est buggé un sillage trois
rapide c'est ça la regarde la rejeter
complètement sauté ou quoique chaise
comme c'est moi ou il fallait plus à
l'ouvrir
donc
bah ça arrive ça m'arrivait hier aussi
il ya beaucoup de votre chaise comme
donc ça peut ça te fait trop vous êtes
trop
vous êtes trop
et du coup bah tant mieux tant mieux ça
nous fait plaisir mais pour l'instant
c'est pas vrai quad et en fait on a
remarqué chaise comme saute toujours
quand il ya une partie hyper intéressant
je crois que c'est ça qu'on peut dire
ces femmes quand il ya la partie qu'on
attend ils nous ont juste laisser
l'administration quand même ils ont été
sympas avec nos paris ils ont laissé la
partie entre néo peau et duda pour voir
nos poulains
exactement
était bien d'ailleurs cette part tient
franchement super party je vous invite à
voir le replay de cette partie
barbe xo qui cela ça valait dans le chat
qui nous propose d'aller voir d'aller
voir les filles on a déjà
du mal à voir les gars est en tout cas
vous voyez
à l'écran vous voyez pas grand chose
mais vous voyez quand même il ya
kosteniuk en arrière-plan si tu veux
pour toi barbe x ou y ajoute peut-être
grillage qui n'a sais pas je vois pas
bien
sur l'écran j'aurais dit de loin dans le
brouillard non je pensais pas que
yasmina ça
je vois pas je vois pas si c'est pas
beau d'awp c'est en tout cas un lit
réseau n'en perdait pas une miette de ce
petit match il
a géré trailer des chéquiers alors on va
pouvoir revenir
j'espère dans l'autre voilà donc on a
retrouvé notre concept est tout une
quarantaine en fait ok 5,04
d'avant arbitres soulte est en train de
nous dire une star avec age 3
x ou peut-être proxical n'en avait pas
vu depuis au moins 5 et une laverie
cachent trois douteux ou alors il vous
avait proposé ça
ok on a de la chance quand même d'être
aux commentaires comme ça ça nous permet
de rebondir sur vos commentaires avec
délectation voilà
alors donc vous donc oui c'est vrai que
firent ozanam ans il joue quasiment que
la fin ils jouent autre chose on a vu
que d'autres choses mais son arme
favorite c'est surtout pour l'instant la
halakha tout ce qu'on a vu dernièrement
j'aime pas du tout la carro mois avec
les noirs mais bon parce que je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à jouer
contre reims et l'ouverture emblématique
de knothole et karpov qu'on respecte
forcément mais je trouve cette ouverture
un peu décevant mais je la sais joueurs
au niveau
hockey c'est c'est quand même vraiment
pas si facile que ça peut-être au niveau
de prouver davantage mais un niveau
intermédiaire je constate qu'il ya
beaucoup de choix blanc et je trouve
donc pas si facile que ça
s'était mal je sais pas est ce que au
niveau cube jetons avec ça mais je
faisais un peu a lancé très
régulièrement on va partir de faire une
petite pub parce que
[Musique]
maintenant parce que on est imposée par
tous comme ça après on doit fini la
partie non une cuve et la pincée bissell
je pensais le mieux à faire yes donc du
coup on se retrouve du silure 3 4
minutes 1 restez connectés on revient
immédiatement un vrai plaisir de vous
retrouver à tout de suite des avis à
tout s'est tu
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
le
oh
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour donc 45 fillon
pourquoi tous yes
alors donc du coup 7,40 cannes côté noir
donc du coup on va vers firoud qui vient
de jouer avec 6 donc il veut clairement
casser tout le centre des blancs
rappelez vous un bel chaîne de pions des
blancs le but suivant de tout casser
donc là il va pas revenir sur ces
prendrait 5 pour garder la bonne
structure
la structure n'a me prend et pacy débuts
en finalement plus de la regarde plus je
me dis que c'est pas si des gueules
parce qu'on va réussir finalement je le
prend 1,5 à abandonner et l'ukraine un
prêt isolé mais après naturellement la
cam a envie de manger des fiancés
donc voilà il ya deux écoles un parce
que si on change de pioncer et après un
échange en bref si les blancs pourraient
essayer de jouer l'entente pour le
contrôle de quatre des cinq avec à
cavaillon 25 un jour tandis qu'est sur
mange occupions
qu un pion eux ça plus difficile à faire
quelles circonstances cette position
non que c'est petit plus non c'est sûr
parce que c'est lui à l'ouverture mais
jongler noir ils sont déjà en fait je
préfère un petit plus pour les blancs
mais je trouve que les noirs ils ont
déjà fait une bonne ouverture dans ce
sens où il n'a pas un problème majeur
il a repris après après une quinzaine de
coups avec une position relativement
équilibré
moi j'aime bien et prend des 5
parce qu'il a manqué ce qui fait barbe
et barbe xo avec eux des cinq j'écarte
dans le chat
et dr
alors je veux faire quoi il veut faire
après j'ai pas cavalier ça qui va faire
que six bayer pays on va essayer
d'expliquer
aujourd'hui chat qui n'ont pas tous
notre niveau du niveau des arbitres
pourquoi le cube alix est complètement
stupide
en fait juste pour vous montrer et sud
ouvrait le ban est ce que tu veux pas le
bagne pour changer car du village vous
vous éclatez vous posez en super
pratiques oenologiques de son coût alors
non je 4 c'est un coût qui peut être
bien sûr intéressant dans beaucoup de
parties vous faites bien attention de ne
pas faire ça chez vous j'ai cats a aucun
bien laurent blanc c'est très glissant
le roi est à poil complètement et c'est
pas un coucou n'a vraiment de faire
quand on veut des chèques alors
évidemment il ya les positions dans
laquelle on peut jouer g4 j'ai pas dit
que c'était un coq en 2001 peut-être que
c'est possible mais pour juger quatre
ainsi qu'un encouragement responsable
faire attention quand on joue ce genre
de types de coups donc généralement
quand on joue des cases la pression doit
être un caractère un peu fermé pour pas
se faire attaquer sur sur le roi
donc un projet 5g cas tout il s'est
peut-être un courant je le troll un vote
radar fixe mais c'est peut-être un coup
intéressant mais de manière générale moi
c'est pas un conte tout cas qu'il me
reste sauté aux yeux parce que c'est pas
un coup naturel à mon avis à cause du
rohan bien qui est qui est maintenant
affaibli après après ce coup j'ai 4
d'autant plus que 4 fois le sech la cdc
des banh cdbn pertinents
on pourrait un don de son corps sache
que babic souhait des maîtres nationale
donc si les bannis pour un crew il ya
zéro problème voilà c'est monsieur même
c'est même à la limite bienveillant
notre part le sachent le soc
ben en fait faire jeu 4 donc ça ouvre
les cases manger quand même est en fait
un enjeu 4 eh ben j'ai quand même encore
moi le foot classe branche qui vivent
donc quatre à gauche pour en profiter et
en plus la colonne est ce qui est en
train de s'ouvrir aussi donc
une fois que des pions ont été rangés la
colonne et va s'ouvrir le roi blanc
elecam pas totalement en sécurité j'aime
pas g4 personnellement c'est pas à toi
mais
ne s'est pas enfin non plus mais
pourquoi pas parce qu'on peut se
permettre sans beaucoup de choses dans
cette position sachez par contre à
quelque chose de dix paires intéressant
pour moi pour tous les joueurs amateurs
qui nous regardent c'est que la fille
rogers il prend du temps avec les noirs
pour déterminer quelle est la meilleure
structure c'est à dire respect c d ou e
d et en fait c'est déjà une grosse
question parce que c'est pas du tout la
même partie après et les coûts de pion
aux échecs c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre les joueurs amateurs et
les joueurs titrés et entre les joueurs
qui trait aux mêmes c'est à dire voilà
ça détermine le niveau de qualité des
joueurs puisque c'est ce sont de
nouvelles positions qui a 1 res c'est
extrêmement difficile de prendre cette
décision avec les pions voilà donc là il
est en train de reculer de voir quelle
est la nature dans les deux positions
qu'ils préfèrent et voilà les tapis de
c'est
tout simplement et ef de magnus qui
comptait le faire avec une structure
française classique on sait bien que ça
va être la suite logique l'on retrouve
sur une structure de française classique
1 plutôt que caro
avec la structure possible des cinq plus
arriérés en réussissent
la possibilité le 5 est difficile à
mettre en place mais on tourne un peu
isolé en d4
généralement c'est un petit peu et blanc
cette colline
je sais pas si c'est une super france
est le cas les décès qui parlent mal le
x 5 et il est plutôt indécise d'habitude
donc avantages inconvénients maxou pour
se dire ce que je pense que leur
position une question cette case 5 qui
km moi j'avais les mandolociens ils ont
découvert cinq avalanches de la jungle
c'est très facile à calais c'est ce qui
est arrivé quelle a été si ceux-ci la
turquie pas rentrer en septième rangée
le coup qui va contrôler le sac les
pièces sont pas forcément bien placé
donc la
position française 5 800 m3 cavaliers de
4 kg carte qui n'est pas du tout joueur
donc je sais pas trop comment on va
faire ici pour la tour siens magnus
maintenant qu'est-ce que je fais parce
que sur le long terme qui en parler de
la méthode d'hoffmann la zone sur le
long terme
la problématique c'est le chemin de 6 à
15 5 et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec des
noirs en fait concrètement pour quoi on
joue là de la question
donnerait c'est pourquoi on joue et il
rêvait ici ça pas de structure pour
laquelle tu joues pour quel échange tu
joues pas c'est pas facile de savoir et
c'est pas facile de faire
donc ici je ne trouve pas les objectifs
de la position alors que j'estime que
les blancs ils ont bonne position
d'amélioration lente ils vont jouer pour
la restriction des pièces noires et
l'amélioration des pièces blanches et du
coup c'est facile améliorer les pièces
blanches voilà je découvre des quatre
cavaliers à 4 90 et 5 par exemple
qu'avec cette référence 7 5
lui qui avait les baies 5 avaler ses
sets pour venir attaquer le pion et si
cela tout va vite rentrer la tour cela
ça se fait manger junca mais qui
pourrait venir au service à travers
toutes les terres blanches ont des
choses à faire alors que ledesma
lecavalier s'est pas renforcé pas
toujours à placer le tas parce qu'il
n'ya pas de case au centre finalement il
va aider le 5 mai au sein que ça va être
dur à faire parce que l'option et
toujours en prise et si vraiment il a
raison romain et c'est une cible ne
regarde c'est pas si facile normal
d'attaquer le bilan des quatre parce que
je suis deux fois ok imaginant toujours
trouver ci joue cavalier à cap tempo
s'est terminée il ya pas de journal
c'est moi qui m'ont qui most sur la case
ces cinq internes du coup en fait c'est
pas bien isolé au sens propre du terme
qui est sur le sol est ouverte que tu
peux taper avec des pièces lourdes du
coup ce n'est pas facile à ta question
le four b2 la course assure cette manie
cela me cavalière 4 c'est bien en fait
quand on parle depuis on est isolé qui
est faible généralement c'est un pion
qui est quand même sur une colonne
semi-ouverte ça veut dire c'est une
colonne où l'adversaire a pas de pions
et pout attaquer là en l'occurrence le
plan des quatre il est isolé mais les
pions des 5 et 6 sont quand même
enfin la bloque le pion des quatre ce
qui fait aussi qu'il ya 4-5 qui est
assez faible et le pion à 610 qui les
arriérés parce que lui laisse rincon
semi ouverte où je pourrais
éventuellement remettre une tour que
tard attaqué ce pion et les noirs ont
beaucoup de mal à jouer eux 5
premièrement parce que je suis beaucoup
de fois dessus et deuxièmement parce que
le tour des cinq serait déjà fait donc
non mais enfin tu as bien joué cavalier
h4 qui est logique mais il
pourrait essayer de jouer dynamique
changer un peu chamboulé la position
comme on a déjà parlé malheureusement
ici c'est que l'optimum u-16 est
beaucoup plus faible que le qui ont des
cartes et du coup c'est franchement
c'est franchement c'est franchement
difficile avant une chanson à propos de
cavale et v8 qui était une possibilité
bien sûr car elle évite ces liens se
font jour là sont des jolis coups mais
c'est un peu long quoi essayer la gamme
de cinq ans pour les bleus en donc c'est
sûr mais c'est aussi parce qu'ils sont
cavaliers ou cinq qui est le cas ici si
ce n'est pas facile avec la tour siens
mais dans l'idée c'était pas mal dans
les dés pour recycler ce cavalier le
mettre une bonne case et taper sur des
cas mais c'est que c'est un petit peu
long et on donne aussi la classe 5 pour
le cavalier blanc au pied carré dh 4
pour changer les pièces donc un
défenseur camerounais 4 il faut le dire
et on arrive un petit peu à faire un peu
le ménage sur le roi blanc donc un jour
pouvoir doubler tour sur la que je la
connais elle pourrait aussi ce pourrait
être par exemple ou dans la poule f 6
pourquoi pas parfois f5 concrètement les
pingouins de
jeu - à terme - vous vous écartez 30 de
la nar mais je vous laisse juger son
consistant mais là je vais faire une
grosse truction cavaliers à quatre baies
quatre cavaliers c5 et à se mettre déjà
difficile donc tu as deux caméras 5 pour
attaquer des s'attaquer aussi ce
qu'avait fait très fort ici et
d'ailleurs le cavalier des fois il ya
des marges de manoeuvre pour venir en d3
pour venir aussi 1,5 donc là c'est
typique dans ses positions de type
structure française karanka
donc b4 carsen ça c'est une raison qui
est vraiment très très bien pour 45
partage est une passion et beaucoup
amélioré et quarantaine il adore ses
positions et à améliorer les pièces donc
le contrôle de ferro de jean s'agit du
camp marie leroy avec fois absente mais
comme on a fouillé 4 même si on donne x
2 qui est essentielle le gouffre où
c'est pas grave après on travaille sur
la plus belle saucisses comme il aime
bien
dans le manu s'il a de la chance il
allait la blanc ici du coup elle a une
position de plus agréable il va
travailler ferroudja
sont ces partis pour est ce que je ferai
une petite fleur stéphane et hume
enverrait avoir jobin n'est pas un petit
moment
juste histoire de ce que c'est l'autre
affiche quand même on oublie de de ceux
de champion du monde
la caméra qui doit gras mais qui va
revenir parce que
elle est là des fois y'a réseau pas
je m'en bats est en train de jouer
brillamment à nouveau il a faim vient
d'avoir trop de problèmes j'aime bien ça
pour moi j'aime bien la loi elle se sait
gala de
miss passe pas grand chose alors comme
on voudrait me faut que leur pose est
quand même hein il faut le dire donc
que leur projet favori de l'attak
donc voilà leader il faut des plots fou
d'ailleurs il ya une ligne dure et de
beau il ya une super partie que j'adore
qui se trouve dans le bouquin de
touretski
parti du port avec les noirs je me sers
plus contre qui contre un grand maître
roumain des années 80 jean plus absolu
sur mon bref marine peut-être non non
non non un autre qui était bien plus
fort que lui à l'époque
les roumains je déconnais mais plutôt
moderne parlait bahreïn a renoncé à 80
c'était bien avant impôts zabo ça marche
toujours non hélas plusieurs y en a
plusieurs mais faisant un trou de
mémoire et en fait sa une position ce
type là en fait pour pour pourrions
zhukov laqué noir ou en fait eh ben on
tape sur le plonger de l'oeuf ou le
fouga smart à fond le 7 mai venom les
pièces d'or pour les pistes blanches
peut pas bien attaqué le
roi benoît rey du coup là je pense qu'il
peut y avoir deux il peut y avoir un
petit peu de jeu avec h 5 h 4 h trois
enfants vous êtes provoqué g3 jouer sur
les cases blanches complet encore
beaucoup de pièces pour les blancs à
chacun des jeux para para d'epo achetée
je crois que les blancs
et est en fait moi c'est égal mais moi
j'aime je préfère un peu le mien anti
pressing noir qui près six mois après
vente il ya une pression comme sur jets
d'oeufs et les blancs ont du mal un
petit peu on va sortir de tout ça
mais mais oui ça fait à peu près égale
toute façon mais
pression et que dresse en juin qu'à
faire quoi faire comme je retrouve ce
nom comme ça plus
on t'a posé de georges jouer moi je les
ai bien vu c'est pas lui jusqu'où le
coût des secours
j'ai pas ce coup ça terminera forcément
personne normale en médaillon de râ bon
est-ce que tu jette un coup d'oeil à ton
petit boudin alors d'où doit rapidement
du dock ou de la soude acquis afin de se
refaire
je vais tour ont réussi sont calculés
tiens ça a l'air d'être une bonne tête
alors une bonne tête mais ce n'est pas
si facile encore mais encore des pièces
est assez compliqué
ça va si juste et carte blanche je
m'enregistre les cartes blanches à dans
ce top blanc de jouer d'accord
tout blanc de jouer
non mais on peut imaginer coup comme
soit 9,5 et les cadrans sont faibles
chez passé pas si clair ce genre de
positions très souvent peu ça qui fait
la qualité pour essayer d'avoir le
contrôle en une ce soir le contrôle
complet des cases blanches d'un dessin
qui peut arriver mais ça reste une
qualité donc faire attention à ça comme
s'est passé sur après s'il veut juste
que manger en 8es faire x 5 derrière
avec lui même envoyé 500 nanar naturel
de jouer jécistes juste comme ça pour
tout vent fou ces deux mais voilà ce
type de choses en tout cas les cases
blanches sont très ouvertes chez les
noirs et avec le foot quasiment gelée
blanche ça risque d'être pas facile à
défendre pour le joueur arménien
ok bon moment on a fait notre petit tour
des stades est-ce qu'on peut aller voir
ma douche matinale et maxime on oublie
un petit peu il est loin et on nous
disait qu'il était très mal dans le chat
est ce que c'est vrai est ce que si
c'est vrai que ça bah oui parce qu'un
gros pions des six des pièces ultra
active
dans certains de ces camps m là je vais
je regardais tout à l'heure sur
j'ai un trou de mémoire c'est peut-être
à ce moment là qu'on apprendra que nous
départ aux mains ces saisies dans sa
[Musique]
non mais la maxime cas ce qui fait à
part là il veut tout me faire perdre
je suis très très déçu à maxime qu'est
ce qui lui arrive là peut-être voilà il
a eu un humour espace dans la partie
précédente
il commence à craquer
avec moins performants et en fait dans
son championnat du monde quand vous êtes
moins performant sur une partie vous un
grand maître
faut le savoir du coup il n'y a pas de
moyen de se refaire à paris ni faut être
bon il faut être bon c'est tout je passe
il tilt mais simplement il est en train
de moins bien joué et il avait bien joué
contre volo kittin il se prend une gaffe
de bébé et après la gaffe de bébés ben
il est pas content et du coup ils
essayent de se refaire son
sens peut-être donner son meilleur jeu
c'est pas commenter ce serait trop
facile de parler comme ça mais en tout
cas il va se battre
mais apparemment il ya une imprécision
de l'adversaire parce que le même à
nouveau revenir dans la partie mais en
tout cas
c'est wayne et poète et lui et c'est
mignon dois dire comme ça sèche parce
que c'est ce qu'on a vu effectivement
avec neo sauf que là c'est en partie
en partie rapide donc ça peut être huit
points là s'est tenue le direct en
voiliers
venus du tessin question avec des foules
et tout en et 6
tu reprends des six direct menace tour d
un match donc il veut peut-être
continuer elles feront pas sûr car ça me
fait roja comme c'est quand même leur
sort car cette fois c'est le grand
format la fiche de 2-2 le problème de la
journée 1 franchement beaucoup de monde
attendre ce vol à la race est vraiment
une position de domination
difficile à jouer c'est difficile parce
que carlson et sur toutes les bonnes
vieilles sa tâche le trim de claviers
mal sommes rentrés sur internet sauf
c'est mauvais signe offrir aux jo mais
elles sont domination f4 voulait pas
typé après maintenant je pense parce
qu'il a déconné une position difficile
maintenant qu'il est revenu dans la
partie je pense qu'il va pas perdre
mais en tout cas je suis moins serein
pour firoud déjà alors sa boîte le
poulain de stouff firo déjà je suis et
je reste chauvat j'aime beaucoup magnus
aussi mais en tout cas pour l'instant
magnus dans son style très
caractéristique
il s'est mal quoi il fait mal hein
chaque partie c'est
en fait parce que même contre je il
paraît que nul tout à l'heure n'est pas
ce que je bave a très très bien joué
il joue avec une stabilité ornans c'est
juste dingue quoi c'est un métronome en
fait
je voudrais du challenge et manu sur une
très bonne partie avec les blancs et
c'est l'horreur quoi en fait ils adorent
jouer le petit plus
et du coup là il va construire ça va
être très très dur pour fuir au jo on va
voir que si vous regardez barthel les
parties de cartes selma ce qui me
fascine c'est que tu as l'impression
qu'il n'a jamais en fait n'a pas jamais
une mauvaise pièce en fait dans sa
position que tu as l'impression que
vraiment tout est linéaire à chaque fois
et là on va le foot est très très fort
ensemble de batteries qui contrôle la
case de sacs et
le cabba les g4 c'est à partir de 5 les
gaz non pas le fou b6 bah en fait une
tape sur le t4 mais il pourrait
rapidement se tourner quatre
mais prenable et le cavalier fait qu'ils
jouent pas la tombe et c'est ce qu'ils
quitteraient mal classés aussi et là on
voit on à la colonne ouverte en c1 la
colonne semi ouverte aussi en
enfin on avons tout ce qu'il faut dans
la position et
est
vraiment on a l'impression que magnus
ben en fait ils jouent comme ça quand
fins et c'est tellement naturel pour le
temps facile devant les magistrats
c'est à l'événement
en fait c'est un trou sa compréhension
professionnel très très forte et là il a
travaillé la fois le sens et ça va être
un maître extra mondiaux pour son
adversaire
déjà on dit bien moment c'est difficile
d'avoir un plan firoud tiens on sait il
est très fort mais mettez votre
adversaire dans une position où il n'y a
pas d'idée
c'est extrêmement difficile avec et noir
je sais pas trop quoi faire parce que je
dois rester sur ma faiblesse ont réussi
ces jeunes toutes les pièces ce cadre et
j'ai pas de perspective incroyable
voilà c'est difficile mais on ne vous le
dis depuis un moment et c'est de plus en
plus difficile voilà sans glace et
c'est l'horreur à ces guildes à ça te
dirait greenline linda green day les
romains vraiment où il ya un lien 1060
plus indien stouff non mais c'est un
humain sur
c'est un roc et
entrevoir g3 assez rapidement pour
casser la diagonale du fou des six qui
est le seul élément un peu un peu vexant
un peu énervant pour
pour les blancs
en fait c'est pas le fourbe et de
l'effort je capote pour te répondre
c'est que
par rapport au reste le jeu d'échec
c'est un autre concession peut-être que
le four b2 effectivement c'est la seule
concession de la position blanche mais
il cavaliere fuite le pion réussissent à
tour g6 il ya pas mal et blizzard a
purgé six ou en fait le fougueux et en
plus il peut se poster en a3 un moment
elle vient s'échanger qu on le fout des
six ce qui serait vraiment l'idée de
quinssaines ici un dans cette position
il ya un objectif clair s'il échange le
x 3 font le food is is a major le trou
et
donc je parle pas de la tour c francs en
l'air et c'est pour l'instant mais du
coup ou b2c un food attente c'est la
seule caisse qui est pas terrible on a
un plan pour lui et si on le reste tout
va bien et on a une position de pressing
on va tourner autour du point 6 et faire
mal quand il le faut au
noir voilà c'est extrêmement dur à jouer
au niveau de la pendule d'ailleurs on
voit que c'est une minute trente contre
4,30 donc maintenu sa réussi à garder
une réserve de temps et ce qui n'est pas
le cas de
d'alireza
et on peut imaginer on peut imaginer que
il a pris énormément temps à les réseaux
parce que la position du sénat je vois
la voile un contexte réel
il en fait aussi au niveau des
perspectives de chaque de chaque couleur
en fait on voit que les voir ils n'ont
pas grand-chose à faire un tour au noir
animal place et qu'avec il à raison de 5
15 jours le fou qui en fait le rachat
lancée par trois jours non en fait
la pollution blanche toujours
la marche bien tout se passe bien en
fait
c'est simple mais en face on en fait on
vous parle de l' avantage des espaces
aux échecs l avantage des espaces en
tant que tel ça sert à rien mais
blizzard
bonne transmission c'est possible je
suis le rempart adam 108 surtout le
français 7e damas et sept ans fait sa
logique et sensitif la france s ab g3 je
pense qu'à ce personnes qui massacrent
de quarantaine pour karpov non non je
pense que ça arrivait au niveau de la
retransmission et on va voir une
correction manuelle avec dame française
vraisemblablement
que je peux vous mettre la caméra plus
proche peut-être
allez soyons fous
notre technicien tout va nous mettre un
gros plan bah le problème c'est que ce
n'est pas de la réalisation comme s'il
peut pas où mais les deux caméras les
joueurs sont devant
devant le 7e concours il casse le match
étiez donc je peux bien différents mais
le temps d'un massage norvégien c'est
pendant le massage dans des gens ça
s'est bien trouvés j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup je le garde de massage
norvégien pour qu'alassane puisque c'est
vrai que depuis qu'on observe dans ce
championnat du monde de rapides donc on
rapide c'est quand même plus difficile
d'être un hyper bon stratège a
franchement ils se régalent quoi web
search est un peu tous tous fait les
techniciens il est réalisateur
compositeur
[Musique]
bon après une entame français c'est un
conte poisse
mais assurément il un jouet il n'a pas
donné sa maman en un coup
je n'arrive pas du tout à ça joue
j'arrive pas du tout à retrouver qui a
pu se passer j'essaie de mettre un petit
peu
sa venue non c'est pas revenu
toujours trop france et 8 il
n'a pas donné sa dame j'en suis sûr sur
toute cette manière là je sais à peu
près de celle là c'est moi qui met des
coups 1 par rapport à ce que j'ai vu à
la prévention j'attends que ça à peu
près un truc comme ça s'est passé il ya
eu en quote j'ai cinq jeux 104,5 a eu à
dessein c'est impossible ça aveugle et
ce n'est pas le jeu vous dire
apparemment trop si des capacités forte
des prérequis fort en danse ses fans
pardon c'est fils ou fille lou qui te
dois bien reconnaître dans l'autre choc
danseurs
il a dit voir à lèvres je ne crois pas
qui mais vu si si je pense je pense que
soient pas modeste et 25 ans modeste
[Musique]
merci en tout cas pour cette fille aux
filous
par treasure que vous avez petites infos
sur un show l'estrima faut pas hésiter
mario beaulieu et du coup non ça
j'ai encore une fois le
nord que nakamura n'a fait que nul
contre antony géros avec les blancs
n'ont qu'à moi
pacy à la fête
toi c'est bizarre
alors ces revenus pour moi donc ça
devrait revenir pour toi cette fin au
niveau de deux maintenu ce qui est en
train de continuer le pressing
qui fait très très mal à
son adversaire
je crois que c'est il va bientôt
abdiquer est-ce que tu as récupéré
quelque chose rien du tout
voilà c'est ça devient je sens que ali
reza est en agonie
heures j'ai réussi à finir bien qui m'a
l'air bien regarder un match voilà
quinze ans un des compagnons gagnent
environ tout à fait la tête
ouais
ouais là c'est perdu pour pour ali reza
et il fait la moue il fait l'amour
le roi est
dans les cordes
c'est dur dur
c'est bientôt car nous
il se régale
alors est ce que
l'on voit on voit tout normalement voyez
grosse attaque sur le roi noir ses
revenus maintenant
est ce que tu vois trouviez un stéphane
de ton côté tout est nickel ont fait
tout est nickel à la loi enfin jacky qui
est pas content du tout non non il est
vexé mais c'est normal c'est un jeune
joueur il a envie de prouver qu'il est
déjà aussi fort que magnus mais c'est
pas encore le cas en cinq ans
après magnus allez les blancs a comme on
le lit c'est gros avantage devant les
blancs bourg sur le genre de
confrontation pour mettre la pression
sur l'adversaire et finalement il a un
pressing depuis le début d'ouverture qui
l'a bien converti un forcément
un
nas et d'un total il ya plus de sites
pour l'adversaire tous les pièces
blanches ont
massés pour attaquer là
on en voit pas comment s'en tirer
facilement
pièces sont trop proches
n'avaient plus de coups après fou à
trois
puisque sur vous prend entre dame prend
à 3 mai pression sur le cavalier fait
toujours celle à partir il ya une
arrache un kiss-in il va pas du tout
dans ma chambre je peux prendre le pouls
des six il a fait dams et 8 avec des
petits guignand en c2 mais il ya
toujours tous rêvent de boulettes de
khassan j'y crois pas le cavalier le
matin un sujet qui avait eu cinq rois
cavaliers n'ont que cinq des huit mois
c'est un peu le message arrive avant
tout les coups on roule a du retard 1
par rapport à la partie via cavalia
la fin la fin du monde
[Musique]
wenn man c'est super bien ce que je dis
c'est que ton avantage de la qualité des
pièces l'espace aux échecs c'est pas si
grave mais c'est vrai que si les pièces
commencent à être valorisés par l'
avantage des espaces là ça devient grave
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer le roi noir est très faible le
roi blanc est ok parce qu'il a ses
pièces autour de lui et c'est bientôt
l'abandon pour pour firoud dur dur dur
dur mais je vais pas
fait pas n'importe qui mais l'âge je
vois la partie c'est difficile là
franchement c'était une grosse
démonstration de karaté dans cette
partie est ce qui est bizarre c'est que
sur vos sites chez ce grand show 46e bah
ça y est donc voilà c'est bon on est on
est à nouveau ok vous le voyez et on
voit que c'est la fin des haricots pour
pour notre petit frenchy
c'est là toutes les pièces mal fichu là
on voit mal on voit quand même mal qu'un
scène mais en fait il va jouer juste
pour empêcher d'arâches inquiets sur le
contre jeu et puis après c'est réglé
on va vraiment très mal car c'est perdre
cette partie c'est impossible donc là il
faut pas se précipiter a eu autour des 1
le tour f1 la plus logique quand même et
touré failli roi à chute
vous voyez
votation firoud il reste 30 secondes
autant une position détestable
faut finir mes 45 il est stable dans ses
positions généralement ils se trompent
pas
si on avait pu parier sur lui peut-être
qu'on devrait faire stéphane on peut le
dire un bac en seine c'est quand même
des favoris fonctionnant exactement
à la c
c'est très très dur on voit que dida a
gagné aux siens
ses fans pour tout blanc s'est
pourtant lancé ou taxi match nul duda a
gagné et n'ai pas fait nul ce qui veut
dire que tout ça rattrape métaux
ça fait mal
j'espère que le départage sera la
confrontation directe
alors là j'essaie de vous donner les
coups au fur et à mesure et mais ce que
je veux dans ma caméra
retard par rapport au stream
mais là c'est difficile dans 48 en bref
à 3h qui hisse donc en fait juste fait
pas confiance car la scène mais mais en
fait non mais en fait il n'a pas besoin
là il fait ce qu'on appelle tournée pour
gagner ça je 4 ch4 même pas il mange il
pourrait manger ne pourquoi pas pourquoi
son viendra plus tard
je la sais
la torture ses positions la plus d'idées
c'est un cauchemar
le clan j'écarte est comestible quand je
veux kovalev c'est la partie je pense
que je cavale et g5 à marmande et agen
torje 5 voilà moi j'ai eu 4 4 calé cinq
parts dans le poggio calibrage d'un wc
c'est une f cette dame eux cinq une
grosse menace abandon par les abandons
fille rosa
il s'est vraiment fait
malmener la part à 40 scènes qui a sorti
une très grosse partie est là
franchement a vraiment rien à dire
franchement hyper impressionnant car
senna dans ce dans ce championnat du
monde pour l'instant on avait dit en
arrivant il y avait déjà
c'était monstrueux louis prat nos
poulains sont égalité comme tu le
tu le dis un finalement c'est qu'un seul
qui prend la tête comme il ya eu des
nuls derrière il est ce qu'il est seul
en tête c'est pas c'est possible
corrobore regrette choc peut-être
peuvent rattraper un menu soupe à l'ail
les 6
500 reste le seul pour l'instant mais il
ya korobov riccio que je crois qu'ils
peuvent rattraper
et tout ouais ils ont cinq points
voilà donc
ce n est qu en tête il va peut-être seul
en tête selon le résultat de corrobert
great choc on peut aller voir ce que
sanogo partie très tendue ou faux les
deux selamat de paula là ça a l'air trés
ton droit mais surtout matt
malheureusement c'est c'est comme morte
qui risque de perdre à perdre non parce
que sur damas chute j'ai encore foi je
sais pas d'il ya plus d'échecs owen
valeur assez fort
d'assister
à match à huit fois ashes dame m6
m'a sauvé un
bas c'est quand même un
bras mais au pire du pire aux pires qui
a besoin de gérer changer les sept parce
que d'abord ici d'un prof ou prend est
ce que je mange si c'est tout ce que je
mange de trois mois d'un practice sommet
une seule fois pour longtemps ça reste
que ça va être gagnant pour rich ou gris
tout qui va rejoindre car un seul en
tête
ballack a le malheureusement c'est dur
pour maxime que ceux qui chez sont
fervents supporters mais bien de terre
une partie qu'on me volait kittin la
ronde précédente et là nul contre un
grand m 2 de plus faible facture que lui
et donc cette main hyper décevant alors
est-ce que vous partirez geslin chaud
que le présent avec milk est toujours là
on l'éteint c'est pareil pour les uns
alors est-ce qu'on partirait pas un
petit peu en pose là pendant que nos
deux joueurs pendant que les joueurs
finissent leur part voilà c'est fini on
sait que c'est il va bientôt abandonner
ces abandons on voit quand même de
panama et la danse est
dans cette partie alors je veux est ce
qu'on est en droit juste de voir ce que
les positions devolo est
géré comme ça on a affaire pour global
des échiquiers relancer la pose est ce
que c'est possible bien d'être à leur
guise pour voir si j'ai vu que les avais
dit là les blancs
pensent sans doute des chances de nul
dans cette position quand même assez
forte après il faut pas faire reprendre
quatre modules te
mettrai ça mais ça va se savoir année là
le roi blanc est coupée 6.42 la tenue
lörrach quatre pieds on verra si si
c'est ce qui se produit et ça c'est
intéressant
par vokoun qui a une qualité mais
l'avion qui avance c'est un cauchemar
ah oui parce que j'ai pas moins f1 à
cause de rosneft roi est une as vraiment
de 2 quelle horreur il avait plus de
temps plus chaud parce qu'il a joué il a
ainsi retrouvé la nuit
non c'était ghinda michel je veux que le
grand maître romain glinda donc à partir
à jean boeuf j'ai beaucoup pensé à la
partie 2-2 n'est pas aujourd'hui la fin
contre contre moi j'ai d'ailleurs
intéressant plus d'avoir des références
sur les thèmes de stratégique fort et
que vous leur posez pas c'est un thème
et ben superbe on peut maintenant partir
tranquille tranquille entre eux je
savais qu'ils réclament donc qu'ils
réclament 2 3 4 minutes et on revient
après peu comme entrer la troisième
partie de la journée vous savez il ya
quatre partis aujourd'hui on se retrouve
tous les jours à 15h demain c'est 15h
aussi pour les quatre dernières parties
du chauffeur du monde mais là on se
retrouve dans trois quatre minutes pour
la ronde numéro trois de la journée dans
des instituts en surclassement guess a
tout de suite
a tout de suite
[Musique]
il
où
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]
à
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
où
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
il
[Musique]
e
à
on
on est de retour les amis
ibars big sue qui nous dit encore en
cause alors que lui il avait lieu il
avait dû aller faire une petite sieste
tranquillement
et avec stéphane en pause on discute 1,6
en province un thème que tu apparemment
staff oui je me suis trompé de bouton
quand je suis revenu j'étais mieux que
7e king bale pour détonations
l'atmosphère voilà un jeune citoyen de
boutons donc là je suis là donc d'isaba
bardy qui sera fait que
on a des pauses imposé par tous comme on
est obligé de faire des pauses c'est pas
con on a envie de faire des pauses c'est
qu'on est obligé de le faire donc si
j'en serai là tout le temps donc pas
rapide ça lui arrange rien de faire des
toasts ou temps
nous on n'est pas comme ça on a envie
quand même content d'être avec vous mais
des fois on doit faire des pauses et
c'est obligatoire
alors qu'on reste on est toujours
ensemble pendant les pauses on débrief
on cherche de nouveau des nouveaux
sujets enfin bref plein d'inventivité
quoi si vous voulez
c'est ce que l'on fait pendant que les
barbes x ou de vtt ou alors c'était
céder la sieste quelque chose comme ça
je te laisse deux minutes kevin mais je
t'en prie je sens prêt je le sentais je
vais cesser montréal jonathan
je déballe vie à toi j'avais j'étais
resté discret
oui il ya stéphane qui profitent
industrie mme pour commettre son sont
une machine en route sur l'âge ensuite
tu vois il est très très occupé et vous
voyez on aurait pu laisser la porte
ouverte il a été un peu plus joueurs
pour qu'on le voit étendre son linge
stouff mais finalement à sa bosse avec
soudain au loin on voit
simultanée entre le fait de travailler
et le fait de suivre ce stream de
qualité le championnat du monde on vous
le rappelle et on attaque la troisième
ronde de la journée et on sait déjà quel
va être le match au sommet il s'agit de
2 magnus carlsen qui va être opposé à
sasha grey juke avec son idole eric choc
super joueur de blitz un top 10 mondial
assurément toujours présent dans les
gros tournois trois des candidats
est particulièrement doué dans le jeu
sous pression pourquoi parce que
naturellement même dans ces parties
lentes ils l'aiment entre guillemets
être en grand et en europe en tout cas
il les met en tout cas facilement il
il se laissait être mal autant puis
petit à petit fait quand même de plus en
plus des femmes et stéphane de vannes
est très intéressé pour savoir qu'est ce
que j'ai eu quand même comme cadeau de
noël
bon j'en ai plusieurs
je vais voir un combat de boxe mais ça
dépend si là j'ai un peu peur
le 15 janvier afin d'y j'ai prévu de la
voix un combat de boxe voilà déjà ça
c'est un des cadeaux
des lunettes polarisantes aussi j'aime
beaucoup la pêche et du coup j'ai dû
lever à 2002 polarisantes voilà
moi il ya d'autres d'autres choses là je
pense que c'est ils sont bien connoté
ces cadeaux là en tout cas je pense que
l'histoire du combat de boxe à doigts ça
doit plaire j'ai envie d'aller voir tony
yoka voilà la conquête c'est lourd les
lourds est normal un gros gros combat de
boxe prévu à paris pour continuer la
conquête en tout cas très très bonnes
questions de stéphane delhomme que je
vais relayé astou fin très clairement je
vois que tout payer il est à nouveau
présent et se dit c'est quoi la question
qui va vous relayez edwards et d'autres
un peu
un peu comment dirais-je
way interrogatif qui étaient là tout va
effectivement vers un oui ouais ils
voulaient savoir ses fans de vin parce
que j'avais vu chantant parfaitement
j'espère que t'es pas mme ute je pense
pas on voulait savoir ce que tu as vu
comme un stéphane voulez savoir ce que
je veux comme cadeau de noël et du
coulage en et
j'en ai comment dirais-je donner
quelques uns à ce qu'est ce que tu as
des petits cadeaux dont on ouvre une
paire
parler sauf que je te donner pour
se régla c'est vrai alors alors moi je
suis en argentine et donc je ne souhaite
je suis loin de ma famille de mes amis
et et
donc moi j'ai pas j'ai fêté noël quand
même chez les amis donc c'était vraiment
entre amis c'est vraiment cool mais je
n'ai pas reçu de cadeau de noël bon ce
que je pensais vous avez tous sur la
chaîne de ce taux n'était pas plein de
sable de polo et ça lui fera plaisir
sans sel c'est déjà ça rappelez-vous
parce que ça a été un nouvel difficile
par 30 degrés en argentine franchement
alors que moi je profite de la pluie
sans discontinuer en a franchement de
repas règne franchement quand tu vois le
nu quand tu vois le père noël dans la
rue
moi franchement il fait de la peine
parce qu'il fait 30 degrés le père m'a
aidé comme ça il en subit
[Rires]
la monf où les mavericks mix ou qu'ils
négocient encore il mériterait de se
faire modérer moi je le pense comme ça
je pense qu'il va faire bander stéphane
pour nous dit il et j'ai l'impression
qu'ils vivent plus trop nous entende
parler de leurs cadeaux de noël parce
qu'il avait juste posé cette question
pour patienter un peu tout le monde pour
broder enfin qui nous a donné un sujet
pour broder on a été trop bon de trop
bons brodeur donc ils voudraient qu'on
arrête maintenant
parler oui michel parent effectivement
je pense que sur toute la bretagne il
flotte même stéphane de vannes ne doit
pas avoir un conte merveilleux
clairement
et alors est ce qu'on a nos petits
appareils manger à mons et bien sûr gris
tchouk carlos m j'ai pas pris trop de
risques ça c'est sûr on apprend croiser
apparemmment mai mais ils vont arriver
donc oui kanak est ce qu'on aura un
dépôt jo bavard il y aura pas de rené
d'houdain et pau par exemple vous le
savez il ya déjà eu un écho d'hydra ses
marques en duda est sorti avec les
fesses rouges de ce match
donc peut-être fait d'essayer comme
obsession qu'on n'a pas trop vu ils vont
arriver sur les premières tables est
toujours très présent je bave à 1
3 nuls 5 et demi sur 7 franchement c'est
chaud
non je vois qu'ils brûleront désolé
stouff il nous a expliqué pourquoi il
faisait une petite pause sur sa chaîne
c'est juste un problème d'accès à sa
chaîne en fait c'est pas qu'il impose
fort c'est comme quand on met des pubs
sur chasse comme fr va s'efforcer et la
sto fils est en pause forcée déjà c'est
les vacances donc du coup voilà un peu
ce qui est un petit peu moins de temps
en temps voulu les streamer et au delà
de ça il un problème d'accessibilité à
son compte donc j'ai un problème
technique dans cet esprit qui est dû au
fait que j'ai dû me connecter aux
comptes pièces comme fr / obs chez moi
et en fait du coup pour pour me
connecter à mon compte un mois se trouve
sur obs d'un j'ai besoin d'eux
leur donner un mot de passe que je
reçois par sms et comme je n'ai plus de
numéros français eh ben je ne reçoive
pas ce sms j'ai changé mon numéro de
téléphone sur twitter mais rien à faire
je reçois françois rien donc je ne peux
pas accéder à mon compte switch sur ovs
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué pour
l'instant
et du coup c'est que pinter belge
maintenant pat methany les belges je
peux je pense puisque il nous a mis une
petite phrase très équivoques d'andreu
puisque il avait deux genres voilà de
liège qu'on a on a compris puisqu'il est
il avait entendu l'histoire sûreté coach
gsm est généralement compte 10 a
forcément voilà on se vend et un petit
un petit bonjour la belgique on peut le
dire forcément j'ai joué en interclubs
belge pour pour le club de char de
charleroi et j'adore ce club il faut un
open en août pour ceux qui seront joueur
de club qui est vraiment hyper sympa un
domaine international et
et c'est un grand plaisir avec une super
team
qui gère le club et le crecq de
charleroi voilà et du coup je veux que
le cercle royal des échecs de charleroi
est concurrencé par le siècle cercle
royal des échecs de liège sans doute que
c'est ça
[Musique]
oui karpov est-ce que j'ai abandonné de
l'objectif de devenir gm un petit peu en
fait dehors comme je l'avais dit en 2009
j'ai joué 150 partis en 2010 60 et
depuis je vous 30 parties maximum
l'année ce qui n'est absolument pas
suffisant en plus tout simplement parce
que je suis pas assez doué pour être
prêts de gm faut être quand même assez
doué et il aurait fallu ou parce que je
ne suis pas assez que je m'investisse
beaucoup plus que je ne les ferai j'ai
fait le choix en 2008 de devenir
entraîneur j'ai encore joué pendant un
an et du coup j'ai eu tout de l'énorme à
partir de 2011 ça fait dix ans que
j'aime énorme et on peut penser que si
j'avais dû devenir gm je leur ai fait à
gond je me serai investi là-dedans avant
et on l'avait évoqué je crois avec
souffre mais le fait d'être 24 50 m ou
24 50 on a eu 25 00 grand max ça
changera pas ma vie de coach c'est à
dire que j'aurai toujours à peu près le
même niveau c'est un peu plus vendeur
effectivement d'être grand maître mais
objectivement c'est trop
d'investissements pour aussi peu de
retour voilà aujourd'hui parce que je ne
suis pas joueur
même si j'aimerais bien être à mettre
tout le monde à rester tout le monde m
je me suis d'accord avec toi et moi
après toi pour le coup ils font que 50
points c'est ça reste quand même encore
accès mais c'est bravo photo ou way est
en fait c'est même pas en fait c'est
même pas que le travail parce que je me
sens plus fort qu'en 2009 où j'avais
déjà 24 5 ans donc en fait finalement
douze ans après je suis toujours 24 50
le problème c'est qu'en 2009 j'étais
moins fort me jouer beaucoup aujourd'hui
j'estime être plus fort mais je joue
très très peu et j'ai donné on
demandé les conseils dans le chat pour
savoir comment faire pour devenir fort
aux échecs qu'est ce que vous voulez il
faut il faut déjà avant tout jouer
ensuite il faut jouer et travailler
et là vous avez vous avez un cocktail
explosif pour votre progression vous
allez faire des progrès maintenant vous
êtes rattrapé par la vie de tous les
jours vous savez qu'un 3d chaque c'est à
peu près une semaine
du coup pour j'estime qu'il faut 80
parties l'année pour jouer en plat pour
avoir un niveau de jeu suffisant pour
inspirer 2001 m 80 partie d'année on va
être sur quelque chose comme à l'est un
peu moins de dix neuf dix semaines neuf
semaines si vous voulez que vous allez
vous allez prendre vous savez qu'il ya
cinq semaines de congés en france bon
moi je suis à mon compte mais voilà
c'est déraisonnable c'est un peu la
problématique
a précédé choix autour de six mois à
venir c'est vrai que quand tu enfin le
titre de gm n'est pas non plus aussi
important pour toi en fait en terme 20
par rapport à ce que tu fais pour être
par rapport à ton travail par rapport à
au retour que tu vas avoir un graphe
photo dr bien sûr on veut tous être
grand match mais on peu pas mal an vont
tout faire dans la vie grand mais ça
demande beaucoup d'investissement de
travail et
et
beaucoup de la bri doit beaucoup joué
donc déjà moins travailler
et on sait que j'arrête mon travail quoi
tu veux que je fasse moi je trouve moi
j'ai montré dans le détail mais j'ai une
petite fille une conjointe et c'est les
jeux peut pas non plus dire donc pas en
vacances parce que j'ai envie de bien
grands maîtres et en plus c'est
hypothétique parce que vous le savez
gagner 50 points posent les perdre et du
coup je préfère faire d'autres choses
mes autres passions aussi je fais du
sport je sais pas mal de prévoir une vie
plus équilibrée que de tout mettre dans
le fait pas c'est grand mais on ne
changera pas ma vie même si échiquier
n'en parlant j'aurais aimé faire partie
de deux pas de ce groupe d hyper forget
la rose est chaque fois
plus effectivement comme un matelot dit
dans notre chasse la problématique c'est
que pour être grand maître à jouer des
grands maîtres ou des maîtres et grands
mecs qui font pour le coup beaucoup
d'échecs
donc c'est dur de passer 25 00 c'est que
à la fois 50 points j'avais fait un
petit un petit bond à 24,70 c'est un
moment j'ai fait un tournoi pour revenir
après un an et demi sont joués à deux
rondes par jour et j'ai perdu encore
aucun ce point là c'est dur à quelle
force tu estimes un joueur à 1700
ben j'ai dit je
rêve ils sont 700 00 à interpol pour te
dire les autres première catégorie c
2011 va faire des tranches de 200 points
donc
première catégorie on va dire que c'est
le début des joueurs régionaux on va
dire 1800 2000 on y arrive à les 1700
c'est un bon joueur départementale 10
sont 2000 un très bon joueur
départementale et plus de mire un joueur
régional dans ce cas classement moitié
du badminton j'ai déjà parlé on est
classé comme ça départemental régional
national et top top français après donc
ça serait une bonne idée donc pour moi
1700 c'est
bon joueur au très bon joueur
départementale
alors sinon ça défend moi je parlerais
je sais le lan pour changer un petit peu
de
chaleur mais alors j'ai un ami qui
pouvait très bien et qui est dit que tu
es très très fort au badminton
alors est ce que tu peux nous prend
d'emblée cette passation que tu as pour
le baby blues mais si tu veux je peux en
parler mais je suis très fort au
badminton pour un joueur d'échecs ça
c'est une précision non mes bons amis
ils jouent et jean clavin bonington
ah ouais mais bon il joue tu vois et je
peux être du bar du marquis voir au
badminton elle a du coup c'est le sport
c'est moi de moi évidemment non mais en
fait c'est relatif au retour pour un
joueur enfin j'estime moi je suis
je suis même plus un bon genre
départementale gt1 bowser départemental
et et voilà maximum donc vous voyez tout
dépend en fait tout dépend du fait de ce
que l'on entend par bon très bon je
pensais que je me débrouillais pas mal
et quand je suis arrivé en club j'ai
découvert un autre monde quoi stevenson
comme aux échecs on a parlé
c'était vraiment c'est vraiment autre
chose par contre dans le tchat tout à
l'heure il y avait manu key et qui est
lui un très très bon joueur de badminton
lui il avait il avait un niveau de très
bons joueurs régional au banik presque
est un bon joueur très très bon joueur
allez plutôt régionale mais lui lui se
débrouille bien mais c'est un autrement
dès qu'on découvre je pense n'importe
quelle discipline on après forts
amateurs récréatifs comme les échecs si
tu veux sur internet pour moi un stuff
et qu'on arrive dans un club voit alors
là c'est très très très différente à la
voir ça
on découvre d'ailleurs un autre monde et
c'est pour ça que si vous êtes joueur
récréatif sur internet et que vous
adorez les échecs allez si vous en avez
la possibilité et le temps du coup avec
un club près de chez vous et c'est aller
dans un club je sais qu'il ya un
streamer à ustream qui estime que sur ce
point comme on souffre et j'ai vu que
lui il avait démarré les échecs
niveau récréatif et que d'un coup il a
commencé il a commencé derrière à aller
dans un club il a vraiment une super
démarche je trouve parce que il fait pas
juste du stream échec pour du stream
échec en main il part de zéro il faillit
fait toute la démarche que je
conseillerais de faire c'est à dire
qu'il a adhéré à un club et c'est pour
ça qui m'intéresse particulièrement emma
en fait c'est déjà commencé tous les
jours on commence à 15h les parties là
c'est une bien petite pause entre deux
rôles ya quatre matches aujourd'hui y en
a eu cinq hier et on a encore 4 demain
pour le dévouement au final à partir de
15 heures et là on va finir vers 20
heures à bord comme ça tu sais tout
mais ça va venir la ja il ya peut-être
une grande pause entre deux je sais pas
ce que là je joue j'ai vu sur une autre
caméra parce que moi j'accepte plusieurs
caméras je vais sur une caméra qui avait
une joueuse qui étaient déjà installés
donc je pense que les joueurs va
démarrer très prochainement les joueurs
vont vont commencer à installer je vais
vous la montrer
comment il s'appelle déjà c'est une
joueuse de géorgie
on à l'elysée
nasdaqnyse et m'a dit je ne sais pas
comment elle s'appelle nana c'est son
prénom ces nanas si je dit pas d'où est
ce que ça a été sa vue sur les calmes
mais au moins c'est facile son prénom
n'en veut pas
donc les gravats l'arrière s'en sort et
leurs amateurs ouais non non non non si
un géant j'ai un pic à chasser manech
loft c'est mal écrit non médical est à
vous le faire le malin lanotte a bien
écrit mais alors le fichier complètement
bourré au niveau de l'union famille
d'appareils la barrière par rapport aux
bons amateurs alors en fait ça dépend
pour moi en fait
un amateur en fait ça dépend ce que tu
pour toi un amateur en fête pascale
amateurs pour être pour toi un genre de
club à 1800 et 2000 d'entre eux 2000 où
ça pourrait être aussi un maître un même
un genre à 2400 locaux en fait un
amateur pour moi c'est un joueur qui
aime beaucoup le jeu mais qui n'est pas
professionnel
mois vont pousser leurs formateurs dont
j'ai des chèques je sais pas ce que tu
en penses ce binz quand ce camp ouais je
suis complètement d'accord avec toi tu
vois des maîtres arseneault qui sont
absolument pas pros qui ont arrêté à
côté ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on voit
dans certains pays pour être
professionnel du jeu d'échecs en tant
que joueur là on parle on voit que les
premiers pros sont généralement titre et
mettra nationale et ça démarre à 23,50
avec des vieux maîtres qui galèrent
d'ailleurs généralement qui sont passés
de 1400 mhz et qui apprennent à
redescendre petit à petit et du coup
c'est extrêmement dur d'en vivre mais
c'est généralement minimum c'est 2350 et
vaut mieux ce qu'on dit pour un dollar
c'est plutôt d'ailleurs des gens des
pays de l'est qui ont un niveau de vie
qui est plus faible dans leur pays donc
faire les primes par exemple en europe
peuvent leur permettre de vivre
correctement dans leur pays d'origine
mais sinon ce conseil pour un joueur
français c'est d'être au moins 26 50 si
il veut il éleveurs en vivre c'est
extrêmement dur 26 5 ans vous parle de
jules moussard qui a été champion du
monde jeunes maxime lagarde christian
bauer fin des purs star pour un épi j'ai
pas cité ben quoi les autres noms a
précisé etienne bacrot maxime vachier
lagrave lorsqu'on dit en fait c'est
qu'il faut être dans le top 5 français
pour en vivre
en vivent 5 à 10 donc peut en vivre et
après au delà de ça même s'il est vrai
un premier essai d'en vivre c'est
vraiment dur de vivre du jeu d'échecs
exclusivement il faut il faut plutôt
donner des cours être seconde en vivent
autour des meilleurs joueurs
je suis d'accord donc du coup après
voilà
was here le terme
[Musique]
franck c'était quoi qu'il était amateur
pour moi c'est ça veut tout et rien dire
ça dépend vraiment je pense que ta
définition de voilà philosophie aussi
comme jeudi pour moi un matin en fait un
1804 amateurs à 1304 amateurs mais
pendant 2400 théâtre amateur c'est pas
proprement comme ça moi je ok moi je
suis pro dans les échecs parce que je
travaille dans les échecs en fait ce
choix entraîneur aussi et donc moi je
suis je suis pro mais en tant que joueur
je suis un amateur pas j'adore ça
j'adore jouer dès qu'ils entendent à
jésus elle enfin tu vois mais je suis un
homme a tué tous
professionnels en tant que le joueur et
c'est donc du coup en plein ce qu'on
peut dire par contre c'est qu'il ya peu
de grands maîtres qui ne sont pas
pourquoi ou ou en lien avec un pro non
pas du juge en tant que thème en lien
avec le jeu c'est très rare de devenir
grand maître et d'être purement amateur
j'ai des contre exemples il ya sébastien
caussens qui est presque grands maîtres
et les médecins par ailleurs c'est
vraiment des exceptions généralement
quand tu deviens grand maître a eu un
investissement très lourd dans le
pipeline surtout en termes de temps
et du coup ça c'est assez rare il y en a
quand même assez peu hein
j'ai pas beaucoup de noms en tête
oui des joueurs qui sont qu'ils sont
grand mère d'avoir un travail commun sur
iphone comme celle du seigneur
ce
sacro-saint je crois qu'il n'est pas
grand mais ce nom n'est pas grand mais
quand c'est sûr ils accueillent donnant
de grands maîtres c'est un peu moi je
pense qu'en fait ils jouent beaucoup
moins lui particulièrement en france
c'est un des joueurs qui devraient être
grand maître depuis maintenant un moment
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas c'est un petit
truc moche dans un trou à de grands
maîtres en fait il ya en lui avait
annoncé qu'il avait deux nuls à faire
pour finir son tournoi non on lui avait
dit il faut un point et demi sur deux
pour
pourquoi de grands maîtres du coup ils
avaient forcé l'avant-dernière ronde et
le lendemain on lui a dit tu peux
toujours faire un an si tu gagnes pas
partie donc il n'avait que un sur deux
affaires à la en 8 et 9 et donc il
aurait fait précédemment nul et nul ça
lui suffisait ne savais pas du coup il a
forcé l'avant-dernière ronde et perdu la
dernière ronde en plus sans les cendres
gagner à nouveau et du coup depuis il a
parfait ses normes mais il est 2500
depuis très longtemps
j'ai un ami qui maintenant et m laval
4,50 en français qui jouait pour sa
troisième normes donc pour le titre de
emi a c'était thomas 2
on s'appelle un
verre à montpellier la louve au tournant
la france appelle
le cap d'agde et a glissé sa cap d'agde
et dernière on en fait des bains ils
jouent contre matt il conjugue donc qui
est titré 1
et en fait ça faisait cinquième titre et
va toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour faire là la troisième vague
lemaître et donc moi je calcule pour lui
je vois bien faire une langue des
tsiganes et donc je l'appelle juba tiens
si tu gagnes match énorme de bmi et il
dit au moment où l on al arab et c'est
maintenant du diable alors je calcule
gens calculent et en fait il faisait
vraiment une norme 2006 gagne donc libre
si si si tu fais en 2001 j'espère que
les dix fois
et le difaa va voir l'arbitré dit lui
vous devant lui une confirmation avant
la partie parce que tu as très important
de savoir pourquoi tu joues quoi et
parce que lui est un petit lité vous un
tournant moyens bon enfin il avait admis
400 et quelques bons que nous n'en
finirons relis je ne peux pas voilà et
donc ils te prennent ils avaient les
blaugrana ont lutté près pas trop trop
s'embêter entre jouer huawei peu marre
et donc qui bavent larbitre et l'arbitré
il lui dit
brassart ya un jour
savoir quoi et en fait l'armée tribal
ces pannes en main et bande annonce en
fait là ouais c'est ça mais l' arbitre
en fait il avait demandé à l'arbitré la
veille il avait dit non moi je vous dit
mme loj pour moi je veux dc est derrière
eh ben il va le lendemain il va avoir
les arbitres ils ont madrid a bien
résumé on m'a dit que oui du coup est ce
que est ce que je la fais il dit je sais
pas jouer et et abusé quoi et du coup
ben hilli l'adjoint ils arnaquent et il
a gagné 1 mais il a gagné et ben bravo
tu as fait norme voulue dès la fin va
dès qu'il a fini l'album voilà taffetas
nombre à merci que vacances annonce
surprise super âge aux prix bas moitié
parce que moi qu'il ya des conventions
dans mon pote et ouais
ça avec il savait que voilà et
hassar peur ça repart on va bientôt
avoir les partis c'est
particulier on a parlé des super grand
maître on a estimé qu'il devrait y est
et qu'il devrait pardon y avoir des
titres à
2601 grand maître plus un grand maître
plus + 1 2700 et les grands maîtres
d'élite à partir de 1800 ce n'est pas le
cas au niveau de la fidh mais ça aurait
du sens voilà et du coup on va pouvoir
passer aux face à aarberg et c'est pas
grave on sent que ça va ça va arriver
j'en peux plus alors je vais enlever
ne vous inquiétez pas on arrive tout de
suite avec les parties puisque on voit
que c'est parti avec magnus donc c'est à
ce chat gris tchouk qu'ils ont fait
chantôme 5 ans vidame refuser ou et à
ils mangent en d5
bon sens le petit fou g5 loubet quatre
paires thématique
assez si simple pour un alto pas
beaucoup de
à toi aussi habito
ce que je veux une allumette
pourquoi je devrais aller m j'aurais
beaucoup de groupes d'un bras jean au
revoir j'ai raté un truc c'est que la
lumière la lumière
il propose une allumette pour aller à
nîmes hier quelque chose c'est vrai chez
moi c'est par
wes à des codes en fait il ya beaucoup
de monde qui se sucrent championnat et
qui va surtout ce com pour suivre la
retransmission dans toutes les langues
avec la loi qui les rackettent français
il ya toutes les langues anglais et en
espagnol
italien russe allemand tout ce que vous
voulez et du coup ben
beaucoup de monde c'est ce qu'a dû monde
et crache le site qui est d'ailleurs
dommage parce que c'est un et le brutal
qui a pas pu jouer hier il a été sevré
recevraient des chèques ouais en fait
aujourd'hui de nos commentaires pour se
refaire
et du coup je ne peux pas accéder donc
pouvoir garder et bien si vous savez pas
quoi faire pendant que pour l'instant on
n'a pas les chéquiers virtuel on vous
invite à aller voir les vidéos youtube
chasse com fr ou alors tout simplement
nos chaînes avec stouff la chaîne de
stocks bastou fin forcément sur twitch
et ma propre chaîne vous la connaissez
maintenant révolution échec sur sur
twitch aussi allé les voir dès que vous
avez un petit moment de vous ennuyer que
vous avez envie de faire un petit peu
d'échecs masse et la bonne occasion
particulièrement hors vacances scolaires
là c'est les vacances on stream un peu
moins ex touffe mais à la rentrée là ça
va faire mal y aura un gros programme et
même le jour de l'an j'ai prévu de faire
le 1er janvier la nouvelle année pro
evolution échec voilà comme ça vous
savez tout on a détendu l'atmosphère et
on est toujours dans un grand vide a
refusé yes alors n'hésitez plus riches
ou n'hésitez pas à venir en solo les
chaînes les chaînes vous avez les liens
sur le chat deux avaient aussi la chaîne
youtube de pièces comme sex com fr
pourrait tout contenu pour le long à
venir donc vous avez tous sur le tchat
un petit fond je rejoue de partout ça
vous plaît et chez moi qu est-ce qu
homme qui regarde moi je mise contre
great choc moi je pense que quarantaine
va gagner et que guy ritchie tu vas tu
vas être mal autant je prends des
risques en plus un
tu pense et je ne crois pas du tout moi
je pense que
comment dirais-je quinzaine va gagner il
va pas tout va s'envoyer en l'air mal
autant aller voilà c'est mon chrono
non moi je vois nulle en fait c'est pas
mal aussi pas de risque je laisse tout
plein mais bath
jeu en fait gris tous qu'il est
il est quand même champion du monde il
est sûr que du monde de blitz et gérer
un tournoi il sait gérer la rapide où il
est lent oui tout ça mais mais il est
capable de gérer une partie et passe en
voyant là je pense c'est pas trop son
style à de s'envoyer en l'air avec notes
et pour savoir quand et à qui les rend
très très fort que tout
moi je le vois ça c'est celui de notre
parti et je pense jeu bon je pense qu'il
va essayer bien sûr de jouer et de créer
des choses mais je ne dois pas perdre et
s'envoyer en l'air comme tu dis
on va voir un ami cher et c'est bien
parce que michel l'huile à parier sur
green shoots toi t'es sur une note
stable et comme ma part ce sera à magnus
est ce qu on a droit d'ailleurs d'aller
voir un petit peu on va les mots avori
avec bouddha le poulain leur pouf et
pour ma part vous le savez c'est
évidemment un exacto bonjour à vos
réclusion contre qui elle fonde alors on
va devoir rapidement se situe le bien
avec seiko contre nakamura nakamura qui
est qui est très très proche d'eux
des cinq et demi de duda et 2 et 2 et de
dépôt et voir un peu ce qui se passe
sonaca la caa les noirs donc sa position
sont à première vue de nîmes sans qu'ils
aient à saint cannat k way i l'asie
n'est pas lié à un point de moins que
character et 1 2 point de moins que les
autres
le temps sur l'écran malheureusement à
yverdon c'est là je sais me l'a jetée me
l'a vu en grand mais comme je n'ai rien
eu en fait ouais j'avais travaillé
longtemps maintenant que tu as le temps
merci brutale savez vous avez du temps
alors voit tout doute la question c'est
quoi un bouddha encore une position de
ce type là vous allez bien ses positions
une de l'espace avec
alors la callas le pion hd reprise mais
malheureusement une fois que tu manges
et h2 à la fin que tu vas perdre 17 à la
catastrophique donc le purin je n'ai pas
vraiment aux prises ici
on voit le réalisme des noirs plus tard
avec 5 donc je pense que la petite fouet
cette petit rang pour commencer et après
un jour de se balancer balance et e5 qui
est thématique un excédent de structures
ou un v6 aussi ces thématiques les deux
thématiques les deux pouces et tomates
x25 et b6 on voit qu'il a choisi b6
donc mais strictement égale interne au
plancher quand même pour compenser l
attaque éventuelle le fait d'avoir donné
l'adresse du roi plan
ici il faut jouer rapidement pour 4 tu
sais que j'avais joué contre 9 sessions
en bullet sur pièces comme il ya
peut-être un an et c'était vraiment
parce que mon à l'époque je jouais de
mon lit en fait c'est très fort pour des
bulles est dans mon lit genre j'étais
habitué vraiment c'était la folie 1 est
d'ailleurs une fois j'avais tu n'as
qu'un droit dans mon lit j'ai dit oui
sous tendent et ça n'a jamais su que
j'étais dans mon lit les yeux et en fait
l'idée c'est que je gagnais genre
peut-être 4-0 contre l'oppression en
bullet et abandonné ben je propose ma
manche il a 20 de vos lots 1 et je
propose avant j'ai fini mis du temps à
accepter la revanche du coup ben je
regarde son pseudo mais j'en avais un
peu son nom et je vois assez neuf
sessions quoi et là il accepte là ils
acceptent la revanche donc je joue mais
là le sexe et le fc sion et j'ai perdu
genre 4 0 d'affilée et je suis et enfin
savoir ouais je savais pas contre qui je
joue et je compterai mais très très fort
je sais pas qui c'était et je vais
défoncer et dès que j'ai su qu'il était
en live tout perdu c'est pas appeler les
moyens je fais avec ce prime des
gendarmes obsession et comme quoi la
psychologie des chèques c'est vraiment
important
ouais mon obsession c'est qu'il est plus
de 2007 alors là je sais pour la sauver
son héros mais en lan il a été un des
miliciens 50
et celle des joueurs très stable
il n'est pas là pour décorer il a joué
de manière très ambitieuse 1 franchement
d'ailleurs j'aime bien s'impose à glace
heures de fou j'aime bien aussi
mais une position qui peut se retourner
très vite parce que très très équilibré
et je me demande si parmi vous demande
pas un bas pour sacrer
[Rires]
estime oddo ces matches qui nous fait
barbecue salut à toi repas tout je crois
que je vais je crois je vais donner
l'été à fatou modeuses pour qui et pour
quelle barbe x dès qu'il ouvre la bouche
c'est shakira aussi fine un mauvais
coton l'art en misant sur le fait que
que j'aurais mal au crâne pour mon
sprint nouvelle en
salles le 1er janvier j'ai choisi la
pallice et pas par hasard ça sera déjà
dur
ok la position très intéressant donc là
on a vu et il ya nippo galfond aussi
avec huawei un petit moment ne pas aller
voir on va les voir des google phones un
petit ceux comme ça après on n'oubliera
pas ses dossiers
ça c'est une grosse olly moss a
résolument sa voix seulement avec que
signifie ce que j'ai déjà jeu de
position et noir que j'aime pas du tout
d'ailleurs ça ne convient pas du tout
c'est trop solide et moi je ne comprends
rien cette mission
en france j'ai du mal à
catégoriser c'est un peu tout faire
enfin quelque chose il va beaucoup d'ex
temps s'il avait vu le match plein du
monde contre anondin c'était en quelle
année en 2000 2008
j'adorerais dollar à la baisse et perd
chaud
parce que dans ses positions la cij ou
le simple cavaliers c3 ou les simples et
kara et ses trois chevaux frontale tour
des mythes
et il essaie d'apprendre qu'on dit
attention aux coups avant tout ce sang
qui peut arriver que 5 peut arriver
faire arracher un truck series peut-être
est-ce que c'est donc sa mère ma fac
c'est très menaçants tour débute en fait
j'ai du mal à m'en vais du cloud âge dès
que je bouge madar et d'un jeu perd le
fou et j'ai pas moyen de voir le
défendra par un cavalier doc est très
moche j'aime bien son coup tama cinq
points c'est à ces forains on est la
case pour la tour et puis on peut un
jour venir sur sur la droit et à kehl le
ranger
alors qu'elle fonde c'est vraiment le
profil qui bon c'est le genre un peu
retraités qui joue plus trop aux échecs
qui a été très très fort dans sa période
qui est vice champion du monde et je
pense c'est le joueur qui en pratique
peu la colère des pauvres je pense n'est
pas très loquace il est proche ouais
voilà et là on voit ce qu'ils disaient
tu vois on voit une époque il ya onze
lutte à la pendule est généralement pas
deuxième enfin des poètes tempo les
pauses les machines de guerre au niveau
du temps et effectivement ça c'est bien
ce que tu remarques stéphane parce que
que tout ce que tu fais remarquer c'est
rare c'est rare de se faire mettre
autant la pression
sur livres de belfort un très très très
intéressant non mais là il ya un
problème pratique quand même c'est à
dire que thierry larrieu
alors est-ce que icij autour des 8 ou
est-ce que je joue grands axes
or moi je recommence à faire tourner
vite parce que petit roxy mort si juste
normal
quant au salaire quand même plus à
d'ouvert plus casse-gueule mais dans
votre côté fia un jour sans une sérieuse
sans peut-être c'est pas bête avant le
roy on s'évite plutôt qu'en 8 si je veux
réagir rapidement
après voir puisqu'avec crops aussi faire
plus facilement feint d'oublier tour
rapidement
généralement les livres des joueurs de
haut niveau sont quand même fait pour
une certaine élite se dirait des joueurs
de première catégorie en règle générale
il ya peut-être des exceptions mais
souvent c'est pour des joueurs au moins
1800 voire 2000
je sais pas c'était d'accord c'est un an
existing elle fonde pour moi il est
assez courte pour moi je rêve ndi même
peut-être moins de 2000 un
jour et on a un effet magique est quand
même en difficulté qui viendraient tours
troyes s'est rapidement alors on va être
comprendre parce que bon - fait avec
l'ordinateur 10,2 sous les yeux et grand
roque donner un avantage énorme pour
pour n'est pas pour qu'elle fonde
donc le joug non excusez moi il me
donnait plus 2 et quand je le joue nous
donne plus 0,6
ça c'est bizarre
et
on voit qu'ils me disent 0,6 à 3 h 3
crac complet tour débute alors quand
même beaucoup plus au début c'était
quand même plus normal map une armée 3
jouer très vite il faut défendre comme
ça et en fait régulier tour des 3 pour
la petit rock à l'arrêt ce que l'art est
belle analyse encore après bourse
j'ai dit pardon
est finie fait du mal a été fait du mal
ben en fait j'essaie de comprendre en
fait parce que moi je comprenais pas
pourquoi tant que c'est plus fort que
toi
il n'y avait pas d'explication enfin
donc tu avais non nommés directement par
et stéphane voilà c'est ça mais j'essaie
de comprendre en fait tu vois je peux
moi je lis ce que je vois mais je pense
que barbe x où il est jaloux de la
qualité de
de tes commentaires et analyse en fait
simplement et c'est autre chose
bon en tout cas
c'est pas si facile que ça pour tourner
pour il se balade pas dans cette danse
est par contre quelle forme on a dit a
généralement le temps est un très bon
indicateur pour voir en début de partie
qui est devant théoriquement
des voiries suisse en même temps il s'en
remet pas je pense qu'ils cherchent
sources qu'il cherche il me cherche on
cherche alors est-ce qu'on est ce que
vous partirez pas vous voir un petit peu
rapidement les français voient route
sans nom oui oui c'est vrai qu'on les
oublie mais ils sont toujours là donc
français grant forest qui ont osé un tel
répit roja ils viennent pertes à oui
c'est pas un appareil mais fascinant non
parce que là il a 26 50 idées sous
classé mais il joue bonne foi ce qu à
25,68 au-dessous de place et
donc les deux bon après je pense qu'ils
sont en prévente se jouer ses coûts de
jeu des joueurs forts mais mais dans ce
cas de figure ils viennent de perdre
pendant les étapes c'est pas forcément
un cadeau de jouer avec forest avec les
noirs d'ailleurs il a joué italienne
avec avec asus g51j g5 1er janvier
martiaux modernes
combat avec ce qui est pour jordan les
votes compteront le ban pour le coup
parce que l'inter et
je te rappelle que alors je vous
rappelle que jacques salaun que kevin et
moi on a on a parié sur sur bar sur
certains joueurs donc du coup on
apparaître les français qui arriverait
le premier entre maxime et firouz ja
donc j'avais laissé choisir kaehlin son
préféré l'aphasie maxime et du coup donc
moi je dois supporter firouz ya donc là
du coup fut roja contre avant une fois
ce jeu sur budget dé se tenir fin roja
exact et est ce que je dois être
rassurés par la remarque de stéphane de
vannes qui est qui m'a dit que
mv elle est en chrono promenade total on
va aller voir ce qui se passe ou aller
voir ce qui se passe comme déjà ça parce
que là ils se passent pas encore rien
fait encore un baston attendu entre phil
rogers me reste mais ça arrive à moi
j'aime bien les voir en fait parce que
moi j'aime bien ta qui est humain
cavaleur af447 et pis tu si tu vas
essayer
ses positions là il va réagir aux
entraînements avec des cartes sans doute
c'est pas si simple qu'elle maniait fait
un cavalier 3 aussi peut-être comme
thématique donc il ya encore il ya
encore du boulot pour les deux joueurs
mais c'est intéressant rapide de jouer
pour l'attack évidemment mettre la
pression alors maxime je ne trouve pas
où es-tu maxime
c'est comme où est charlie tu sais la bd
pas mal pas mal beau mâle belles
références je pense que
c'est parce que dans le public il y en a
certains qui est qu'ils auront bien
compris cette petite bref je m'étonne
d'ailleurs que barbe x ou coller des
petites v il devait avoir quelques bd où
est charlie c'est bien son style à mon
avis
décidément je me demande même s'il a
enfin pu louer charline est bon ça chez
compass sur un seul morceau
on voit pas ce qui s'est passé dans la
partie alors on va à fond on va pid
et merci à stéphane dereine qui avaient
bien lu là et puis on voyait un 14
minutes contre contre 8 minutes il joue
un petit gros m mais bon petit grand
maître c'est un très fort joueur
d'échecs
maximois il avait juste échange et d'un
mot départ et ensuite il a activé très
rapidement ses pièces il a gardé le pion
à cinq
essais puis on avance et l'autre pour le
récupérer il a fait des concessions au
niveau du roi ou le pion et s'est pas
rendu compte
et il a commencé à se faire tactique et
par maxime avec le roi qui a l'air ok
c'est quand même pas très bien ce à
l'infini les pirates sont pas du tout
développés qui a été plus que fois si tu
ne peux pas jouer
je pense qu'on peut on peut essayer de
je pense qu'on peut revenir sur les
parties
est maintenue ça fait un petit moment
peut-être qu'on peut les voir manu c'est
gris chaud je savais pas grand chose
tout à l'heure j'ai cru j'ai cru que
c'était pas passé grand chose mais là
c'est mieux quand même pièce alors
position typiques de gore bidart avec
gordon des changes trois cavaliers eux
deux qui est le plus réputé avec trois
cavaliers ou deux pour jouer aux cartes
pour la majorité comme tu l'as dit que
stéphane
c'est plus agréable pour les blancs dans
cette seconde position ouais parce que
chaque membre 4 mais attention que les
pions ici ils peuvent être pendant
longtemps alors pions pendant ce temps
que nous nous donne une définition kevin
en fait ces deux pions qui sont côte à
côte un mais qui n'ont pas de copain
pion à côté d'eux donc c'est un duo de
pions qui n'a pas de copains qui ont
donc ça veut dire que ce duo de pions va
forcément
réduire ses propres pièces à l'
esclavage et du coup il va faire
soutenir ceux des options après ce duo
pions dans le cas que l'on a sous les
yeux il va être un duo pions centraux du
coup ça contrôle beaucoup de cases et
c'est très très difficile pour les noirs
de libérer les pièces d'avoir de
l'activité et c'est pour ça qu'on voit
souvent dans cette structure une fois
qu'on a pris le cadre des oeufs et feu
on voit souvent le coût des noirs c5 qui
est qui le grand classique de la
position pour que les pions ne soit plus
côte à côte et que sa face des trous
voilà voilà pour vulgariser un petit peu
les choses et je pense que par dick
soumahila il a enfin compris ce
qu'étaient les pions content et ça c'est
important pour revivre cela j'étais de
ces cinq ans fait s'attaque elle pions
créé un trou en fait rang des quatre
voies c5 des fois des 5 et que y avoir
dans certains cas ces quatre là ça
marcherait ça marcherait que cette
veilleuse pour juste pour expliquer en
fait un ici il faut que je bouge le fou
en fait d'un jeu gagne la casse de 5
pour mon cavalier mais j'essaie % en
fait qu'on ferait en fait c'est simple
après il ya des complications que le c4
à ça c'est encore autre chose là j'ai
joué à six qui n'a pas de sens juste
pour montrer un petit peu comment
comique mais voilà après généralement
les pions pendant qu'on n'a pas de nom
plus généralement ils se trouvent sur
des colonnes qui sont celui ouverte en
face maria papillons monarques général
et du coût des plans de votre faible
peuvent aussi être fort si on arrive à
c'est bien et protégée au smic parce
qu'un des pions sont très solides au
sens pas facile de venir les chercher
en tout cas l'idée des blancs c'est de
faire ici
plus tard près 4 prendre de l'espace pro
tout c'est un petit peu les pièces
noires et commencer la table mais c'est
un des meilleurs systèmes normalement
connus référence et qu'on le gambit
d'âme quand on joue comme d'amd change
d'ailleurs on joue f3 qui a eu lieu au
niveau pour faire re 4 sinon c'est la
tacc de minorités avec le plan b car des
cinq mâts et glauque à manier plutôt
poster f3 pour ceux qui aiment les
candidats mme d'attac de minorités
bekaert b5 c'est l'autre plan de
7,2 cette position
et babx ou qui se régale toujours dans
le chat en tout cas et c'est pas un seul
un j'espère un les hydrates châtain ne
laissez pas la parole tout le temps à
barbe x ou
effectivement si on n'a pas de copain
pions les pions marc flores aux échecs
dont il faut soutenir ses places en trop
avec des pions pour reconstruire le
centre c'est la base la base un des
grands principes c'est que dans
l'ouverture on essaie de s'approprier
les centres n'est pas que dans
l'ouverture maintenant mis en jeu donc
c'est un bon principe de tenir des pions
avec des pions
et il ya eu un petit b52 de manu c'est
ce qu'on vient de voir ça qui est
d'oublier sac donc l'un des rares de le
faire maintenant probablement les unit
deux qui pourraient avoir ces sur quatre
pouvoir essayer le jeu des cas très
déstabilisée du contrôle du du purin
cave
vous ai pas en tête ça n'a rien à voir
sur la d4 c'est après que ça ça me
laissait aussi le fiancé c'est un peu
faible
ce conte c'est normalement la ses
caractéristiques b5 dans la position du
gambit nam quand le brushing blond est
tombé 4 pour mettre le cadre alliance
s'écartent sur l'a15 forte ce qui est
plus étonnant dans cette situation c'est
que
la case sekkat je n'ai pas accès
puisqu'on vient b2 donc j'aime plus b3
sequans 15 d'avant-postes
montant b 5 ok on va t'il puis ont été
enlevés quatre pièces qu'elle serait une
belle case pour installer encore que tu
avais donc si je vais en c4 plus tard il
y aura toujours b3 pour chasser donc b5
c'est quand même un coup c'est une
concession quand même quand on fait le
pion c'est ce qui est le cas avec vendus
et las casas acquis dans le cadre ce que
j'aime ouais je sais pas grand fan pour
l'instant je préfère alors si vous
voulez là normalement plantes blanc
associé à quatre c'est un jour de faire
un 5 4 et 5 voilà le plan blanc sauf que
le flou en f4 pour l'instant il mal
placé dans cette idée
alors il me semble que nos championnes
du monde parties rapides et plus donc
c'est chaque année un
village au lycée chaque année et sinon
c'est à cause du cycle des candidats en
tournoi l'an ils n'y arrivent pas du
monde après tous les deux ans pour la il
convient d'y et pas mal de choses il
trouva des candidats vous savez donc
c'est pour moi qui réduit et réunis par
dont les huit challenger pour définir
qui sera le challenger à la couronne
mondiale en l'occurrence cette année
c'est nro meacci et pour organiser ce
trou à des candidats mais il faut avoir
les les candidats et les candidats par
an les définis via les tournois qui ont
lieu dans les deux ans précédant le
chemin du monde avec des deux critères
la 4e place avec des gros tournois le
classement elo un érythème de
l'organisation etc etc et bref on t'a on
a comptable souvent les huit joueurs du
top 10 mondial c'est à peu près ça oui
joueurs du top 15 mondial
qui en plus quand tu lis fatou il ya une
certaine logique puisque il faut aussi
les organiser et organiser un
championnat du monde c'est pas simple
les joueurs ils ont leurs exigences
il ya toujours des histoires d'argent
aussi donc il parle de choses à régler
pour trouver un lieu qui convienne aux
deux joueurs il ya un cahier des charges
à remplir et on voit là que great choc
mais notre exécution le plan basique
dans cette position
donc on pousse le pion mais rien des
coups comme fou c'est un vrai trou c'est
un bien la problématique c'est qu'il va
y avoir des 4 et 5 c'est à dire que s'il
espérait 4,5 il a perdu avec les noirs
donc maintenue s'il à réagir au centre
avec avec ses 5 d'école un pion bessac
ccam c'est quand même plus logique de
faire beckham d'abord et ses 5 ans 8
alors en fait fragile à la cause ces
sacs ce qu'on voudrait faire je vais
expliquer pour pour les succès que moins
fort dans le tchat
l'idée on aimerait comme je l'expliquais
faire pousser à pourquoi en fait parce
qu'on aimerait en fait poussé élections
l'aref jusqu'en f5 pour aller manger
éventuellement le fou 6 et pour attaquer
aussi le rosé betty est fou c'est un
pourquoi parce qu'en fait il me le faut
en g3 déjà il ya une fourchette entre 3
triple fourchette je perds une qualité
et si je mets le fou ici parce que t as
bien sûr et ici on se mange et le fou
généralement il est fort la sphère de
fou aux échecs finalement la pression
est ouvert c'est vraiment une très très
fun
ces quelques très très fort convenable
sont gardés donc sous ses airs est tout
à fait logique parce que on bouge le fou
on dégage le pion f et au contrôle aussi
la case de trois cavaliers et en plus
social ça paraît peut-être offert b3 et
en contrôlant aussi la gamme a3 du canal
qui pourrait bien s'installer ici donc
fou c1 c'est vraiment un cookie qui sert
à beaucoup de choses qui contrôle les
cases qui permet aussi de jouer cinq ans
mais comme tu l'a annoncée bientôt sur
d'attentes un peu sonné cinquième femme
un orchestre garage ça c'est vrai que tu
as raison de vulgariser un petit peu
cette chose là parce que c'est ce
hors-série n'assurait pour ses palaces
hurel de le mettre en a reculé comme ça
mais au final c'est quand même enfin ce
sera sa meilleure case pour l'instant
parce que les jeunes un peu tout le
monde et il a aussi parlé du fait que
les noirs que les rejets de b4 et c5 qui
est très important parce que du coup
bien centré ben il et on va dire figé et
vallée noire pourrait avoir envie de
choses à cavaliers et même si le jeu un
coup comme c'est simple pour ouvrir
justement la diagonale le fu chi pour
arriver ici aux versions de leroy et le
château de 4 1 qui pourrait s'écrouler
si le pion des quatre venaient à partir
de piolenc pour vous aussi un jour est
de faire le ton mais qui était en fait
la ca c'est hyper compliqué voir un peu
comment ça va se passer et mp3 de la
part de great choc qui attaquent
cavaliers cavaliers pour panser car
lié à 3 pour pas perdre de temps
donc avait les bécistes mais différée
qu'à voir les bécistes d'accord bon ben
là ça paraît facile de jouer la position
maintenant fou ou 3 est possible tant on
a un très beau signal et veiller à ce
que relève sarah caucase mais faut 3
pour jouer ça ait dit ou fait trois ans
maintenant ce qu'il y'a plus qu'à les
prendre trois
points dire c'est quand vous avez une
chaîne d'options centrales comme la d45
faut pousser à côté faut faire la
rupture à côté de deux pions de 5 le
sommet de votre chaîne de pions
normalement indique ou de faire la
rupture
donc m'arrive qu'un top 5 c'est naturel
pour ceux qui aiment le jeu en question
là je sais pas ce qu'il a fait quand
scène mais il est en train de donner
raison à
aniche elle michel va revenir tout
content à mon avis heureusement qu'on
n'a rien pas rien là c'est pas nous ça
sent pas bon qu'on magnus je pense à la
fois je vais le garder 4 c 5 yahia qui
avaient des câbles hébert qui
il ya eu cavale et b1
ok peut-être qu'il a un visage et j'ai
vu
alors oui parce qu'il a gênés suis moi
j'avais pas vu qu'il y avait une dame
des deux de la part de
deux griffes chaud je pensais qu'il a
joués fou aux trois tout à fait
naturellement et f4 f5
la sq là du coup ce procès sans que
parce que c'est grave ou pas des glaces
c4 c'est choquant c'est qu'on a
l'impression compliqué est-ce qu'il faut
3 aurait changé quelque chose
prise dans le série à l'étranger
[Musique]
oui il va accoster sur cavaliers prend
il va peut-être mettre son coeur
vaillant des quatre interne peut-être
fossé dans lequel et des cars ou être
l'idée voilà c'est un peu comme une
structure française au final au final on
va jouer contre le plan des cinq maîtres
un cavalier en d4 donc on table le
fugace blanche mais on se dit qu'en
compensation est mort donc avec un outil
fort en d4 qui est indélogeable et ce
depuis honda ça qui est qui a isolé dans
peut-être un jour mettre le foin 3
continue et qu'il a poussée f4 f5 ça
peut être intéressant et c'est sûrement
son idée un
mois j'ai confiance dans le temps
j'ai confiance dans le temps pat je
pense que c'est c'est bon et oui en tout
cas il ya une lente rené peau qui n'est
pas sa position il a proposé une très
rapidement bien défendre avec les blancs
pas terrible ce qui la fait mon poulain
vous nuls hyper vite à vue et blanc
c'est pas trop son style mais bon alors
à quel moment on a fait la dernière
pause j'ai certes un doublement des wii
a peut-être raison on fait une petite
pause et après on voit mal un dada on a
vraiment des pots-de-vin obligatoire
chaque demeure très très fort sous la
coupure pub là stepan bravo social
mais je crois que c'est je crois que tu
as raison je crois que tu as raison et
apprendront fait une dernière à la fin
en fin de partie là c'est le moment
parce que on fait vraiment trois minutes
de pause on revient direct il ya comme
ça on voit le dénouement de cette partie
entre great choqué et magnus voilà allez
après il y aura un quatrième mandat
d'offrir en reste avec nous on se
retrouve tout de suite a tout de suite à
toute une famille
[Musique]
donc
il
[Musique]
à
en
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour les amis pour
ses critiques
pendant la pause le drame avec une
qualité qui a été qui a été perdu par
pas marqué mais il va ce matin il va se
battre dans cette position où il a
encore des chances pratique puisque les
pièces de great chocs sont pas très
belle néanmoins il n'a pas tout
maîtriser clairement sans peut le dire
et il ya en difficulté pour la première
fois des mois va montrer comment il a
perdu la cache j'ai mis le coteau de
pièces comme il ya un hyper intéressant
mais elle a fait rater j'ai dit au
président prend fou à 6 oui mais il a
voulu si vous voulez casser le joli sens
de great choc ça s'était plutôt bien
mais il a oublié en fait ils perdent une
kalach pas vous avez vu avec fou à 6
pouces et 7 il a perdu une qualité
maintenant il est en train d'essayer de
se refaire ce qui est possible qu'on
voit quand même que les pièces montrant
qu'un très active donc
est-ce que great choc d'un poids un
petit peu déconné en plus le fou de
cases noires qu'elle fout distinctif des
noirs puisque les blues n'ont plus
fait mal c'est-à-dire qu'ils contrôlent
beaucoup de cases donc c'est un facteur
qui peut faire que ma news va réussir à
tenir mais il est quand même pour moi en
difficulté de manière assez importante
au niveau matériel humain difficulté du
coup là ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est
changer des pièces que le cir a placé un
peu tout ce qui est sûr les bonnes cases
sigrid parvient à échanger des pièces et
à se placer un petit peu sur enfin à
améliorer ces pièces ont à dire et bien
je vois pas pourquoi il mais ici il a
quand même des choses un rien qu'avec
prudence est roi il ya un pion qui peut
avancer en d3 la part de food calmes
très forte il ya des compensations
rappelons que michel dans le chat à
parier
sur green choqué
[Musique]
plusieurs moments un gris chaud qui est
il et il était vraiment bien dans le
début puis après il a peut-être un peu
imprécis et puis là car le sénat a
vraiment raté un thème tactique je pense
qu'il a complètement raté l'histoire de
la qualité et pour le coup il est en
train quand même de de trouver sa voie
puzzle c'est là qu'on voit qu'on est
quand même humain même quatre scènes qui
rate des choses
et puis un peu de fatigue finalement ils
sont à deux jours de rapide c'est fin de
deuxième journée mine de rien vous savez
on a démarré à 15 heures en même temps
que les joueurs et hier on avait démarre
à 15 heures c'est fini à 22 heures un
petit peu moins mais c'est à peu près ça
aujourd'hui ça va être 15h 19h30 20h
c'est quand même d'aider à prague est
très prenante et le jeu rapide necib
beaucoup d'influx nerveux tout peut se
passer très vite fouad en forme
tactiquement à chaque coup ça peut être
dangereux bâle a effectivement poussins
c'est en train de se compliquer parce
qu'il ya l'histoire de fous ces 3 qui
arrive fossé 3d deux peut-être mangé un
jour ans et 4 c c'est chauvin donc il
faut ces trois salles à 26
parce que vous voyez que la majorité est
le roi des blancs est morte un fait ne
sert à rien les trois contre deux donc
finalement il ya un pion de compensation
plus la perte de fou le pion des trois
îles en train de prendre de la valeur
donc s'il n'est pas perdue s'appelle le
drame
maintenant pratique je commence à bien
aimé que je me sens là il est noir
ces femmes
d'accord avec poussins
les petits fous ces 3 qui arrive moi je
préfère les menant à la gare voyez quel
est le nord c'est la galère il ya déjà
pas ça y est la paire de flambe le
provençal est un peu critique à craquer
mais il est en train de
souffrir il a peu de temps aussi un il a
peu de temps la part de fouet c'est vous
avez devient en fait il y avait du
contrôle jeu grâce aux options passait
évidemment cela en fait
j'ai une théorie là-dessus parce que je
me suis aperçu que dans les partis ça se
produisait souvent la théorie de la
décompression après avoir encaissé le
matos si on le voit assez souvent des
coups un petit peu apprécié le fait de
digérer le matériel si tu veux et c'est
un peu ce qui s'est passé avec great
chaud que je pense qu'il a été moins
précis au moment où il a gagné la
qualité et c'est le moment plus
important pour valoriser valider les
avantages matériels et maintenant c'est
chaud c'est hyper agence de pub bien
c'est pas intéressant or très souvent
voir une partie d'échec quand on place
une combinaison ou coup choses tactiques
gamme des matériels pas très souvent
pense qu'on a gagné la partie et on se
relâche et c'est à ce moment là en fait
qu'on gaffe kong aph et
10 mois est ce que tu penses ses fans
que je devrais écrire une thèse sur la
théorie la décompression
en tout cas je te citerai un intervalle
c'est très intéressant à continue
t'arrête pas ça va ça va donner donner
quelques belles citations dans cette
dans cette thèse sur la théorie de la
conspiration non mais c'est vrai en plus
et alors on s'est passé selon ces
personnes dans la partie
on vous imagine un peu car athènes a
sacrifié pour que personne à rater un
cette prise de qualité quasiment sur un
cauchemar au tac il laisse à crissier et
donc du coup il était mal barré et c'est
là un je pense ainsi aux critiques la
d'ivoire car c'est ne vais pas de compte
en est du coup
c'est relâche à son droit d'être
contents ils pensaient qu'ils allaient
gagner et au final
il il gaffe enfin il a pas fait de
grosse gaffe mais le travail je découvre
normaux zone plutôt où se trouvaient des
meilleurs coups et là on voit que la
pollution maintenant bain
plutôt en faveur de fait très très peur
traite cette position je dois avouer que
là
où elle a joué avec peu de temps on veut
voir
à chaque coup il est en oui mais tout en
danger maintenant il ya le plan fous ces
quatre à cinq à quatre baies 3 1 assez
basiquement
ce que je peux pas jouer ça ne lave pas
bien à voir ce qui se passe mélange pas
où mais sur l'échiquier ce n'est pas de
mon ressort
il a joué on voit qu'il a commencé à
pousser planche pour 1,4 carlson
à quels horaires on est en retard je me
concentre sur la position uniquement pas
sur les cartes
on en retard j'essaye de me dire que
c'est après que le roi eut vu en f1 doit
avoir un à cinq
hockey qui avait un faux procès quatre
que par qui on prend 1,5 et le rock est
venu jusqu'en informa le plan à 5 à 4
donc oui mais cette poussée le show qui
va être vert et je pense que ce que je
veux faire à caral scène c'est à 5 à 4
baies 3 et sur qui on prend cette fin à
3 à 2 à 1 l'idée typique 1
je pourrais faire b3 et sur pions
préemption prend ses mais en fait le fou
contre internet hasard et donc du coup
c'est quand même plus sympa de ramener
le pion en a trois et après à deux et
après un une fois qu'on a dévié le pion
à 2 grâce à pétrole quelle horreur s'il
perd cette position franchement c'est
laurent blanc doit s'en vouloir
mais maintenant c'est plus facile
clairement à jouer avec des noirs
rappelle deux choses doivent pas savoir
des fois pour tout vous dire si c'est
gagnant pas gagné mais ils savent que
c'est plus facile c'est une pression à
de résultats pour les noirs maintenant
sont d'autres oui car c'est rare qu'ils
jouent pour gagner qui a du temps la
pendule est née quand même plus
confortable sinon il ya o'neal qui nous
demande et j'avais vu la question des
origines il tue la pause est tout à
l'heure et on tape a répondu est-ce que
à part le titre de champion du monde
classique c'est sont à plus prestigieux
ou pas du tout ben c'est difficile à
dire parce que pour moi le plus
prestigieux ça reste tous les tournois
en lan qui existent autrement hormis
choplin du monde ya la coupe du monde
c'est très prestigieux il ya des gros
gros tournois style
un
style chorus etc enfin les gros tournoi
fermé
et sinon après arrive dans un second
temps les jeux pré rapide comme le
chocolat du monde de rapidex sais pas ce
que tu en penses quoi
bon un titre c'est un titre 1 après
je pense que c'est à l'appréciation de
chacun de donner plus d'importance à un
tournoi qu'à un autre là ça reste du
blitz du rapide donc c'est moins on va
dire des échecs quand on voit deux
parties lentes par exemple la buse kenzy
gros tournoi et qui utiliseront le pays
bas c'est un tournoi où il ya peut-être
les 5 milliard gens du monde en tournois
qui sont représentés gagné de tournoi
c'est monstrueux championnat du monde de
bled c'est rapide bien sûr le niveau le
plateau est monstrueux c'est trop fort
c'est aussi très fort mais après pour
moi où il ya à titre de champion du
monde sa race camargue champion du monde
même si c'est du rapide doublé tout quoi
que ce soit pour moi
pour moi
voilà
je pense ça dépend tellement ça va vite
qu'est ce que le prestige ne dit pas
tout
questionnement philosophique de pâtes ou
non mais voilà comme je devrais je sais
le linge reste
je reste sur ma lancée même si c'est une
compétence particulière d'abord pendant
le jeu rapide c'est très spectaculaire
très impressionnant mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le combat quand les
joueurs ont du temps bon bah pas si
facile alors attendre qu'on fait sur
foot y avait deux fois la soif ou si un
v2 là c'est un cauchemar c'est un
cauchemar
voilà c'est ça après x 3
c'était c6 qui a été joué donc c'est au
noir ce que même la b2 peu qu'elles
servent le soutien je sais rien je te
bouges féminin massa vainqueur encore
pour fourguer soutenant que je vais
venir piquer le pion celle-ci s'apprêt à
wissous dans l'essonne
tu vas devoir faire tourner la balle
je vais le pion sait si cette manche
celle-ci
cgt pas les bras le tient quand même la
mêlée de danse ont paralysé à cause du
fou moi je moi je donne 1
un gardois
recept à tuer un gain de ratés nous dit
stéphane
[Musique]
mais c'est chaud pour les deux joueurs
vous savez un dans cette transposition
alors le gars de rater ce monsieur il
est ici que le tour de vis de son
ordinateur
huawei vision pas si facile mais en même
temps et là pour le coup c'est trouvable
fallait et pourquoi b2 marchait pas
avant très vite
la partie mais
donc là je regarde dans le classement
pour l'instant je ne vois que tout le
monde a fait du lin quasiment à part le
genre ouzbek a better off qui bat volta
sexe non je vois et doujaïl et dubaï en
train de jouer un coup d'oeil en train
de jouer n'a pas fini de taille joue en
réaction à la mort de ce conte buts à 1
à 2 secondes voire d'audace de secondes
avant que c'est mon poulain juste pour
voir ouailles encore plein de pièces à
temps non mais c'est pas la position
c'est l'impression que tout à l'heure
voilà il ya plus beaucoup de bien à tout
type y sommes plus pour godard faut que
le reposer mais on va dire que c'est ça
au hasard
un beau match nul cette position
moi je pense alors bon mon petit doigt
me dit que
alors il va pas rater il n'a pas raté va
le faire tourner et s'est tournée pour
gagner ce prix ok on est à mi chemin du
sault va rester sur magnus whitmarsh a
mangé la pièce alors que s'est passé
rapidement ses six trous c'est un b deux
tours
ok donc
créer tous qu'il va essayer de sacrifier
laquelle jouer la pièce pour entrer là
dedans est-ce que c'était parce que ça
enfin tient simple ce qui te plaît
parce que sinon après il va perdre son
pion pour rien menaces échec avec dame
daria dont un molière du coup voilà nuls
maintenant donc cette finale deux tours
3 compte de l est généralement assez
facile à défendre
il ce que vous avez à faire juste pour
faire un nul
mettez votre droit le plus haut possible
et 10 millions de style boudreau non je
voudrais pas après monte à tiques qui à
21 ans au fait que je pensais que magnus
à les pousser en fait la position
c'est ce qui se passait d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui s'est passé sauf que et là il a
laissé échapper et après ils jouent
trois contes de voilà un nul ça c'est
dans sa cellule as élémentaire et déçu
d'ailleurs on voit sa tête qu'il est
qu'il est très déçu jeudi qu'il a raté
quelque chose ouais il a des choses
somme était bien payé mais la langue
dans l'ultra zai note effectivement
comme à chaque fois on a vu qu'ils
avaient été très très fort
greene choc clairement mais là on voit
on voit aussi tu vois carsen il est
détendu on voit très bien que la
nouvelle est facile que ds leur finale
donc là le résultat at on a 80 vous
attendez et les blancs pas pourrait
servir chaque fois
échangé un pion enfin c'est vraiment
assez facile on peut spéculer je vois
que jude a fini comme obsession
comme ça ta mémoire revers à gagner
lâche un petit instant ou alors gagné
l'a fait une dame il a réussi à faire ça
la dame qu'est ce qu'il est fort grosse
opération comme pour d'hydra
nous
il va souffrir énormément avec les noirs
et il va sauter un homme aimant je sais
pas si c'est si bien que ça qu'ils aient
gagné pour le rapport
quelle mauvaise foi
du dax qui passe en tête qui va
probablement être rejoint par par quatre
scènes et
25 à sa cellule et on sait qu ils se
parlent dernière ronde comme ça les
joueurs se parleraient
donc là je pense que j'ai 6
je sais ce qu'ils on prend et roy g7
s'est lassé l'annulation standard garder
le 6 puis on prend 3,17 et en fait du
coup les banques peuvent plus bouger
parce que après les pions cavale on
n'aime pas trop ça
à voir le roi bout je mange le pion et
on a final qui est assez standard ce qui
s'appelle la fameuse finale filles d'or
qui fait nul assez facilement qu'il faut
connaître ma part faire un court depuis
maintenant
mais si jamais la tour partait de la
septième rangée et ben je pourrais faire
et chaque facilement et récupérer le
pion angers 6 avec les blancs n'ont rien
de mieux à faire que d'attendre et moi
aussi je vais attendre sur ma santé me
ranger est en fait c'est nul très
facilement donc donc j'essaie c'est une
bonne manière de pouvoir faire nul sans
souci ça c'est marrant de voir débriefer
aussi ils ont pas vu la même chose tu
vois ils sont tous les deux surpris
maman rapides ils ont vu beaucoup de
choses des deux joueurs mais savent pas
tout parce que la pollution était
vraiment très complexe qui sont entrain
débriefer de voir un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé vous voyez ça va ça va vite
walesa pas trop en voir
c'était hyper complexe il n'avait pas
beaucoup de temps pour ben oui c'est
vraiment là ces voix là il on rigole ils
ont trouvé que c'était assez fou ils
sont assez contents tous les deux parce
que ça a été un rebondissement va cesser
c'est rigolo mais voir comme ça on n'a
pas vu ce genre de scène à chaque fois
les fois là les gens se marrent
directement là on a un vieux qui lisait
pas mal pas mal commenté leur parti moi
tu vois que les journées passaient pas
qu'ils prennent du plaisir tous les
dehors vous le savez pas c'est que
l'accès s'est départi de folie ce débat
la folie et puis ça les oblige à être
dans une certaine zone d'inconfort en
fait ils n'ont pas tout maîtriser ça
qu'il faut savoir ils ont ils laissent
leurs intuitions leur calcul mais
rapidement parler c'est pas évident pour
moi en tout cas c'est très intéressant
beau combat encore de carlson et great
chaud et qui se font dépasser
apparemment par d'houdain le poulain de
dust off mais c'est vraiment l'horreur
entre ça et donc alors fi route déjà
qu'est ce que ça a donné pour fear ocha
je chantais pas oublier ah oui mais moi
aussi j'ai oublié de te regarder mon ami
mon rôle il à
la fin cela ce match nul contre contre
vannes forest actemra
s'était pas passé cette grosse partie
aussi
maxime à gagner donc on l'avait vu un
petit peu la partie c'était assez assez
expéditif donc finalement on se retrouve
dans une situation telle deux points ils
ont un demi point mccaw mais deux
couleurs si
je fais pas de bêtises si je dis pas de
bêtises
alors je vais pas m'en vais pas me
voir non je ne me retrouvais pas je
pense je pense que tu encore toutes ses
chances de gagner oui surtout j'ai fait
va de soi il faut pas une mauvaise
journée
donc du tout alors en tête nous avons
great food et carlson qui ont rejoint
duda qui était le premier à marquer le
point e
pour m pour arriver en tête et à six
points sur huit maintenant est bon on a
cinq joueurs sur la butte en main on la
met pas mener hachey on a beau tout à
rock créé la surprise en quarts elle
aussi n'a je bavarde car eev et qu'elle
fonde toujours présent
des joueurs sont pas par hasard et or au
delà qu'à moi qui ai quand même
normalement un des grands favoris de la
discipline main rapide il se balade pas
ton serait la cinquième 1000 1 point de
retard elle a aussi calmement comme on
le disait hier nakamura il n'a pas le
sur un vrai chantier depuis quasiment
deux ans et non c'est vrai pas de chez
les pièces non mais en valais la grèce
c'est pas pareil quand tu joues sur
internet et quand tu arrives sur un vrai
chic et tu tu calcules par-delà reis et
c'est un peu difficile à s'acheter un
échiquier dg télé pour la maison
n'ont donc du coup peut-être que ça joue
aussi on verra ce qu'ils ont envie est
en tout cas parce que le blitz est quand
même sa meilleure cadence
à malakal laquelle il vous a bien qui a
très bien réglée avec la prime ou même
bien vraiment un culte qui me met
doucement moi je pense en fait quand je
regarde la casse tribune qu'une fois
sourire de regarder tellement
impressionnant j'aime bien ça serait
bien et des fois ça va ça m'arrive de le
regarder streamé
et j'ai l'impression que en fait naked
encore plus fort quand il parle aux gens
et quand il sait qu'on regarde en fait
il est très fort c'est pas faux et se
motive en fait ils se motivent est bon
la deûle et ça il ne peut pas parler
quoi j'me va parler pour la tribu pari à
tarbes
après là je pense qu'il a envie aussi de
jouer car hauts-de-seine il n'a pas du
tout envie d'être juste
je ce trimestre c'est à dire je pense
qu'il veut prouver à ses revues qui
beaucoup moins seul estime énormément
ben je pense qu'il veut prouver des
choses et puis pour le point tous à
d'autres et aussi ces extreme donc
effectivement il a tout intérêt à bien
figurer en laye a pas perdu une partie
il me semble qu'il a fait que des nuls
c'est les 2000 points qui lui manquent
mais force est de constater que il doit
se battre
vous avez classement un jour ça fait
pour lui et magnus quand une grosse
grosse impression franchement oui ben là
les trois les trois co leaders la dou da
green shoots carlo scène très très bonne
impression et derrière c'est des joueurs
qui ont tout le temps été devant a
maintenant fait de cfc le seul dont on
n'a quasiment pas parlé on l'a vu
arriver quand même aujourd'hui sinon
tous les joueurs on a beaucoup beaucoup
parlé mais c'est vraiment un combat qui
est difficile quand on sait qu du board
ou bof il est vraiment très très fort en
partie rapide et blitz et qu'il est 14e
avec cinq et dix ans et c'est une belle
galère un tout tout et tout est dur et
je vois un je n'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu une petit message de marc
big sue malheureusement encore modérée
pour lui
c'est bon
[Rires]
peut-être que pour une fois il l'a pas
fait exprès et dans ce cas c'est dommage
mais à ces vérités qui désole vassaux
réa
je voulais marquer la lorelei son
message en fait
un lit raisin mi-raisin il n'est pas
encore bastoon il n'est pas encore foutu
parce que il encore sonné l'hallali
raisin il a juste
perdu une partie contre manu sont faites
donc ça reste des tournois qui sont
exceptionnels
néanmoins là il est un peu glissé au
classement il est là comme à cinq et
demi ce qui est tout à fait correct il
induit points de la quatrième place et
un point de la première place donc il ya
rien
rien de dangereux pour lui il ya moins
de joker pour tout simplement on vous
rappelle le format du tournoi il ya eu
cinq partis aujourd'hui on a quatre nous
en reste une et ensuite demain à partir
de 15 heures ça sera le dénouement se
joue pas du monde rapide avec les quatre
dernières parties donc à partir de 15
heures ce sera la grosse bataille avec
ma les chocs ils vont arriver avec
beaucoup plus dangereux ça promet déjà
on a fait un clip choc à la scène
c'était sympa devant leur petit échange
de 2 fin de match on a quand même bien
rigolé on voyait les joueurs n'étaient
pas forcément d'accord mais avec
beaucoup de respect ils n'avaient pas
vécu les mots chose ils se parlaient de
différents moments différents feeling
qu'ils avaient eues et ça avait l'air
d'être assez cocasse on aurait bien aimé
les écouter et vous serez en anglais
donc toute mort est traduit tous et
chrysler mais sans reptile était sans
fin il me faudrait les micros des
joueurs maintenance trouver pas mal de
tête mon bien tout avoir
traducteur en plus
en plus en plus
là je pense que d'où d'un cartel n'a pas
joué encore d'accord non non non c'est
tout d'anna pas perdus
sont pas joués jusque là du coup je
pense qu'on va avoir droit maintenant un
doute à 40 cède donc tout à fait d'avoir
des blancs cartney avoir les noirs on te
serais un carlson duda et aigri choot ce
serait bien de le voir je suis contre de
maipo passerait de belles affiches quand
même un yes sim le tout le moins il est
en présentiel et on a les caméras des
joueurs donc c'est assez agréable à
suivre forcément et là on a vu un
dernier échange
les caméras elle valorise les moment
justement où les joueurs sont un peu
vert d'ailleurs alireza tout à l'heure
quand il était en grande difficulté
contre man u seront voyait qu
il laissait apparaître sur son visage
ouais le fait qu'il était très mal
mais là il ya eu un bel échange entre
ajustements great choqué et magnus où
ils rigolaient de cette partie un petit
peu folle qui s'est produite sur la
france est hyper chaud je pense que les
deux il savait pas trop où il était et
après au final un peu plus plate à 3.2
et salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
en tout cas gros gros événement est ce
qu'on fait la pause avant de redémarrer
je vois pas ce que c'est peut-être le
plus sympa parce que ça comme ça on
revient et on s'arrêtera apparemment
milieu et derrière
trois minutes de pause 3 minutes de
pause et après on est parti pour la
dernière ronde de cette journée le
quatrième match de la journée voilà les
weeks où tu connais
stéphane a expliqué les choses tu fais
intéressant visant encore mais emmanuel
est dégoûté aussi mais ça nous est
imposée par clay score mais en plus ce
sera peut-être la dernière fois en plus
après on enchaîne de même aller à ce
moment ça mais non il ralliera une
dernière au milieu mais on est obligé à
ses forces et on est tous comme melun
points mais une demi heure de jeu voici
des mails attention il faut faire des
pauses enfin on est obligé de faire des
pauses c'est comme ça et en fait si vous
voulez qu est ce qu un contrat avec
switch et du coup on est vraiment forcé
de faire des pauses c'est tout ce qui
nous l'imposent enquête avec c'est le
confort c'est stéphane le coup force et
la master class de stéphane sur le
confort c'était voilà
on sait qu'en allemagne où elle a tout
de suite plu plutôt n'est pas fait il
revient exactement on va vous manquer
vie à tous a tout de suite
[Musique]
à
le
[Musique]
e
le
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
tous
vous
[Musique]
et
en
et nous sommes de retour donc les
joueurs qui sont quand s'installer pour
cette dernière partie nous a tous de la
deuxième journée des championnats du
monde de rapides alors on a les
appariements qui vient enfin d'arriver
alors je pense quand tous les intéresse
c'est ce que tu veux pas qu'un petit peu
on voit un petit fille rosa chefs
syndicaux
cela m'a
sauvé c'est hideux de
la cara scène duda cette avancée
nakamura fedoseyev jobard à guy choot
mois s'écoulent à ce qu'on avait dit
après mais il est né pauvre
con créateuf mvl
sépare innove qui rit car sinon on se
retrouve garrier ce n'est pas ces cas là
plutôt un bon apparemment pour les peaux
même si bon il avait noir c'est ce que
j'espère c'est ce que j'espère pour rien
de caché
en fait l'ac la soirée parfaite c'est tu
sais bien c'est clair qu'ils accolent à
mathon petit yann christophe et du kun
hee poki qui avec les noirs gagne sa
petite partie et on a passé une bonhomie
et français a là on affirme aux doigts
qui jouent contre cherche un coach
écossais c'est le joueur alors il l'a
fait il a fait un gros truc lorsque cela
est fait
c'est un l'ukrainien qui montrent un
jeune il a 25 ans maintenant et
je crois qu'elle a gagné un gros tournoi
il ya peu de temps plein comme semir
quoi mais vraiment un très bon joueur
shevchenko et mvl j'avais dit que je me
doubliez concrètement je crois qu'on
créateurs les pompiers ont craint pas
facile d'accès mais le malheureux de
bach ou non qui détiennent un temps du
moins c'est ça en gardant en huitièmes
de finale je crois à la coupe du monde
donc c'était un match un peu sans dessus
dessous et c'est parti en tout cas ouais
ça va arriver sur nos écrans on peut
vous dire on va garçonne kit installé 12
ha qui n'est pas encore arrivé
duda qui a gagné partie qui sont comme
en c1 tu vois c'est pas les gens en ont
marre de ce rythme là ils sont pas tous
à table alors que ça a démarré c'est
clair ce avant demain avant les premiers
coups arrivée sur les échiquiers et
magnus il n'a pas d'adversaire est ce
que woods a abandonné un tournoi dans de
da est arrivé il s'est installé dans la
vie ça va et ça discute pas du tout
parce que là c'est la part du suisse à
lui faire c'est la partie tant attendu
et là je vous dis les gars on va tous
soutenir duda sur notre site en tout cas
j'espère que tu es avec moi on va faire
un petit
allez la cave deux minutes pour voter
doute à aucun scène
la petite de petits sauvages alors moi
je sais que alors écoutez bien je garde
un truc hein c'est aussi car cellules
encore les blancs je sois venu en
urgence et met 15 cl vous soutenez
stouff vous devez voter à duda par
contre si vous votez carlson et ben ça
va le poids c'est donc en fait moi
j'essaie de voir un peu ce que ce que
vous voulez faire en tout cas bien
évidemment tous pour nous à un an plus
doux d'acquis qui joue qui joue chez lui
je crois qu'il est il exactement ah oui
les polonais du
droit joue à domicile je vois domicile
et wii
fit chilienne c'est bon ça tu vois il
avait joué à 4h50 rené peau samassa
s'est mal passé maintenant il veut si
c'est ce qui c'est que 46 son client et
qui va du col et donc une baisse du yen
nulle somme va parce que les noirs
j'imagine que je t'offre nul ça lui va
mais il ne donne pas envie de voter nous
donnera jamais se
noue
nous franchement la choisissez la voie
de la raison je voulais dire
c'est 6n donc là j'ai pas encore il ya
eu un cavalier en c6 jouer mais c'est
pas moi c'est de voir si la haye l'aveu
h4 oulala attend ses pas sur la dernière
partie que ça va on va essayer de
changer de vue là tiens quand même à
ruth je commence je comprends pas je
prenais pour quelqu'un de sérieux hier
mais alors là je fais confiance à se
trouve sur duda mai la has et tu te fais
même influencé je dirais c'est plus le
terme juste une histoire de confiance
est
là il y en a un problème on y vend à
roanne j'ai un petit problème de ces
l'impression que ça va encore couper
casse comme vous le savez louis
picamoles
face à petit sa petite verlan de 4 c 5 à
3 mais à haut niveau cette petite
variante ça ne marche pas au seulement
63% pour qu'arsène ouf on s'en sort
merci à tous ceux qui ont voté car
assène la voix de la raison et ce tout
va du soutien quand même
dans le chat mais ça ne suffit pas
carson voix de la scène il est au dessus
il a les blancs mais vous allez voir en
tout cas je remercie tous ceux qui ont
voté pour carlson parce que vous l'avez
bien passé dès maintenant vous allez
voir qu'il va se voir juste à manger par
l'entraîneur ans qui joue à domicile
bon on n'a pas de chance là pour à
chaque fois que c'est le dernier match
vous savez bazbaz desquesnes partie en
attendant à se suivre d'access comme
plante casse un peu moins parce que
lorsque tout le monde veut la voir cette
partie donc que là vous la voyez un
petit peu sur la caméra on fait ce qu'on
peut c'est ce que m'a planté
web en crash mais ce dernier ces
quelques secondes si on va un peu
bizarrement
ça c'est clair
mais c'est pas génial génial alors
est-ce qu'on va récupérer quelque chose
j'aimerais que la position de ce que
c'est
dans ces cas là où ça risque ont fait à
chaque fois on fait la promo pour nos
chaînes stouff dans ces cas là on fait
la promo pour casse comme un fair use
tube voilà quand les caméras et surtout
les échiquiers n'apparaissent pas on
vous dit à chaque fois aller voilà le
youtube caisse comme et faire aller voir
la chaîne 2 to est allé voir la chaîne
près volution échec nous ferez plaisir
et n'hésitez pas à nous suivre parce
qu'il y aura d'autres stream version
échec
beau moyen de prendre du plaisir encore
surtout pendant la période scolaire donc
n'hésitez pas à regarder les plannings
respectifs
voilà voilà et est ce que pensera et oui
ça a débloqué l'échiquier avec une
variante hyper rare pour
pour d'idra qui a joué avant qu'un
cavalier 6 au deuxième coup stuff et du
coup je comprenais pas trop bien pendue
maintenant je vois très bien mais je
vois pas enfin se débloquer bref encore
un petit peu à perdre
donc sicilienne rare pour pour bouddha
très rarement à haut niveau et a très
mauvaise réputation cette variante qui a
été jouée par un bouddha attention il a
travaillé même s'il la joue là en rapide
les joueurs ils ont vraiment vraiment
travailler les ouvertures et ya pas deux
essais qui s'est dit qu'ils n'avaient
pas de souci
donc il a peut-être une idée je sais
qu'il ya deux grandes lignes dans cette
variante cavaliers m6 qui pose problème
au noir oui c'est sûr verdict ce qui
nous vient apparemment sais pas si ça
c'était juste pour perdre ne jouerez pas
ça et même d'un mix où il fait des bons
commentaires aussi je sais pas ce que tu
en penses stouff mais ba remix ou c'est
du gros commentaires à la con change pas
une équipe qui gagne
inbar mix où c'était limite lier de le
ban nature un bon lancement vers
généraux je n'aime pas la possibilité de
le faire je vais au départ juste pour
voir un peu ce que c'est ouais c'est
hyper intéressante car à 9,6 ok ok
ok
voilà
oui le h4 caractéristiques d'un genre
position pour gagner le droit à la
bataille en tout cas il y aura des
assemblées doivent purger trois fous des
trois fois quart des thématiques on
prend l'espace et je pense qu'on va
faire le camp rock 1 jour c'est de taper
sur le plan des sept qui est un poil
arriérés quand même
et mes chansons il ya plusieurs joueurs
âge
c'est sûr que si doux d'ajouts ça en
étant en étant comment dirais-je aussi
fort dans un tournoi majeur quand même
sa reine du rapide c'est qu'il a
travaillé ceux qui considèrent que ça
tient très bien voilà ça y'a pas de
souci là dessus mais c'est quand même
étonnant puisque cette variante est là
camp de base mauvaise réputation mais la
théorie fluctue évolué et il ya des
choses qui sont remis au goût du jour
quand c'est un très bon joueur qui ont
bien travaillé avec leurs équipes
respectives
se disent que la rende maintenant tient
alors qu'on croyait qu'elle ne tenait
plus photo que 40e je pense pas qu'il
ait préparé cette ouverture
non mais n'a pas l'air non plus à rien
c'est impressionnant elle à la roque est
bon avait une position comme sous
contrôle un pas deux
voilà après il ya 15 ans quand il ya un
gros enjeu dans cette partie un bar à by
xor je sais pas peut-être tester des
choses à ce stade la ddt pour moi ça
peut être dangereux quand même hein faut
vraiment être sûr de soi quand je dirais
qu'ils sont en tête tous les deux ce
plat du monde
enfin je crois que la barbie que s'il
est fatigué il va bientôt retourner
faire une c est ça que là il est en
train de vraiment de
nous dire tout ce qui lui passe par la
tête il a placé son filtre du bar bkx
sans filtre ça peut vite être un peu
n'importe quoi on vous le dira méfiez
vous de ceux qui regardent trop le chat
les propos de marvin peuvent devenir
incohérent en plus on a passé dix neuf
heures on a passé 19 heures
souvent après 19 heures il ya eu l'apéro
qui est passé par là on sait bien et 8
9% l'an prochain regardez quelqu'un
je fais on le sait la banque lazard et
jacou pense que c'est encore bloquées à
son échiquier parce que je vois qu'il ya
eu mais c'est ça elle sait qu'on paie
sage qui hier matin et si jamais je je
je vois la
salle un petit peu c'est qu'au niveau
international il avait l'air
il avait l'air
en avance ouais ben moi je ne suis pas
bizarre bizarre je vais les regarder
ce com qui me refusent d'entrer
on va pas grand chose malheureusement
à ça commence à revenir
mais gare en avance et ses revenus à
leur taille est bon donc il faut baisser
hâtive ces quatre vous prendre qu'elle
va déprendre est grande moi j'aime bien
cette pression pour les blanches
salaires c'est vraiment difficile pour
les noirs
ok vous voyez tous le pion 17 et
arriérés le plan blanc autour des deux
tours d un qui peut arriver
mettre un cavalier en 1/4 aussi à terme
par la position c'est difficile en fait
faudrait pouvoir faire des six sa vague
et noir car c'est ni l'ami saddam en c3
pour garder un oeil sur fion g7 comme ça
des six n'est pas injouable
ouais moi j'aime bien ce que l'accident
qui a attaqué sur ce revenu dans l'ordre
maintenant on est
[Musique]
on est ok complètement jamais beaucoup
d'hommes soit parce que c'est assez
prophylactique sur g7 genre sur des
sites par exemple il pourrait y avoir
des problèmes à bâle contre angers 7
mais il faut d'abord manger une fois en
d6 voilà mais manger et après manger ici
c'est l'idée et du coup ça empêche un
peu ces idées-là de plus des 6 lors des
5 je prends en passant aussi ça ça
transport rail un salut redire hot
et là on voit une domination enfin le
l'ouverture pour l'instant je ne parais
paimpol et carlson qui pille on sait les
positions qu'ils aiment encore une fois
il va améliorer donc de froid b1 les
torrents des deux baies 3 améliorer la
position que l'on est obligé 4
je sais pas comment on peut rendre les
attelages ça vaut aussi pour se fixer un
petit peu là le roi mais en fait on peut
y trouver vraiment amélioré toutes ses
pièces comme d'hab alors peut être que
les noirs au moins d espace et moins de
consulter la huit cavaliers en cinq ans
baissé qui fait un peu la gueule
chaque page dit si ça peut être
compliqué
mais duda il est quand même très très
fort il va trouver des choses à faire
dames 10 3 a été réussi à y revient on
est 3 qui les maracas elle attend lé
fait trop c'est trop pour moi et je
comprenais pas d'emmener trois je suis
mais qu'elle n'annonce un dc10 vu juste
en paix si le rock mais tour des 3 du
coup ils veulent web c'est logique fonda
et en organique sur des lits tour d2 il
est fait autour des trois
dames 4 rien du tout il ya juste fou
j'ai trois sans doute et après on fait
un plan un trou d un
non mais ça va être une position de
domination et je pense que carlson il
adore ce que l'on position enfin c'est
ce qu'on a vu depuis le départ du
travail est-ce qu'on pourrait jouer
servat 17 grand roc s'est vite des cinq
dépôts est ce que c'est pour eux sur les
grands enjeux autour des 1 et dessins
qu'il n'y a pas à cause de prises est
toujours qui ont j'espère qui est
toujours en l'air et cap seine derrière
quoi j'arrive pas à le faire
parce que je me retienne débarrasser de
ce problème quand même mois ces quatorze
clubs angers7
marrant car ce n est pas très bien malin
est une bonne position très solide
autour des échiquiers à une attaque y
arriver aux deux contres fedoseyev il ya
quand même il ya quand même des baux
alors la caf et 2 août et vos petits
chefs a alors moi j'ai déjà vu de la
camorra mais de mettre 10 01 fedoseyev
sur vos cascades en stream est là mais
là ça va être différent comme contexte
est différent toujours sur une partie
mais je parle du match mais je pense que
le concept quand même deux bêtes noires
tout ça doit jouer la psychologie
l'accession d'internet et du coup je
donnerai un bel avantage à nakamura
d'entre eux dans cette confrontation ma
passion est là les blancs ils jouent
ultra vite même si là
on n'a pas nécessairement les temps
on peut les vendre un peu un petit peu
je vois d'agri tour quand même c'est
quand même des trucs idiots sur les
têtes sur les stars parce que
franchement c'est ce qui anime et
hongrois caruana revenir aussi un voix
kawa d'en revenir
un dépôt aussi qu'il faudra pas oublier
je te rappelle mais poussés qu'il est
pauvre
c'est qu'il est pour demain
[Rires]
ok donc la paix en tout cas vaso blanche
d'obama de solides 1
d'augmentation sans risque qui arrivera
à ses chiens ses chiens great chaud et
il peut faire peut-être plus un joueur
pourquoi ils essaieraient pas dans cette
position est posé quelques problèmes au
noir il ya vraiment aux eris la paire de
crocs n'est pas assez forte dans cette
position vous voyez que le fou aussi ce
travail est assez mal et elles font b6
même s'il travaille il n'est pas
incroyable compterait faire cavalier des
cats au delà
on va pouvoir mettre une petite pression
à terme sur les noirs sans risque et au
pire même ne serait pas avec ta
extrêmement mauvais en tout cas j'en
bave à il fait un trou droit monstrueux
alors née procès manche michel il
s'associe à toi pour
tailler des belles
dames et des positions déjà hyper
bizarre alors c'est incroyable à ce
processus avec d'un métro à la c1
gleizes egbe 3 avec dame v3 qui a nom
conquête je pensais que c'était la
langue anglaise avec ses 4 je peux pas
le faire il a joué encore ni pervis de
regards il a quatorze minutes on la
connaît celle là cette anglaise avec un
bac à la lecture si potentiellement
marosi si on arrive à faire le 5 1 jour
agrainoirs il l'a pas laissé le fait le
coeur griefs et new un voyage le foot
français systématique pour doubler les
pions qui donne un énorme jeu au noir
parce que là il a prudemment français tu
es maintenant dépôt est en train
d'essayer d'aller chercher le ko avec
ses pièces et l'affaiblissement du petit
rock la partie va être jugé niall le
soutien
deux griefs il est il est merdique il
n'y a pas d'autre mot est du coup le
très ambitieuse café café dépôt
clairement 4,5 hyper intéressant ce
qu'il a fait et voilà cet opéra c'est
une belle partie regarde 3 et 7 après h4
s'est tendu parce qu'en fait c'est vrai
que là on voit toutes les peurs
d'enfants noirs donc le foot c'est une
mauvaise pièce il ya un pion de plus
pour les blancs mais en fait il ya un
retard de développement avec cigales des
fonctions tous faibles et le droit qui
est tout seul un virage 4 super et de 16
h 4 arrivant je suis d'attaqué sur la
colonne accès
web très joli coup de b4 pour aller
à la baston
au
moins ils libèrent le cavalier et
guerrier se laisse pas faire au niveau
du temps on le voit
[Musique]
rien sans la tentation si jamais je des
cap caval dans ces cinq ça peut poser
des problèmes blanc au noir quand même
hein enfin à toi je suis quand même
assez réac sont là megharia qui avaient
vite répandue d'une époque il est
toujours très très vite c'est une
pression autant
voir un peu comment ça se passe là c'est
une position que c'est un peu gâtées
c'est tout ce qui est qui qui est hyper
intéressante est en tout cas
qualifié de casse gueule parce que vous
voyez les très déséquilibrée six régions
déconne ça peut aller très vite dans un
sens ou dans l'autre est-ce qu'on
n'irait pas voir
maxime
et alireza on aura fait un tour des
échiquiers
avec maxime qui a fait attaquer par des
moustiques maxi louis giard à ce
problème je vois dire en bretagne
au moins de leur ad'ailleurs
donc mc solutions à blizzard à la taxe
sur la coban h sur le pion h4 ça à la
rivère intéressant moi j'aime bien ce
qu'il fait là faire trois ou quatre
tours g4 seilam naas ans avec la prison
bratic obligés de mouiller on adore
cas et des cinq romans hi-fi règlement
si je mourais des 500 un bon coup pour
l'homme quand vous faites attaquer
échange les pièces un comme ça vous
calmer les ardeurs de votre adversaire
cavalière 4 été monstrueux faut aussi
c'est intéressant
donc là on peut peut-être pas aussi la
suite fou prend des 5 et 34
après ils te regarder le cajon iso pas
qu'il ya ce coup aussi à proposer un
critère intéressant je garde la maison
moi je n'ai pas envie de donner mon
cavalier f4 ouais en fait ça me permet
de pouvoir quand même faire purger
quatre alors je sais pas ce que ça donne
- là-haut pire f3
hockey ouais mais tu as quand même des
concessions ce fou qui mauvais le case
marques sont ouvertes c'est vrai on
atteint là sa plus grande mais
le 6 mai
naturellement on a envie de manger de
manger ici pour pour continuer la tacc
manger comme ça et mes deux fois en
dix-sept manger h4 mais j'ai cavaliers
g2 aussi entourage 4 qui est intéressant
beaucoup de
classe et très intéressant mais on voit
on voit qu'un contrat qu'offrent les
blancs qui est quand même sous pression
enfin tout en compte un but la plus
belle région de france
généralement tape attendre sa problème
je peux me choque en plein mois tu vois
je pense à tous les gens qui en france
n'habite pas en bretagne si je sais que
c'est dur je sais que c'est dur j'ai en
tout cas j'ai conscience de la grande
chance que j'ai donc c'est pas envie de
trop en faire je pense à stéphane en
argentine qui doivent bien malheureux je
vois qu'il ya beaucoup de problèmes de
moustiques et chez toi
trentaine voilà une trentaine de degrés
c'est souvent comme contexte alors là en
beauté rare bonne dizaine de degrés il
ya une puis revigorante bref le top pour
le top comme ça après en plus tu
savoures quand l'été arrive où il était
en plus ils ignorent généralement avec
un jour trois semaines voilà ploaré ya
vraiment 06 je vais me plains de rien au
point d'avoir figure toi que fatou
à la hâte en
lien doute déjà je crois qu'une fois
j'avais dit bretonne elle m'avait
m'avait repris
mais la région je crois qu'elle est
prenante
pas mal on sera proche ouais on se
rapproche du bonheur à nantes sauf
qu'elle est partie en allemagne parce
que balla
elle trouvait qu'elle trouvait que les
allemands étaient et est plus sympa
non mais des fois je peux comprendre que
pour alex la vôtre variations
professionnel
j'ai pas dit que la bretagne
est en train de tuer en train de
complètement déconner
c'est pas mal mais on touche presque le
bonheur des doigts
non il ya beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
monde qui le dit d'ailleurs fait il fait
bon vivre et avec avec locaux vides
apparemment les gens sur 100 sont
aperçus donc
un des aspects négatifs du coc vide
aussi qu'on ne compte par le passé c'est
que voilà tout le monde s'est rendu
compte que la bretagne une belle région
de force se voir la plus belle pour ceux
qui habitent en
gros
on va revenir un peu
sage et des chats qui évidemment quel
bordel
propos ce n'est pas nous avions peur
c'est pas une estonienne où tout s'est
barré en vrille
il ya une structure d'essence tessin qui
ont réussi 6 et ce serait logique je
pense à grenoble ce week end qui vient
en d3
sega cd on va juste attendre un petit
peu d'avoir les couples nous arrive
parce que là on attend encore les coûts
qui sont chargés chez moi en tout cas
oui merci d'un torres a tout résumé
pourquoi parler d'échec quand on peut
parler de bretagne c'est vraiment
et attention il ya du breton dans le
chat en plus donc
il ya des bonnes reprises ses revenus
alors je le dis pour voir un peu donc
c'est un bien joli on a trouvé une
indienne classique au début qui a qui a
brillé
nordiste indienne classique seconde
leçon pour le récupérer avec le coût 1,5
les blancs boucle le centre avec des
cinq une fois qu'un essai c'est jouer et
chaque camp à ces ruptures f5 pour les
noirs qui arrive très vite et ses 5 pour
les blancs qui va arriver aussi dans la
partie glisse et tous les coups
classiques c'est un peu bizarre c'est le
c6 du chef go
way
chef celle qu est ce qu on appelle le
buteur ukrainien ou pas je trouve
pathétique s'assume qu il est hyper
chaud en ce moment moi je devrais je
peux faire des gros tournois des gros
actuelle à 26,55 ça sans classement fidh
et il ya quelques mois il avait même pas
26,1 et grosse progression il a que 19
ans je crois non pas mal pas mal de
champions de champion d'ukraine
et
fais attention
non il est dangereux de la carrière des
caps et hyper chaud avec le foot 15 noir
qui va être pareil voilà c'est
ok c'est intéressant c'est intéressant
alors je pense qu'on va revenir comme ça
car c'est
d'abord il ya brutale qui souhaite qu'on
agrandisse l'échiquier par rapport à
fait qu'il soit sur smartphone donc je
crois qu'ils aient c'est pas son
île et ouais enfin il se plaint
partisans comme ça ils aimeraient ils
aimeraient grand échiquier la petite
calmes on va par contre tout l'échiquier
tu peux l'agrandir c'est tourner le ton
iphone fois tonton smartphone
sur twitter tu peut agrandir ton écran
tu ne verra pas le chat s'il mais tu
peux la grande guerre alors que senna
vous tu le disais sérieusement magique
truc sénat j'ai cru que le nombre et non
pas du tout
ouais hk a fait quelque chose aussi
alors donc revenons à karlsson duda
c'est quand même la partie plus
intéressants qu'ils jouent pour le
vide ou doit il va en fait il aura fait
deux parties contre les deux de craquer
ça va être dur commence
alors du coup on vraiment pas ce qui
s'est passé parce que là on raconte des
choses on s'arrêtait à
damas quatre ans qu'il avait joué moi je
l'avais vue sur la caméra
montano cadre moins d'un requin noie le
poisson j'ai trois cavaliers à cinq
attaques c'est carry trade a prévenu ok
ils auraient pu je paie 3 aussi pour
défendre ces quatre d'après finir par
tourner un qui a coûté cette wild gratos
tour des huit cavaliers de en défense et
quatre en attaque la dame e4 on recule
et aurec trois caves à laisser si donc
la ja est-ce qu'il faut croire être une
possibilité
qui permettrait de pouvoir gagner un
pion fois j'étais petit frère mais
d'apprendre 5 avril on apprend que ça ne
marche pas
ça
qui fait mal parce qu'après d'un procès
verbal me sens soulagé geste option qui
en plus ont été fortes quoi ces
cavalières 4 non ça c'est un cauchemar
ce serait trop dur pour pour les blancs
ici il ya eu froid en justice
je porte la scène mais magnus il a
encaissé le pion
nous dit c'est déjà ça et après il va
travailler jusqu'au bout cette position
alors d'un prochain sans que c'est un
héros c'est pas obligatoire donc oui bah
il va jouer peut-être un l'est d'alger
adam g kwh an passé qu il y avait un
truc un lieu qui avait dû avaler des
quatre cavaliers des cartes je crois
qu'un des caps ouille ouille ouille
cas les dégâts furent à ce tout
petit oubli ne pas qu'ils attaquent la
qui attaquent aussi noir que s'inquiéter
tout temps pris là et surtout la case de
la case de surtout preuve cinq cavaliers
de et on se fait ramasser
alors il se passe quoi louis aliot alors
c'est la partie mais j'ai arrêté quatre
ans d'un point f3 cavale et 23 sur un an
ces faits et il faudrait cette
province est là on a pris de retard sur
la
sens pas enlever sa part de là on va pas
des conditions non plus ici
m on va pas bien monk avec vous et si ce
n'est le pion existons c'est ça la
problématique
depuis hier six tombes mais il ya comme
des pions 3 pour passer enfin surtout de
pilotage qui passait en
en fait il a trois qui ont passé non
seulement un sas a
déplacé sa mère ok les banques qui ont
passé potentiel
cbc toi c'est intéressant c'est c'est
une partie de la fin de journée pour
nous et on voit d'action passer partout
en finale mais y voit une belle
opération et vacances est ce qu'on se
dit donc toutefois f6 alors maintenant à
3 15 à 17 ans via deux pions pour
localiser deux pions cheval voilà contre
contre la tour
avait maintenant prenons je pense que
magnus c'était vraiment bien tout à
l'heure avec laon on s'envoie avoir une
belle nul
ça dépend devoir commenter 3,7 hors jeu
but on peut essayer d'avoir des idées
comme ça parce que là comment se
défendre elle faisait déjà non mais
attends si je fais être qu'après ce que
c'est pas moi qui joue pour gagner je
pense que c'est ma news qui va jouer
pour gagner quand même c'est possible
mais j'ai peur que de ton pions soit un
peu faible en trois sets pour j'évite
egypte est retombé de coeur pierre
vraiment cavaliers de deux mois après tu
me fixe un plan social
à voir comment ça en fait je pense que
les prochains mois vont être cruciaux la
votre roman importante et u14
il est des pièces copé a dit à cause
alors tu vois je crois que ça tout a
brûlé mais les pions coppens est
important enfin tout a bien raison comme
ça on n'a pas de pièce oscar et en plus
cela il ya peu de pièces est d'ailleurs
le roi doit faire partie à part entière
maintenant que la finale donc droit des
2 3 3 doit arriver un moment pour les
blancs ou recettes à propose a été
proposée par khartoum pour ramener le
roi noir laisser passer la tour des huit
leroy qui s'est caché pendant toute la
partie il sort du bois la
logique
j'aurais bien sûr c'est c'est
hyper-important fait à l'idée c'est de
activer le roi va passer les tours en
jeu vous avez causés chaque ne pas
appeler de rock et tout le temps des
fois en finale on peut sortir le roi
directement comme ça
autour des 3 maintenue s'il a envie de
travailler à sa petite finale
méchante et duda plus en difficulté tout
à l'heure
et pour l'instant pas partie des cinémas
toujours des temps est en jeu
qu'est ce que tu fais je sais que on
avait l'obligation de l'ancien cubain -
est-ce qu'on a lens maintenant revient
ou
tout à leur joie la règle tout à l'heure
en néon ces deux donc c'est bon donc on
va dire que where je pense à la simple
ses fans a été marin il a fait une pause
plus longue pendant qu'il se passait
rien et me lancer deux pubs donc c'est
bon coup de pub aujourd'hui où on va on
voit se libérer un peu la salade à la
partie il ya mon petit poulain seconde
carte scène pour pour
je crois que ça va être une terrible
désillusion
tu préférais les moments que je pense
que ça va se finir comme ça mais c'est
pas grave
on dira ce qu'il dit mais qui joue pour
la gagne si commencer les blancs en
célébrant pas ce que fera qu'un lieu de
rouennais d'euros 3 hockey chouchou
j'amène le roi et 3 je pense que les
deux joueurs que je compte la sonel
dernier je pense que les deux soient pas
plus pour le ghana
je pense que c'est une position qui se
joue pour les deux ans mais ça va
dépendre de ce fait car scène parce
qu'en fait il ya une qualité pour deux
pions et du coup bah
si
en gros si je vois là avec ses pions
barras finale hudak était plus quoi donc
alors mon argument pour dire que les
blanquetiers joue pour quelque chose
c'est que le roi j'ai plus de
possibilités d'amélioration et on voit
que que les noirs et si genève comme tu
le montre à faire ça et là mais non
pions mes pions g5 à chaque sera plus du
tout la même partie bon là je rêve un
peu d'ici là même noda pourrait jouer
des coups comme f5 messi comment se
jouer des coups comme ac 5 alors c'est
mon cavalier qui récupère braquage et 5
par exemple la 15e 5 ça peut être très
intéressant donc là on va vraiment avoir
une belle partie et pour moi il va
technicien c'est une position que leurs
dix doigts doit juger 00
j'aimerais bien techni fication de
magnus dans une position sebbar bien sûr
tu aimes tu as bien ça
[Rires]
par pur sens pédagogique évidemment bien
sûr on l'a bien compris
non mais c'est si vous allez faire
intéressant je pense que deux joueurs
ont leur chance je te rejoindre dans le
sens que j'ai pas peur n'aie pas peur je
pense que les blancs ou non on va dire
en plus de chances 2-2 d'améliorer la
position c'est vrai que jose et laurent
blanc en finale et bastille qu'est ce
qu'on va avec on va monter et en fait je
pense que si on arrive avec le roi a
activé un petit peu à s'activer un peu à
pousser un peu les plombs prendre de
l'espace avec les pions elle roy tp
pendant des banques du coup
ça pourrait peut-être pension en faveur
du déblocage presse en fait si je dois
choisir un camp je choisis les blancs
c'est pour ça que je joue exposition
ménard dont j'étais assez malin parce
que sur trois il peut y avoir des tours
prix g3 c'est pour ça que je fais bien
presque rweb de l'autre
sachant que lennon après je rends chose
achevèrent de cette position c'est ça
c'est ça des si c'est bien clairement on
espère tout moment peut-être cinq ans
comme ça moi je fais roi f2 sur war3 qui
veut manger tu as peut-être qu'il ya
toujours eu en fait je sais pas donc
comme je sais pas j'ai toujours peur
c'est de l'anti d un peu la position
cette position elle serait assez
facilement je pense nul hein oui en plus
on sait pas à chaque fois on doit trop
surveillé donc en rapide c'est mieux de
jouer la sécurité si on venait de rouen
f2 passé par troyes c'est pas un
formique si je venais montrond m26 vous
un cadre c des côtes fixation c'est
normal et au sein qui a décidé de jouer
directement ouverture des colonnes avec
la tour c'est normal aussi paravent
aussi que eux 5 eh ben ça donne des
casques ans maintenant donc pour
l'instant ça pas possible parce que je
perdrais j'ai trois mais il semble que
deux versions sur g37 une fois que je
mets le roi un voeu de où tu défends les
pions et dans un jour je pourrais être
hélas ces cases là quatre des cinq
cavaliers ça peut être intéressant en
tout cas on voit que duda qui joue à 5
jeudi la dynamique ouais mais peter van
marwijk qui joue pour gagner mais je
pense que les deux
je pense que de toute façon si je vais
pas ça et qu'arsenal améliorer
facilement comme le faisait donc il
c'est à lui de prendre une décision pour
faire quelque chose
donc story 3 vient d'être jouée j'avoue
que j'ai du mal à comprendre ce coup
parce que
ok est-ce que c'est l'idée de prendre du
cavalier par cas et des facs je pense
qu'ils le feront de la tour qui devait
tomber avant
bien sûr chris cavalli miro projet trois
noms
peut-être je suis en train de regarder
cavalière ktk et des 5 il a mangé comme
ça et après année le roi 3 et
il veut construire
il va y 20 milliards est lentement et
c'est mieux pour les blancs et je suis
sûr que c'est un pressing blanc cette
position c'est pas si facile pour l'aude
à médiouna il a très bien joué des six
le 5 la très très très bien conquis la
police mais ils nous regardent les joies
il nous régale parce que ce festival on
comprend une fois qu'on a vu des coups
mais c'est dur de les trouver en si peu
de temps franchement c'est clair nous on
est assez loin tranquille sur le canapé
enfin
c'est sûr que
non
en fait nous on est tranquille on
commente on parle on ordinateur qui nous
aident enfin c'est facile mais pour eux
ben ils ont pas des depuis c'est
difficile et il joue de manière
extraordinaire quasiment tous les coups
de l'ordinateur et trouvent des défenses
et de partout c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment voiliers qui pour rappel non
peut dire une bêtise au pire on se marre
elles perdent la partie donc c'est
surtout sa grande différence aussi
au cash il nous dit karmani c3 cavale
des 5 oui oui on va tout va 3 c'est
juste pour pour stabiliser la structure
déjà comme on l'a dit avec la ville et
au f4
damas et il a passé le point m 2
maintenant que le roi tu as raison f2 le
pion et défendu alors je peux toujours
pas sa cavale c3 je pense mais
non également il va aussi remanié au
vélo il va falloir qu'il est avec qu'ils
améliorent alors peut-être joueurs f5
souhaite travailler à cavaler la 4e il
était alors manger rené lecavalier ici
révèle hélas on va voir un peu comment
ça va se passer alors mans je suis pas
fana sont importants parce que je
l'impression que les noirs pourraient
manger un petit ninja ftf 4e 5 c'est
logique un caschili m5 parce que on
arrive furnal cavale c'est normal il
faut faire il faut faire gaffe ram ne
faut pas se prendre le cas tu es un
problème angers 3 ou 4 3 mais chevaux au
tempo presse à ça le fait
f5 droit et justice qu'elle et ses 3 e 4
à gré des demandes l'euro 1,5
et le 4c pour imposer un problème sur la
tour alors doté de touches 17 mai qui a
pas l'air la pâleur
il a pas l'air confiant un bouddha et
galère un peu c'est qu'il fasse aux
flèches et précis un essai bien c'est
que ce
jeu c'est qu'un abandon chat qui
qui ont mis
qui a envie que c'était duda qui est
joué pour le gain que c'était joli je
crois pas je crois qu'il essayait de
jouer dynamique pour pas perdre cette
position de manière de manière lente
c'est surtout cela et du coût
caché des remarques intéressantes un
cache ce qu'ils proposent c'est plutôt
pas mal
f5 3,3 et peut-être tour f4
en cas de 4 lorsque c'est ça ce n'était
pas facile à jouer cette position avec
un vague et noir
auquel cacher tu fais avec 5.3 et après
cavaliers cette fois tu veux faire pour
éviter sans doute
sans doute
les cartes
tac ouais
il n'ya plus que bart becks l'isf et qui
se fait modérées les autres aussi un
tout le monde peut faire modérer vous
parler correctement c'est toujours bien
le droit
il faut
rigoler mais rester respectueux voilà
c'est juste ça
neuf
tentes et wii pikachû s'ils avaient
vraiment dit haut débit ce mode le
véhicule à leur respect comme d'habitude
et nous racontera drobo barbe comme ça
mais non il y en avait vraiment parlé
donc il nous en a parlé en même temps
récemment à poussan tu auras fallait
vraiment idée super résultat après a
gagné et sid geste par exemple c'est pas
pareil que la chine a dit mme marois
mais c'est quand même quelque chose de
et d'autres bons on est resté sur grand
format alors qu'est-ce qu'on a eu on a
eu droit à quoi est-ce qu'on passe droit
alors un très rapidement faire un petit
tour à y avoir juste en 30 secondes
fillon ses propositions ouais c'est
complètement dingue c'est un très gros
bordel je prends rien 6 passes mais le
roi alors je vais dire ce que j'en pense
après tu vas me dire oui c'est parce que
non non je te dis vraiment ces femmes ce
que je pense c'est comme il a son rond
en danger je vous dis que c'est comme
dangereux cette position et je préfère
la position de l'ukrainien et c'est pas
orientés par rapport à ton poulain quoi
que ce soit non mais c'est vrai que en
pratique ça là quand même en pratique
c'est la dure pour très dur même pour
des bornes après sans calculer on arrive
comme ça sur une position on n'a pas ça
avant mais compliqué on va être
compliqué
nakazawa tanaka
makan très bonne position 1 je pense que
web et là il doit être le roi le roi de
feydeau cfc c'est terminé parce qu'en
fait mon coup droit et en sécurité j'ai
une grillade moi mais j'ai récupéré tous
les pions
est vraiment j'ai aucun problème après
j'ai pas encore trouvé avec roy g7
cavaliers gso même dire ça la rechange
quand même des dates damage fuite etc
mais bon sang sûr que les amants je
l'avais annoncé qu'ils allaient gagner
je pense sans problème parce que c'est
vraiment sa bête noire le bas tout le
temps
qu'elle vient ou alors là il s'est passé
plein de choses août orange et si c'est
ce qu'elle fout la soupe rase et de
peut-être pas eu le choix mais je suis
peut-être encore
pris en effet mes droits sont faibles
mais on sait qu'on sait pas lequel des
rois est le plus faible peut-être
laurent blanc quand même parce que m6
l'idée c'est aussi sans doute les ânes
on ne peut pas vamos isaf six tours
détours des six d'abord
qui la fissure déficit un peu longuette
un tas de conseils par échec de son île
après je me garde d'un concept 3 quand
il le faut non je pense maxime marty est
haute et maxime il est mieux valait
mieux il va il va réussir et la petit
fille aux attentes on est pour la ville
et pour voir la dépouille dans la foulée
pour une étoile je gagnais au nom leur
grosse partie
il ya la peau qui a gagné bon je pense
que l'ase expéditif je pense qu'il avait
quand même un beau d'appariement enfin
enquête sur est très fort garayev une
arme il a fait un sacrifice de d'armes
quand même un compte de tout compte deux
tours
ocarina et riber est ce qu'on peut voir
rapidement très très vite
ferrou avant de se serait très très dur
de voir les roues et duda craquer aïe
aïe aïe on en a parlé de de cette
hypothèse de voir tes deux points craqué
sur cette dernière ronde 2ème jour
arrête
et je veux pas je peux pas je me fâche
on a beaucoup de parties ouvertes
et vous qui sont vos bêtes noires ou
c'est pas sympa ça
enfin tout fatou les bêtes noires c'est
toujours des joueurs qu un plus fort que
moi mais j'ai deux joueurs français qui
me réussissent très mal ou qui sont pas
les derniers de la classe non plus mais
c'est en bouche y est et christian bauer
puisque j'ai des bons résultats contre
les plus forts que moi en règle générale
parmi les joueurs français je suis
positif contre quand même quelques
grands maîtres ce qui est plutôt bien
mais par contre christian bauer est en
dessous chics 3-0 chacun mais pas pour
moi pour donc c'est pas terrible amstar
mais sont de supers joueurs pour autant
mais ça se passe mal ces joueurs là
voilà voilà
et toi tout fait ce que tu as trouvé
telle bête noire ben moi tome va donc
mieux
pourquoi on parle de 5 le monde
échiquéen et noir pour alors fac ou modo
c'est ma bête noire en puzzle rush sur
la scam ça c'est clair je perds à moi je
pars tout le temps juste
et non je pense que j'avais près 50 50
pour être
au alors là c'est chaud est ce que il
n'est pas foutu duda j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont quand même pasqua la
province je peux pas tout ramassé tu
prends une bonne pioche mais là ça va
faire 4 pions c'est de m'amuser c'est
bien compté 1 et oui et oui ton et
parlait en fait souffler les trois clubs
passé mais c'était pas du bon côté mais
dont il est passé et que tu les
avais vus en avant sur presque
il faut vraiment être là ils vont
vraiment un art détroit bien passé si si
les perses à la crise bien que né pauvre
passe devant duda avant la bonne heure
là dans la journée
son arrivée en avril 5
6 7 6 après
je trouvais qu'il avait très bien joué
douze grains et regardez c'est corrélée
avec le fait qu'il n'ait plus de temps
en fait il a commencé à déconner et
quand il ya une prétendue tout
voilà ça fera avec le passé mais point
trop 4 contre 1 ici est un peu passé ici
ça va être trop difficile y a pas de
menace sur le roi blanc qui est vraiment
qui est un poste dans le 3d voilà
légier c'est terminé je pense que je
pense qu'on va voir d'où dapper cette
partie c'est sûr
yaye fatou qui a dit un truc marrant je
sais pas si tu dois modéré à opérateurs
quoi j'ai passé six à ce que je te
laisse regarder je suis à se découvrir
après des commentaires très dur de palau
mais ok c'est moi qui lui ai dit que je
sais bien je suis déçu mais l'allemand
elle a bien rebondi elle a bien rebondi
dessus quand même hein
après
the beast je verrai bien fatou faire une
bataille de puzzle hausse avec avec
indochine bauer je trouve cet éclair
surtout bauer je pense qu'il est chaud
aux fesses de lörrach en fait christian
c'est vraiment le genre de joueur fait
une douche il ya peut-être moyen de
l'avoir et
mais christian c'est le genre de joueur
j'aimerais pas vraiment très créatif si
vous voulez en bois j'adore ce joueur
est par contre j'adore enfin je suis
toujours content de jouer contre lui
mais à chaque fois après une fois que j
y suis dans la partie en moins il ya un
moment où j'aime moins tu vois ça se
passe moi ça va voir aussi entrepris son
bord jeu deux fois j'ai fait ça fait 1 2
me sur 12 je passe pas tant la rue et la
partie que je perds la rend plus heureux
tout pas dû la perdre a dit me -10 1
demi et moi c'est pas mal et la bassée
avec toi écrite à la main annoncé blanc
aéro mise à jour deux fois qu'on lui a
aidé ni mal non une petite nul une
petite bulle blanche est un peu déçu tu
pensais qu'avec deux fois on est capable
de bonnes mains ce cadre
[Rires]
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
c'est la fin là c'est la fin là il a
quand même trois pions de moi
ça va être un moment quelques
sur la caméra y'a plus personne ne
sait s'il joue à si si j'ai cru et nous
montre une fausse caméras sur le et
j'écris
je me suis laissée franchissait avoir
tué à ses preuves que je n'y crois plus
pour bouddha on va bientôt aller voir
nos joueurs font c'est qu'ils vont
bientôt devenir un
prime time le téléphone devient en scène
très sonné la déconnexion on l'attend un
truc comme ça l'un
à oui ben là quand je trouve qu'on est
réduit à jouer le téléphone pour sauver
son poulain
si tu veux on peut même aller on peut me
m'avait maxeda fait nul
à hilla nuls merci berline qui je suis
en a qui nous aident à chaque fois on
est actif que tu as donc c'est encore
une grosse partie de bush et celle là on
va pas tout vu mais et tous poulains
alireza qu'est ce qui donne parce que
finalement ça c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour moi je suis un peu
chiant
un don qu'a dit résorber le voir un peu
vert donc aqsiq a fait nul et alireza
qui a calé blanc étaient en train de
pousser un il a mangé le pion à et va
troquer le pion b contre le pion à et
après il a un trou de plus de pions à
avoir s'ils arrivent à la gagner alors
moi je comprends jamais rien ces finales
en occupions avec le pion de plus on a
bien le roi blanc il a passé donc
j'aurais tendance à dire qui va gagner
peut-être
le roy on va pouvoir le mettre en fait
roi f3 g3 wife 4 en 1 un mousse jusqu'en
à 6 non mais là ça doit être gagnant
très important d'avoir la tour qui
bloque le roi aussi un battant qui coupe
le roi mais n'en a plus qu'à monter le
roi essayer de créer un réseau de maths
ou monter droite qui manque pas armé
attend là bas
on emménage avait pas vu l'évolution de
la position d'un coup et
on pouvait se passer des choses et du
coup si je fais rouages et 3 je suis
trop j'ai droit chf 8
et j'attends là vous enragez vie trois
chiffres je ne vois pas le bien moi je
suis coincé
karlsson a terminé personne a gagné 1 ça
y est on est on est on est sur la fin on
voyait fin de set de ce deuxième jour
demain il y aura le dénouement du
championnat rapide grosse victoire de 40
celle qui renvoie ses études jan
christoph duda
ça fait bien plaisir cette petite
victoire puisque né peau come back donné
pour qui vient faire mal et attention
bad urgent bava s'avère difficile aussi
contre gries tchouk
effectivement rapidement
rappelé tout à l'heure sa position à
deux résultats là ça va ça va arriver et
ketchup qui
avait quand même trois pions pour la
tour avec deux pions face au champion en
b la croix ici et etb2 ça a l'air a fini
un
aria niayes
salars traiteur pourquoi avoir donc
ritsu qui va être en tête tout seul avec
quatre semaines et 2 jours sont déjà
joueurs
mais j'ai toujours envie de célébrer
impressionnant voire
on avait dire le premier jour on avait
dire que penser qu' on ne voyait pas
gagner encore un championnat du monde et
bien figure toi qui est encore là il
encore en tête avec 40 scène
au bout de deux années évidemment comme
il n'a pas sévi mais ce qui est
impressionnant c'est pourquoi ya eu
des marques nuls à
répétition et se passe quoi s'il fait ça
y est donc
l'endroit des deux il ya peut-être tour
c6
en fait il y avait un gamin regarde
c'est magnifique il y avait trois des
trois qui étaient proposés c'est andy
qui l'a proposé et regarde maintenant la
différence
ah non ça ne marche pas non plus je
pensais qu'ils allaient tous ces six
baies 5
tombé 6 3 s'écarte c'était pour moi le
c'est joli non en plus
ils sont peu de temps là-bas en vidant
c'est très dur de voir que ça mais
effectivement je la garde des trois
camps fermés au revoir c'est surtout la
c3 détroit tu peux peut-être faire trop
d un mais voilà du coup il voit ses deux
tours des six maintenant
ok voilà donc ça marchait pas c'est un
petit piège
il a trouvé six en fait si ce fait
d'armes pour montrer aux gens et ben en
fait j'ai un point de plus mais mme roy
est trop loin et maintenant c'est lui
qui va venir manger ne purent en premier
la faire attention en fait chacun mange
tous les pions en fait je crois que ça
tombe pile ok donc à cette seule en tête
ont du coup on voit revenir son fils
rosas comme la partie et je me revois
bravo franchement je ma main et fait
plaisir mais franchement je bave
invaincu je crois pour l'instant
où il va il a gagné sept fois un enjeu
alors ils répondent ils à tours oui
elle est toujours assez profonde ins est
ok
mais il va gagner maintenant le roi est
trop loin
dû être coupée machin dessin moment de
manger ici et faire une petite mais au
début de la finale ça me paraissait nul
samedi la finale non ça me paraissait
gagnant puis après nul suffisait pas il
eu des choses billets les bizarreries
cette finale qui nous rappelle un petit
peu la finale qui aurait pu se produire
compte enfin très embêtant parce que
parce que malheureusement pour moi ça
veut dire que les raisins il prend on
est content pour les français fassent
mentir mais c'est vrai que maxime il a
fait une petit nul et alireza va faire
une belle victoire et du coup c'est un
en avant sur un de plus
ben là on a maxime qu'il ya comme un
département je regardais alors alerté la
cinquième à voir à partir et maxime
qu'un sac est complètement donc si fil
rouge agathe est parti il aura un peu en
avance sur maxime avec quatre parties à
venir alors que de l'autre côté on va
voir que duda qui a perdu sa partie aura
un demi point de moins que
les peaux qui a 7 mai les pots vases
carlsen
voir ce qui se passe mais en tout cas un
miroitement c'est pas grand chose il
peut se passer par des choses
alors attends est ce que vraiment
furieuse l'a vraiment eu un
début ce qu'on en voit ce qu'il a fait
en fait campagne ces présents bizarre
c'est quand même un salon dont l'or sur
5 km par an pour g8
la caméra
serait super salut à toi enfin tous nous
voir rester à regarder
on va essayer de voir s'il techni fils
là mais je crois pas au début ça passait
déjà droit ces salaires dans la
je pars me ranger cette année après ce
fait ça
vaquez dire c'est que je mets mon roi
ici serait échec ce n'est pas peur parce
que j'ai ça ce retour g8 comment je
gagne par contre
c'est quand même pas s'effacer d'un
techniquement c'est au tour f4 qui
paraît simple geste mais faut calculer
un peu tout ça en dérange échec sur
voila j'ai bon après ça avait finalement
sauvé la gagne en prêt
merci pas demain et on se voit demain
s'il va vendre à partir de 15h pour tous
ceux qui veulent
il ya la main mais c'est une des
mouvements en plus avec la quarantaine
de gares agri tchouk hyper fort et nos
joueurs français on espère qu'ils vont
finir comme des boulets de canon surtout
ils viennent parce que c'est un peu rude
pour lui bon alireza
donc demain 15 heures la garde demain 15
heures c'est comme aujourd'hui un 15h20
heure à peu près mais finalement déjà on
voit quand même que 45 green shoots
nepos avait enfin est ce qu'il y aura un
champion du monde parmi eux sans doute
un quart de scène créé tout dépôt bah
franchement je m'en fous moi moi car
c'est des choses moins 47 et
impressionne beaucoup dans ce danseur
dans ce mois mais gichuki il a été hyper
fort aussi bien sûr en fait moi c'est la
qualité des parties car c'est tellement
propre que oui on excusera
m'impressionne beaucoup plus que
celui de souk à prier tous bien sûr il
fait un super tournoi c'est monstrueux
mais après qui sait qu'il va s'y coller
pour aller chercher 40 cents et home
depot 1
baisse que demain on va avoir 15 ans et
9 ans ce serait beau que dépôts viennent
dit à l'abattre 15 c'est donc là alors
attends je veux ma barbe blanche qui
vient de monter tout en haut
alors que la
6ème à trouver
je comprends vraiment pas oui 7/3 6-3
cause dans la sphère du moteur
oui vous voyez un peu de temps mais il
va gagner je pense sur les yeux
peut-être si ce tournoi se passe quoi
ces matches on essaie d'avoir
en route pour l'instant tant que ce
n'est pas fini il n'y a pas de tableau
final malheureusement pour toi il ya un
tableau intermédiaire quand la ronde est
finie on vous donc pas vous montrer le
classement pour la barre des 3
ce qu'on veut avoir c'est le coin en
huitième devant un pion ce qu'on appelle
la position dite de lucciana pour ceux
qui connaissent et du coup ils en train
de travailler pour son roi passe devant
le client vous et accompagne le pion
jusqu'à d'armes mais c'est pas si facile
quand ils reculent
la dernière partie ça fait deux fois
qu'il aurait pu gagner apparemment que
le rouage 6 1 information on l'a plutôt
leurs deux fois mais là du coup
n'a pas cru si la cause de ce que tu as
montré d'éloigner la tour si tu veux
ouais je veux leur montrer encore une
fois tout à l'heure dans la finale il
aurait pu gagner ici avec 3h 6 et ça
gagner parce qu'on va être sur 3,5 ici
je peux je tour 1,4 et en fait il n'y a
pas moyen de pouvoir approcher son roi
parce que sur walf catch pg5 surtout
reprend j'ai 5 g fameux tour échecs ses
droits par là où je prends la torre se
rode descend je fais échec en finale il
s'occupe à la bourre et du coup on fait
qu'il a pas moyen pour ça et donc si on
va avancer sur échec 0 à l'aller surtout
rachid chihab g7 qui est important à
l'entrée et maintenant j'ai 5 g/j si on
a nos droits devant qui ont encore nous
voulait et là on va pouvoir travailler
la saga position sans problème sur échec
je veux faire des petits échecs à
n'importe quel moment si on remonte
devant je te pousse et ça ça va gagner
du temps et en fait je pense c'est cela
raté un deux fois il a raté va revenir
un parti et ça a fait nul on voit que ça
a fait mieux on va revenir donc
chirurgien qui va s'en mordre les doigts
qui aurait pu gagner plusieurs faisait
de finale iroise 5 cela faire trop fade
ème position je pense que lui avoir
imputé nationale aura de la part du
joueur ukrainien non mais parce défense
en mai mais ouais mais c'est étonnant
parce que phil rogers vont aller très
fort on l'a vu lé chantier peut être
étonné parce que c'est pour un joueur de
ce niveau là des joueurs comme nous très
facilement qu'ailleurs mais ils sont
peut-être fatigués aussi ses fans je
sais pas mais ça vous regarde et on sait
que ça joue encore en fait ok je pense
que j'ai compris l'ordinateur il a donné
match nul c'est une retransmission et
l'ordinateur a pu voir qu'enfin 2ème
position et c'est pour ça que l'orateur
marque match nul en bas comme moi je
vois mon abonnement mais du coup et a
trouvé warchi spectacle mais du coup
jouent tour à 4
bon je sais pas il ya trouvé non en tout
cas y'a marqué match nul mais la partie
elles jouent ils devaient d'abord 3/4 de
jeu là
bas alors c'est bien c'est gagné
d'ailleurs comprends pas trop
c'est gagner je pense parce que si je
savais
alors oui oui je le pilotage toujours en
argentine je suis encore enfin pour un
petit moment quelques bruits courent ici
vous savez c'est le ce qu'on avait ce
qu'on avait dix roues un schisme va voir
quel va être le résultat annoncé pour
l'instant il n'y a pas le résultat en la
barre
ouais ça joue à la fois sage ou encore
remarqué matches nuls en battant fin
quand je le vois encore écrit en bas si
sage ou encore ses membres âgés certes
il a trouvé
fierro c'est pour ça que c'est détonnant
qui trouve pas parce que pour quelqu'un
de son âge au temps mauvais temps tel
numéro deux mondial tu connais tu es
censé connaître cette mouture h4 c'est
le coût que pratique que j'avais envie
de jouer leur tour eiffel on peut juste
faire un chèque g5 un g6 pack terminée
et sur wais ci se faisait saint ghislain
on a engrangé 6 au pire
je vois je la croisais si c'est
apprendre un petit échec et on revient
faire le sketch à groix g7 droit il va
réussir mon regret c'est ça bref si
c'est mieux encore pardon c'est pas un
effectivement
aux caisses et ses films locaux ok ça me
ça me remonte le moral
ouais ça mon moral de ses fans et en
plus c'est plus dans la logique des
choses que je n'ai pas trop à comprendre
on n'aime pas trop dire que le mec hyper
fort avec quelque chose ça fait un peu
voir mais pour nous c'était anormal
parce que c'était facile pour qui roule
déjà et pour pas mal de joueurs
systémique que ça disons que nous on
peut là on peut ne pas la gagner parce
qu'on est quand même une fois non mais
non mais non
en fait si tu veux normandin niveau pour
s'en mêler mais qu' ils sont stables et
nous en deux temps crise de temps on
perd cette stabilité alors que les mecs
comme fil rouge à l'écran mettre en
règle générale sont beaucoup plus stable
et finissent le boulot et ils ont un
très bon niveau technique soit très bon
bagage technique ce qui leur permet
aussi de de finir avec plus de fiabilité
alors il va pousser chaque chaîne qu
jusque jusqu'au lucciana mais en même
temps c'est bien pour pour vous vous
allez voir comment fois qu'il va la
jouer jusqu'au bout
parce que hockey avant il va attendre un
peu il va jouer
sa mort ils veulent plonger à rené qu'il
faut accompagner le pion c'est ce qui
est en train de se passer avec le roi et
un mois pour extraire le roi parce que
l'europe va gêner le pion au début on
n'attaque pas le roi aide et ensuite il
gêne donc on va le ressortir qu'ils
allaient voir il est parti pour faire un
live a jugé ce s est pas ce qu'il dit
veut pousser psion est du coup les gens
vont attendre leur tour en argent et
parce qu'ils avaient l'habitude
d'attendre je te l'exacte non mais après
on va mais là la tour en e1 faire et
chaque pour pouvoir extraire notre roi
somme à djabla la première je veux
retenir et à je vais forcer le roi à
partir de cette ligne attend que son
tour ou un échec si je vais leur en être
si je perds directement un coup droit et
fuite et le pion ira d'adobe air forcé
sur les malades l'europe devra partir
sur la colonne d
maintenant ça va être la deuxième étape
parce qu'on va vouloir extraire notre
roi une fois qu'on aura
éloigner le roi noir mais si on
l'extrait directement va se prendre
plein dé chaque avec la tour adverse
donc c'est là qu'on appelle cela du pont
du sénat ou du bouclier comme vous
voulez mais vous qui y est c'est
peut-être plus simple c'est à dire que
on va poster de notre tour va d'ailleurs
normalement sur la quatrième rangée
parce que là il va pas rester en il va
descendre un moment deuxième rangée mais
bon normalement en la postant en 4e
rangée cette tour blanche pour qu'elle
aille en cas de sortie de notre roi
quand on se prend plein d'échec m un
bouclier en place ce serait plus parlant
mais là on peut pas le faire j'imagine
parce que les joueurs ont joué des coups
mais sinon vous aurez montré après
notamment la notre tour voilà il ya eu
abandon est vraiment dans une amie roi
ici avant abandon parce qu en fait d'un
jeu mais roy ici jamais jeu pour
acheminer ses seins c'est
imparable donc voilà donc juste pour
l'idée en fait
si la tour avec 1 h déjà parce que l'on
verra si la tourelle
voilà prend place 3 3 voilà là ça très
bien le courage froid par exemple et sec
voila voila je l'expliqué
et là maintenant on va faire un petit
tour 4 pour prévoir la sortie de notre
roi tout simplement c'est à dire qu'on a
une manoeuvre maintenant de sortie droit
qu'on va se prendre échec et chaque
échec échec des fairways set je me
prends tous rêvent trois échecs je vais
aller ranger du tour j'ai trois égéries
passe ses jours au fc est un acte
croyait cette menace dame
donc les noirs doivent réagir 26 feria
je fais des échecs à mort pour embêter
pour embêter stéphane donc el-cheikh 3
et 6 échecs si je quitte le pion bas je
le perds donc je dois attendre et là je
continue et sec est en fait je peux pas
partir parce que
toujours mon client en prise d'arrêter
la défense devront donc en fait ça ne
gagne pas dans cette position regardez
bien la position que mon stéphane parce
que si notre tour avait été en 4e rangée
comme on vous en faisait part
précédemment là on aurait le coutour g4
du bouclier c'est pour ça qu'on anticipe
la sortie notre roue en mettant tout en
4e rangée et la convainc fuir avec notre
roi et qu'on va se prendre la série
d'échecs à un moment on peut mettre le
bouclier en place et
gagné n'a pas donc c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'y du très bon coup c'est de faire tour
4 en prophylaxie c'est le couple est un
autre dossier de ses positions par
exemple si j'attends et ben maintenant
je peux le roi accepte menace dame comme
tout à l'heure sur échec je viens angers
6 sur un sec je viens à f 6 donc la même
menace maintenant c'est de faire touré 5
et 3 5 le petit pont mais si les noirs
font de même pour être froid je pourrais
je crois g5 et maintenant la tour
peuvent pas venir en f1 parce que j'ai
fait mon clan qui va manger le menace
dames il n'y aura pas d' enfilade parce
que maintenant on peut toujours venir
angers 4 et surtout rejet des quatre
tours de trois échecs tour g4 et même
les changes de tours ne faudra pas ce
que le roman est trop loin et la page
internet la dame en fait révision d'une
petite finale classique
alors niveau en terme de niveau c'est la
tranche 14 17 sens qu'il faut connaître
déjà cela
ça c'est ça c'est la base c'est la base
des finales de tout le tour attaqué la
règle de lucciana et de et du de
philidor donc donc ça c'est vraiment une
règle importante à connaître il faut que
d'être 50 jours des clubs c'est la base
communs dit stéphane et je suis bien
d'accord avec lui et est ce qu on fait
un petit tour sur le classement je t'ai
pas on voit un petit peu à la fin je
vais vous mettre le classement
maintenant ça va être de marbre et de la
leur ouais maintenant qu'on a terminé
avec
le truc je vais vous mettre un peu plus
grand puis c'est le voir après je me
remets ça ruth kindy belle finale n'est
pas encore son niveau n'hésite pas à
regarder par exemple le replay parce que
là avec stefan hula fait vraiment
énormément de fois alors c'est sûr c'est
facile pour nous quand on n'explique pas
de problème mais si c'est la première
fois que vous voyez ce type de finale
bat il faut répéter répéter répéter ya
pas le choix il faut que ça rentre
beaucoup avec cette aide mais sur sur
neuf du court donc tu vois cette
émission neuf sacs à main un score
stratosphérique 1 quand même tu vois
carte scène en première place et tu vois
le petit poulain de piques à thiès avec
sept sur neuf qui en deuxième position
de renée paule riccio au départage donc
c'est la chine qui est déjà
la star jusqu'à la fameuse wii
l'équipe là mais clermont perd
franchement il a précédent donc n'a qu'à
en embuscade comme un accord en
embuscade avec doug drabek jo baba qui
ont bien animé vont de forrest est
toujours là
fear hodja caruana qu'on n'a pas trop vu
il ya g du monde à 6 et le la main
en embuscade donc carlson qui gagne tu
t'avances bon tu encore très confortable
mais commence à prendre un petit peu
d'avancé
je pense qu'on va avoir un petit quart
scène n'est pas là quand même
ça m'étonnerait parce que ce serait
logique après ça va dépendre des
couleurs parce que du coup je crois que
les progressions sont pas eux non plus
et cette europe n'est pas qu'il a à
jouer mais mais mais avoir en tout cas
ça va être intéressant moi j'aimerais
bien avoir un petit à petit car ce n est
pas un oui mais il n'est pas qu'un
simple plutôt non ce serait de l'epo 47
en époux ils venaient à voir ils veulent
gagner avec les noirs et caravanes
avaient les blancs et bien c'est fait le
mien ces dépôts car c'est le mot juste
et absout times parce que tout ce qu'il
a vécu avec les couleurs abdou cette
europe est un petit gris tchouk là mais
c'est quoi des couleurs en fait ça ce
que ça colle ouailles bassong riccio
qu'il a déjà joué
il avait renoncé soi n'est pas au camp
cents soit 12,7 europcar en scène
jake hanson est critiquable et noir et
aux autoroutes je ne trouve pas la
touche la ratez
pas trop de drapeaux
ouzbek général ham c'est pas lui qui
nous gâche pas
le droit il à votre deuxième au
classement il a besoin il est en planque
il en planque cefic hachey ce qui à mon
avis a planqué son poulain haye leïla et
use d'accord et donc du coup il vient
d'avoir les noirs aussi donc du cou noir
noir
d'avoir un trio riquet au plus fort et
l'eau normalement après il ya plein
d'autres aucun scène il va avoir les il
va avoir les noirs il a eu des blancs
donc logiquement vu qu'il a des
greenshows qui va demander un des deux
il prend plus gros lots normalement sait
qu'arsène dépôt
si oui si l'histoire n'a pas encore joué
écrit tout fin ce qui est mon niveau car
senna ou précise n'est pas qu'un ancien
il a envie de coller les noirs un dépôt
stéphane connaît
mais on est en train là pour l'instant
stéphanie n'a pris une grosse grosse
option sur le pari des français je dois
bien avouer que y en ait un nouvel de
gala quatre sur quatre pour sa passe
et ça paraît
mal barré
donc cette adoption et j'ai une toute
petite option mais c'est pas facile
parce que l'époque on arrive à jouer
tout en haut ça a peut-être permettre à
deux doigts de se refaire il est en
groupe des six et demi raingeard eu
envie de dire c'est un groupe plus
tendres mais quand je regarde les grands
noms du groupe de six et demi non ce
sera dur aussi pour du nord j'ai une
toute petite option mais c'est vraiment
pas grand chose alors que stéphane a une
grosse option sur le pari des français
et on peut même alireza il est encore
candidat à la victoire finale donc il va
être hyper motivés alors que la nouvelle
bas il faut qu'ils fassent ça un truc
comme quatre sur quatre en tout cas
incroyable où trois et demi s'il veut
revenir la rentrée des questions ça va
être ça va être hyper intéressant est en
tout cas grâce à 80 donc demain à 15
heures jusqu'à 20 heures on encore 4
euros exact mais ça c'est pas de huit
ans parce que nous avons quand même
vachement de joueurs qui peuvent revenir
tu vois on rompt la foule à sydney puis
les cadres ohana on a quatre on a un
haka mouras s'est mis aussi est bon bien
sûr toujours devant silence est encore
un sexe à un emploi c'est c'est vraiment
ouais c'est vraiment des parties de
qualité que l'on voit c'est hyper
présent a commenté stéphane votre égal
bien franchement pour nous c'est facile
le spectacle est présent il ya beaucoup
de parties où on s'intéresse aux
meilleurs joueurs et franchement c'est
très qualitatif et demain il y aura du
suspense avec les petites caméras comme
on l'a vu des petites choses comme grid
choc en scène va bien rigoler
yes donc du coup les gens merci beaucoup
à tous d'avoir suivi d'abord celui de
stream donc demain on sera
on sera de nouveau là avec avec kevin à
partir de 15 heures donc ne ratez pas le
dernier sprint final geek et voilà et
donc demain 15h 20h pour pouvoir en
le dédoublement de ce tournage sur place
du monde parties rapides donc merci
encore kevin merci à tous et merci à toi
stéphane c'est un vrai plaisir de faire
cela avec toi puis on se revoit demain
15 heures sans faute pour la fin du
championnat du monde deux parties
rapides avec quatre scènes et compagnie
yes merci à tous